Previously on Mobamex Ich bin hier noch mal herausgeeilt worden. Ich soll Ihnen einige meiner kleinen Gedichte noch vortragen.
Herzlich willkommen wieder auf unsere Hörer in der Schweiz und Österreich.
Die Leute mit den weißen Westen kommen gleich.
Ist überhaupt eigentlich irgendwas passiert?
Mein Kopfhörer explodiert.
Gleich zum Anfang von Mobamex, heute gleich mal.
Der richtig langweilige Teil.
Das ist natürlich echt geil.
Sag mal, wenn ihr Tim sagt die ganze Zeit und Tim hat es nicht raus, das macht diesen Podcast ja auch aus.
Nee, Apple und Software, das könnt ihr nicht.
Das wiederhole ich. Die Daten waren eigentlich noch nicht im Ansatz verstanden, aus welchem Samsung-Produkt das durchstanden ist. Die werden sich ja die Zwischenstände von Mobamex durchsagen. Leider bin ich immer noch mit demselben Team geschlagen.
Hat doch bestimmt bei den Fanboys gehört.
Völlig verstört.
Tim rantet auch schon auf dem letzten Loch. Also meine Freundin war am Wochenende im Stadion und ich habe so lange gekocht.
Willkommen bei Bum Zag Return.
Ja, heute nun, also wir können uns, also die Wikipedia hat ja verschiedene, also da ist ja eine sehr lange Liste von First Form, ja also wir könnten uns da einigen, ob wir jetzt die Sendung im Stab reimen oder im Schüttel reimen, ja oder generell einfach im Dreivierteltakt machen.
Jambus.
Hört man mich?
Mich hört man glaub ich nicht.
Der Reim ist fett.
Mich hört man nicht.
Fette Beats, fette Reime hier.
Dich hört man nicht?
Mich hört man dann glaube ich nur leise.
Doch, man hört dich aber nicht gut.
Ich hör dich.
Sag mal weiter.
Ich sitze ja auch neben dir.
Du hörst dich nicht meinst du?
Du musst auch in Reimen sprechen.
Ich muss auch in Reimen sprechen.
So, was ist denn dein Problem?
Das Mikro, das lässt sich nicht hören, denn ich bin... Also ich höre mich auf jeden Fall nicht.
Aber wir hören dich.
Ihr hört mich?
Ja. Und du hörst uns.
Ich höre euch ja.
Ja, ist ja ein dolles Ding.
Magie.
Jetzt dreht Tim wieder den Knöpfen und gleich geht es wieder gar nichts. Also entfandt euch nochmal eine Runde.
Ah, jetzt höre ich mich.
Das war das Wunder des nicht eingeschalteten Expandas. Na du warst ja hier Tonprobe nicht da.
Nee, war ich nicht.
Drum, drumstens. So, wie auch immer, jetzt scheint ja die erste Aufregung hat sich gelegt und wir können ja auch einsteigen. Denn es ist Mobile Max, wir schreiben das Jahr 87. 87. Ausgabe. Für mich ist es immer zwischen zwei Wochen. Mobile Max ist für mich immer wie ein Jahr. Frühling, Sommer, Herbst und Winter ist einmal komplett durch.
Dafür passiert aber ja schon nicht wenig überhaupt.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber wir sind ja auch schon 87, da nimmt man dann das Leben auch anders wahr. Ich bin nicht mit Folge 1 überrascht. Wenn wir alle 13 wären, wäre das wahrscheinlich total aufregend.
Total aufregend?
Aber irgendwie diese Macintosh News Lage haut einem auch irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr vom Hocker, oder?
Vielleicht sollten wir sagen, was im Jahr 87 gerade neu war.
Wir sollten mal mehr über Erlangen Regen, da hab ich so das Gefühl, da ich dir die Show Notes der letzten Sendung anschaue. Aber ich hab ja auch die letzten Tage mich noch versucht, auf die Sendung vorzubereiten und hab meinen RSS-Reader aufgemacht.
Moment, Moment.
Sogar gelesen?
Moment, das Ding ist, ich benutze ja, war ja früher mal ein großer RSS-Freund, jetzt hab ich bestimmt monatlang meinen RSS-Reader nicht mehr aufgemacht und dachte, okay, ein Füllhorn von Apple News wird mich empfangen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Apple Insider, Mac Rumors, Mac Stories, auf John Gruber, ich hab's ja alle gelesen.
Und was war?
Crickets und Tumbleweed.
Und der Gruber auch?
Nur über irgendwelche anderen Leute, andere Firmen, irgendwelche jada jada hier eine neue Zahl.
Ja, ich prangere das auch an, weil am Ende müssen wir hier selber noch die Arbeit machen.
Aber der Gruber, der hat hier so eine... Ihr müsst jetzt so auf seelische Daseite mit erhobenen Zeigefingern. Der Gruber, der hat ja so eine... Der hat ja auf diese Uhr, habt ihr Nibbler-Uhr, oder wie diese Uhr heißt, diese e-Paper-Uhr, die auf Kickstarter jetzt... Pebble, diese Pebble-Uhr, die jetzt so massiv finanziert worden ist.
Ja.
Und da hat ja der Gruber gesagt, also ich, wenn ich so gucke, dann sehe ich ja als allergrößte Gefahr, dass Apple da eventuell...
Satz zu Ende.
Und ich würde ihm sogar unterstellen, ich würde ihm sogar unterstellen, dass er ähnliches im Wald hört wie ich.
Ja Max, soll ich am Ende doch noch berecht behalten?
Ich würde das mittlerweile nicht mehr total ausschließen, aber sicher bin ich mir überhaupt...
Sicher sind wir erst, wenn wir das haben.
Ein Wecker.
Nee, irgendwas... Ich hab das ja vor einiger Zeit schon mal angedeutet. Irgendwas ist...
Im Busch.
Irgendwas ist im Busch.
Ja, mein Handgelenk ist auch so nackt. Also Apple muss was tun.
Für alle, die sich gefragt haben, wozu dieses Handgelenk überhaupt da ist und was da rumpassen könnte, haben wir jetzt...
Haben Sie schon mal in Ihrem Touchfinger hochgeguckt? Da hängt noch mehr dran.
Warum tragen wir keine Armbanduhr?
Nein, ich sagte doch, das Handgelenk ist nackt.
Ja, ich meine vielleicht sind ja die anderen...
Ich hab früher Armbanduhr getragen.
Ja, haben wir alle mal früher gemacht. Oder es war ja mal total heiß.
Als man Zeit noch für eine wichtige Information hielt.
Ja, als Leute Digitaluhr noch für eine großartige Erfindung hielten.
Ist es?
Damals, ja.
Ja.
Aber ich hab jetzt meine Digitaluhr hier in meinem iPhone drin gesüngt.
Genau, und das Telefon war der Tod der Armbanduhr. Das heißt, die Armbanduhr hatte eigentlich nur dann wieder eine Chance, wenn das Telefon dort einzieht.
Oder wenn sie verdammt geil aussieht, ich meine, das würde auch reichen. Also ich würde sie zumindest kaufen, aber nie tragen und dann so was verkauft. Und dann kommt iWatch 2.
Wenn man ehrlich ist, ist es ja eigentlich auch ätzend, so ein Ding am Handgelenk zu haben, dann schabbert das ja die ganze Zeit über deinen Rechner und klackert hier und klackert da, nix, dann machst du wieder ran, dann lässt du liegen. Aber es beweist, dass wirklich nix los ist, wenn wir jetzt hier schon über eventuelle Apple-Armband-Uren spektulieren. Und ich frage mich auch, inwieweit Tim Cook dafür direkt verantwortlich zu machen ist. Also zu Steves Zeiten, da brodelte es in einer Tour und kaum ist dieser Tim da.
Es gibt doch die ganze Zeit iPhone-Gerüchte bis zum Unfall.
Das sind doch alles totale Lüschenius.
Ja, diese Albernheiten hier von wegen, dass er das Display größer macht. Oder ja, machen sie das Display doch nicht größer, machen sie das Display nur höher. Weil dann müsste, diese Begründung, dann müsste niemand die Tabellenbreite anpassen und die App-Entwickler müssten nicht ganz so viel machen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so. Früher haben sich die Leute so echt nach vorne gewagt. So es kommt jetzt hier irgendwie das dreifaltige iPad, keine Ahnung, irgendwas, ne?
Da sind wir auf die Schnauze gefahren.
Aber das Ding ist halt, sie dachten halt, okay, Steve, der bringt halt auch immer einen Knaller raus, mit dem keiner rechnet. So, die haben einfach ins Wilde geschossen, weil sie auch was Wildes erwartet haben. So und jetzt kommt der zahme Tim Cook und trauen sich auch nichts mehr zu. Der Koch. Wir machen jetzt das Display ein bisschen größer, das ist alles, mehr kommt er nicht mehr.
Ich glaub ja eher, dass diese ganzen Schüler-Grafiker, die damals diese ganzen 3D-Entwürfe gemacht haben, dass die mittlerweile in irgendwelchen Start-ups alle arbeiten und keine Zeit mehr haben.
Das erklärt einiges, ja. Aber für mich persönlich, also ich mach Tim Cook so lange dafür direkt verantwortlich, dass Apple langweilig ist, bis er mir das Gegenteil beweist, jawohl.
Ist das jetzt jedes Mal unten Peek?
Aber dafür müsste ja der Tim erstmal einen Peek gehabt haben. Wir könnten ihn Tim C nennen, um Verwirrung.
Nennen wir ihn einfach der Koch?
Das ist wieder ein bisschen lang vielleicht.
Also Tim, wenn ihr keine Themenkarten zieht, dann machen wir weiterhin Jokersendung.
Wieso? Das Thema ist ja super. Man muss ja schon mal drüber nachdenken. Dieses Pebble-Ding versucht da nützlich zu sein für das iPhone über Bluetooth. Das heißt, es ist eigentlich hochgradig abhängig von dem, was standardmäßig über Bluetooth geht. Das ist nicht sehr viel. Und von dem, was Apps ihm senden, dann muss da aber die ablaufen, die nur in Ausnahmefällen irgendwas im Hintergrund tun kann. Und von daher erwarte ich mir da jetzt nicht so viel, was dieses Ding tun kann, außer die Uhr anzuzeigen. Natürlich ist an sich eine Uhr mit ePaper, Bildschirme eine coole Idee. Da macht ePaper mal total Sinn. Also ich würde einfach das Ding auch ohne die Integration schon interessant finden. Weil wenn man es mal dünn aufträgt, wenig Strom verbraucht, macht man so ein ePaper-Mini-Bildschirm da eine Knopfzelle. Das hält ja ewig.
Wenn du keinen Sekundenzeiger hast?
Ja, Sekundenzeiger wollen nicht. Ich meine, was willst du da schon drauf sehen?
Zwei Jahre später, Tim, eine Uhr ohne Sekundenzeiger!
Was hab ich sich dabei gedacht?
Aber im Sekundenteil könnt ihr eine LED links blinken oder so was vielleicht.
Also ich meine, wenn es mir auf die Sekunde ankommt, dann nehm ich das iPhone.
Das ist dann der neue Werteslogan.
Find übrigens mal eine App, die auf dem iPhone die Zeit mit Sekunden anzeigt. Da gibt's gar nicht so viele.
Na, die Atomclock hier.
Naja, wo die Sekunden wirklich als Zahl da stehen, das musste ich hier irgendwie bei Big Clock schon noch extra als Feature-Request anmelden. Alle anderen Uhren, die ich gefunden habe, tun das einfach nicht. Den Sekunden-Zeiger kaufen. Aber nur 5 Euro, jetzt auch die Sekunden.
Aber jetzt mal mit dieser...
Per die folgt immer nur alle 2 Sekunden, und wenn man extra zahlt, dann auch jede Sekunde.
Mit dieser Pebble-API. Ich weiß ja gar nicht, weiß jemand, was über Bluetooth eigentlich so an Signalen alles rüberkommt? Also ich meine, klar, dass das...
Nullen und Einsen machen.
Ja, aber was die da alles so mitgeben. Ich meine, so ein iPhone, das hat auch echt gute Auto-Integration. Und die können auch zum Beispiel mindestens anzeigen auf dem Display, welches Song wird da gerade gespielt. So diese ganzen Steuerungen hast du natürlich. Kann das nicht sein, dass die da auch einfach so neue SMS-Nachrichten oder sowas, dass die da auch irgendwo auflaufen und einfach von jemanden genutzt werden und wir das deswegen nicht wissen?
Dass da SMS-Nachrichten auflaufen?
Na ja, dass da weitere, dass da schon auch Notifications und sowas reingehen, theoretisch. Und wir das einfach nur... Niemand je von dieser API erfahren hat?
Also ich kann dir jetzt nicht auswendig runterbeten, was Sache ist, aber du kannst mir schwer davon ausgehen, dass das iPhone tendenziell erstmal weniger sendet als alle anderen.
Ich hatte dir schon mal in einer Sendung erzählt, das ist bestimmt so gefühlt drei, vier Jahre her, dass ich bei meinem Kumpel irgendwie mal, er meinte hier sein Radio kann irgendwie auch iPhone nicht, alles klar, connected. Und schwupp hat die Sau von Radio in mein Adressbuch runtergeladen.
Das ist nämlich das erste, was die Dinger machen. Das hatte ich auch mal in so einem Auto, was meinte Bluetooth. Ja, gar hier Bluetooth Kopfhörer. Weißt du, das ist das erste, wo man denkt, so Auto mit Bluetooth, ja, was sollte es tun? Lautsprecher? Nein.
Telefonbuch hochladen, haben sie bei Instagram gelernt.
Aber hier gibt's Uhren für diese Pebble Clock mit Sekundenzeiger.
An alles gedacht.
Naja, dass es das gibt, ist klar. Die Frage ist nur, wie das für den Strom verbraucht.
Was ist denn das für ein Display? Ein normales LCD ohne Farbe, ohne so beleuchtet?
E-Ink angeblich.
Naja, dann verbrauchst du auch gar keinen Strom, oder?
Naja, außer beim Ändern des Bildes.
Die Änderung kostet Strom.
Ja, aber jede Sekunde...
Ich glaube, das könnte auch gehen.
Die kostet halt jede Sekunde Strom. Ja, das wird dann auch nicht nur 24 Stunden halten. Ich hab keine Vorstellungen davon.
Müssen ja auch nicht nur das Display komplett drehen, sondern...
Zehn Millionen haben die dafür gekriegt.
Die haben gigantisch. Was wollten die haben?
100.000.
100.000 und 10 Millionen haben sie gekriegt.
Aber vielleicht ist das die Signal für etwas, was wir noch nicht begreifen. Also ich meine, angenommen... Nein, Kickstarter und ich, die freuen mich. Vielleicht ist das ja auch noch so ein Steve-Fühl. Ein Fühl von Steve.
So ein Nachbeben meint sie, ja?
Ein Fühl. Na, ein Fühl, Mann. Na halt, ein Gefühl. Ein Fühl. Liest du kein Internet oder was?
Offensichtlich die anderen Seiten.
Gehört das so in die Kategorie Flausch und Ponys und so?
Ja, gibt's sogar in Twitter. Wie auch immer. Keine Ahnung, ob Steve das noch gefühlt hat, oder ob das schon jemand anders gefühlt hat, oder ob das überhaupt jemand gefühlt hat, aber nehmen wir einfach mal an, irgendjemand hat das gefühlt, dass dem so sei. Vielleicht haben sie mit ihrer Technologie eigentlich alles, was sie brauchen. Da muss man sich ja nur diesen iPod, wie heißt der?
Nano.
Weiterdenken.
Ja, da muss man ja schon dran machen.
Wo sie ja explizit schon Armbanduhren-Support mitliefern quasi. Also bei dem einen Update, was es gab, also bei der Aktualisierung des Gerätes, haben sie ja zusätzliche Ziffernblätter nachgerüstet.
Vielleicht sind ihnen auch nichts anderes eingefallen.
Ja, aber du weißt, wie sie sind. Sie machen nichts in irgendeine Richtung, wo sie nicht irgendwas wittern.
Sie haben Third-Party-Zubehör auf der Bühne beworben, was ja wirklich nicht oft passiert.
So, und ich könnte mir das halt vorstellen, dass sie diesen iPod Nano irgendwie in so einer iPhone-Mélange vielleicht in irgendetwas in irgendwas hinentwickeln. Und vielleicht spielen auch Podcasts eine Rolle. Aber ich glaub ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr da dran.
Der Handgelenk-Podcast-Player.
Ein kleines Podcast-Studio im Handgelenk.
Amazing.
Hat sich jemand dieses 1944-Video angeguckt?
Ich hab das ja drei Tage vor dem Gruber gepostet, ne?
Hat aber niemand gelesen.
Ja, weil ich ja nicht so ne wie sagt man, snappy Headline irgendwie benutzt habe, sondern nur Ich hab's gesehen. They are the elephant and we are the mouse.
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Das ist furchtbar, oder? Also das ist das ist noch so das alte, überhebliche Apple.
Irgendjemand hat kommentiert ein lange verschollenes Video und ich wünschte es wäre so geblieben.
Ja, Gruber war es, glaub ich.
Ja, da ist was dran. Da ist was dran. Das ist furchtbar, das ist wirklich grauenhaft. Ich meine, es gab ja auch lustige Sachen hier, wie Windsongs 95. Hat man ja glaube ich auch schon mal irgendwann. So eine Sachen. Das war irgendwie nicht so, glaube ich, nicht ganz so offiziell, wie das jetzt hier gelaufen ist, weil laut dieser Background-Story, die da jetzt gerade gepostet wurde, ist das ja tatsächlich so ein richtig Apple-sanktioniertes Ding. Was man ja auch erwarten möchte, wenn da Steve Jobs irgendwie einen Präsidenten spielt. Das wird ja sicherlich nicht so... Da wird er ja nicht in irgendwas hinein montiert worden sein. Was sie sich dabei denken, ist mir vollkommen unklar. Ich meine, es ist lustig, dass damals war der Feind noch IBM. Das zeigt eigentlich schon, wie schief Apple damals eigentlich lag.
IBM als Feind zu betrachten?
Ja, also zumindest sich auch darauf so zu versteifen. Gut, es war halt damals so das Böse im Raum. Und sicherlich war das jetzt auch noch nicht so absehbar, wie sehr sich IBM von Microsoft lahmen lassen wird. So lizenztechnisch etc., Wann ist dieses Video entstanden?
1984, als der Mac rauskam.
Ja, richtig, stimmt.
Na ja, da waren die Clones aber schon ein Problem, glaube ich, für IBM.
Da ist ja IBM PC.
Da haben die noch den Maßstab gesetzt. Da haben alle probiert, IBM 1 zu 1 nachzubauen und so.
Wann gab es denn den ersten Clone? Das war doch der Compact. Ich glaube, das war ein Compact, genau. Wann ging das los? Ging das nicht erst später los? War das 1984 schon so weit?
Ich glaube, das ging relativ schnell los.
Compact wurde 1982 gegründet.
Dann haben sie wahrscheinlich drei Jahre lang gar nichts gemacht und dann haben sie einen PC. Die ersten Produkte, März 1983.
Tatsächlich. Eine tragbare Version. Dadurch hat sich Compact überhaupt erst so definiert. Wobei portable, also das ist so Klotz zum rumtragen.
Das hat ja auch Steve Jobs bei der McIntosh Vorstellung gesagt. Nein, das hat der Computer selber gesagt. Der McIntosh. Don't trust a computer you can't lift.
Kennt ihr das nicht?
Doch, aber ich hatte das nicht mehr so in Erinnerung. Na gut, es ist erstaunlich, wie schnell das losging mit diesen PC-Klons. Wobei, was heißt schon schnell? Zwei Jahre?
Nee, ich glaube, dass das IBM komplett unterschätzt hat, wie wichtig das Betriebssystem ist an der Stelle. Und wie einfach es ist, das BIOS nachzubauen.
Ja, die haben ziemlich alles unterschätzt damals. Und dann haben sie sich halt den Enterprise-Markt verabschiedet.
Aber eins haben sie halt nicht unterschätzt, dass der Krieg so stark ist, dass man sich da lieber zurückziehen sollte, was sie erfolgreich gemacht haben.
Ja, dass sie ihre PC-Sparte zum richtigen Zeitpunkt verkauft haben.
Und ihre Festplattensparte.
Und ihre Festplattensparte, da sind sie ganz klug. Und das wird jetzt Microsoft auch genauso gehen, glaube ich.
Stimmt, das ist eigentlich erstaunlich.
Sie verkaufen ihre PC-Sparte und ihre Festplattensparte? Welche Sparte wollen die verkaufen?
Office? Na, es geht ihnen genauso im Sinne von, dass sie sich in Richtung Enterprise verziehen, weil ich glaube, mit Konsum, das können sie irgendwie backen.
Aber ich glaube, so auf lange Sicht hast du also, dass nur noch irgendwie im Enterprise Business irgendwie PCs rumstehen und die Leute zuhause alle Macs benutzen, das wird auch nicht, nee, glaube ich nicht.
Die benutzen auch nicht alle Macs. Die benutzen entweder Macs oder iPads.
Aber dass die nur noch da, was hast du gesagt, im Enterprise irgendwie...
Ich war jetzt gerade auf Windows 8, Premiere Club und mit keinem anderen Eindruck konnte ich wieder nach Hause fahren, als dass das einfach alles vorbei ist da.
Nee, ich glaube, ihre Xbox-Strategie ist nicht aufgegangen einfach. Also wenn die aufgegangen wäre, dann sähe es jetzt anders aus.
Xbox?
Ja, also die Xbox-Strategie, so wie ich sie sehe, war halt, wir bauen eine Kiste für die Gamer, wo die Spieleentwickler nicht dran vorbeikommen und dann bauen die aber für die Xbox mit DirectX, also dieser ganzen proprietären Schnittstellenscheiße von Microsoft, die Spiele und können die dann leicht auf den PC portieren, weil das im Prinzip das Gleiche ist. Und damit, glaube ich, haben sie versucht, den Konsumermarkt zu kriegen. Was sie nicht bedacht haben, ist, dass so eine Kiste wie die Xbox halt nur was für einen Hardcore-Gamer ist und nicht für einen Casual-Gamer. Und der große Markt an Casual-Gamern halt der Heimanwendermarkt eigentlich ist. Die Leute, die Hardcore-Gamen, die sind, glaube ich, auch sehr stark in der Unterzahl. Und Apple hat den Casual-Gamer-Markt gekriegt, ohne es wirklich zu wollen, würde ich mal fast sagen. Weil es halt einfach passiert. Und der Casual-Gamer-Markt ist für Microsoft weitestgehend verschlossen, glaube ich. Und dadurch haben sie auch keine Chance mehr, mit dieser Chimäre aus Xbox und Windows die Leute von der Xbox auf Windows zu ziehen.
So sehe ich das. Ja, ich meine, die Xbox ist doch ohnehin ein Misserfolg.
Ich glaube nicht, also sagt der Chat auch, dass das, ich glaube nicht, dass das die Xbox-Schattung war. Ist die Xbox ein Misserfolg?
Na mittlerweile nicht mehr, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, die ist eine Venue-Sparpe, die noch ein bisschen Geld abwirft.
Ja, das ist eine, die...
Ja, die haben ewig lange draufgezahlt, aber...
Ja, das ist unterm Strich, ist das immer noch ein Minusgeschäft.
Da haben wir mit Milliarden von Minen angefangen, oder?
Nicht auch nur im Ansatz die Kohle, die sie da reingesteckt haben.
Für die Xbox One nicht, aber für die 360 geht's wohl, glaube ich.
Ja, aber für so ein Unternehmen wie Microsoft ist das ein Witz. Ich meine, wie lange ist diese Xbox jetzt am Markt? Zehn Jahre?
Naja, sie mussten ja... Am Anfang hat sich ja Sony noch mit... hat ja noch gegen gehalten, ne? Jetzt die nächste... Die nächste Konsolenschlacht geht dann vielleicht schon eher in Richtung Microsoft.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, aber... Falls es auch eine gibt. Ja, genau, also...
Na, Playstation die nächste ist, dann könnte ich die nächste Xbox auch...
Ja, aber wer soll denn das noch kurz...
Ist die jetzt angekündigt schon? Also nach allem, was ich... Jetzt sind wir natürlich wieder schon in einem Bereich unterwegs, an dem man uns nicht auskennt. Es gibt ja diesen Wien-Nachfolger, der ist schon ewig angekündigt.
Das ist auch der totale Fehler. Also wenn man Nintendo-Aktien hat, kann ich nur sagen, verkaufen, verkaufen, verkaufen.
Ja, so ähnlich sehe ich das. Also dieser Klotz, der aussieht wie dieses externe Display, das man da dran hat und so. Naja, vielleicht... Xbox und PS3-Nachfolger sind noch nicht angekündigt, weil es das EA, die haben jetzt irgendwie... Die einen Fatalzahlen haben enttäuscht. Und die haben gesagt, ja, wir haben schon mal Rückstellungen gemacht für Next-Generation-Konsolenentwicklung. Und das so irgendwie so ein bisschen so die... Okay, da wird wohl was kommen. Aber mehr gibt es doch noch nicht?
Also ich hab im Internet schon gelesen, dass es die Xbox 720 geben wird und die PlayStation 4 auch. Also schon, das lasse ich sehr definitiv.
Dass sie das noch rausbringen. Weil das ein Markt ist, wo keiner Geld verdient. Punkt. Apple geht nicht in Märkte, wo keiner Geld verdient. Apple hat eine viel bessere Gaming-Strategie. Da verdienen sie sich dumm und dämmen dich mit.
Ja, wenn alle denken, die wollen ja auch irgendwie in den TV-Markt, verdienen sie da Geld?
Langsam. Also wir waren bei Windows, aber meine These war, ich sehe das nicht. Ich sag nicht, ich liege auf jeden Fall richtig. Lass uns doch nicht durcheinander reden die ganze Zeit. Das hassen die Hörer zu Recht. Ich war da, ich habe mir nicht viel anschauen können. Ich hatte nicht viel Zeit. Ich habe irgendwie so zwei Talks gesehen, dann habe ich danach in diesem Demo-Room irgendwie mir noch so eine Windows-8-Installation, die irgendwie auch nicht wirklich funktionierte, angeguckt.
War die auf einem PC oder auf so einem Tablet?
Die war auf so einem iMac-artigen PC mit Touch-Bildschirm.
Ach Gott, also genau die Variante, die man nicht will.
Wieso, welche Variante will man denn?
Würdest du hier so einen PC kaufen? Also wenn man sich einen PC kauft, einen mit so einer Touch?
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es da überhaupt eine Variante gibt, die man haben will, aber das war das, was da stand. Und das war halt dieser bekloppte Hybrid mit diesem Kachelkram. Und dann kannst du da irgendwie auf Desktop tippen und dann hast du halt so einen normalen Stino-Windows-Desktop, der irgendwie keinerlei Überraschungen hatte. Da ist so ein Browser-Icon auf dem Bildschirm und das war's. So, und dann geht ein Browser auf und du hast dann halt in diesem... Ich sag mal, ich will mal Aero sagen. Wie heißt das? Metro. In diesem Metro-Teil hast du dann halt nochmal so einen Internet-Explorer im Metro-Design. Und dann kannst du dir das Wetter anzeigen lassen und noch so groundbreaking applications in dieser Größenordnung. Da gab es einfach nichts zu sehen. Die Hälfte stürzte irgendwie gleich ab. So, und meine Frage an diesen Spezi war halt, was die eigentlich wollen? Also was ist jetzt... Ja, was ist das Interface? Was ist ihre Strategie? Das konnte mir nur keiner erklären. Keiner konnte mir sagen, was der Sinn davon ist, dass das so kombiniert ist.
Das ist aber schon nahe an Trollen, so eine Frage zu stellen, oder?
Na, was soll ich denn da sonst für eine Frage stellen? Ich hab natürlich auch gefragt, wann das rauskommt. Das konnten sie mir auch nicht sagen.
Die können da nahe liegende Fragen nicht beantworten. Das ist echt. Das hatte ich damals, als das Windows Phone 7 vorgestellt wurde, dass auch so total nahe liegende Sachen einfach nicht erwähnt worden sind.
Das war auch alles so furchtbar unprofessionell. Allein diese Moderation. Oh, ey, da haben sie da so einen...
Oder die holen ja auch mal hier irgendwie den...
Nein, die haben das komplett aus eigenem Personal bestritten. Keine Ahnung, wie lange sie diese Nerds da irgendwie vorher im Keller gehalten haben, bis sie auf diese Bühne kamen. Aber es war einfach ein Fremdschämendelux.
Und wie viel hat denn dieses Plasteteil um?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab das überhaupt nicht eingereicht, bin einfach reingelatscht und keiner mich... Ja echt, also voll war es dann nicht. Ich hab da vorher noch gefragt, so hier, kann man euch jemanden mitbringen? Anmeldungen, lalala. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass hier gähnende Leere geherrscht hat, aber es war jetzt auch nicht so, dass man das Gefühl hatte, dass so die Massen da irgendwie reinstoßen wollten.
Was war das jetzt, also es war so ein Presseevent?
Also es ist in diesem flippigen Enhau-Hotel da am Wasser.
Enhau-Hotel, achso das ist da vorne...
Das Musikhotel, da neben Universal.
Mit dem, mit dieser coolen, so halb über die Spree-Ruhe hängenden...
Genau, genau, genau, genau. Und da ist irgendwie auch alles ganz flippig.
Und die nehmen sich auch alle ganz flippig.
Und die haben so einen Konferenzbereich, halt so üblicherweise mit so zwei Präsentationsräumen und dann so einen Sammelraum und dann nochmal so einen Nebenraum, wo irgendwie der Demo rum war. So, es gab irgendwie Schnittchen, es war auch alles ganz okay. Und Getränke, es ist auch nicht übermäßig viel, aber angemessen, es gab wohl auch noch Mittagessen, keine Ahnung, ich bin nach dem Mittagessen gekommen, ich wollte das nicht haben. So, aber dann kam dann halt irgendwie so ein dünner Hansel und hat halt dann die Speaker angekündigt und ich dachte, ich brech ins Essen, was der für schlechte Witze gemacht hat und wie furchtbar unprofessionell und peinlich das war, was der von sich gegeben hat. Ich kann das gar nicht wiedergeben, es war einfach... Also ich hätte den Typen einfach sofort rausgeschmissen danach. Geschweige denn den rausgeschmissen, der beschlossen hat, ihn da überhaupt hinzustellen. Und dann kündigt er sogar noch einen schlechten Witz an, dass er jetzt einen schlechten Witz erzählt, und dann ist er auch noch schlecht. So, dann halten sie ihre Vorträge auf Deutsch mit englischen Slides. Also... Gut, da kann man auch irgendwie mit leben. Und vor allem so, ja, und Windows-Design, und wir reduzieren, und wir lassen alles überflüssige weg, und dann so textlastige Slides, so, ja, die irgendwie, so mit so Bandwurmen setzen, irgendwie fünf Bullet Points, so richtig schön PowerPoint-Feeling. Also da widersprach einfach das Gesagte dem sichtbaren. Dann war auch diese Aufteilung so merkwürdig, die Bühne war irgendwie in der Mitte, und das Publikum saß links und rechts davon. Also links waren so bunte Sitzkissen, diese Start-up-Kissen, die man haben muss, wenn man so ein Start-up hat. So eine Fat Boys. Genau, solche Fat Boys-Teile. Auf der anderen Seite so Stühle für Leute, denen das so peinlich war.
Leute, das müssen wir jetzt kurz erklären.
Du bist nicht gemeint, das sind so Sitzsäcke.
Nee, wirklich, mit den Kissen.
Aber jetzt stellt euch mal diese Präsentationssituation vor. Also links und rechts Publikum, und in der Mitte ist die Bühne quer zum Publikum. Naja, ich meine, wenn sie das eine Publikum anschauen, hätten sie das andere Publikum im Rücken. Also ist der Präsentationsort quasi um 90 Grad gedreht, aber in der Mitte. Und dann sind vor und hinter der Präsentationsbühne vier Bildschirme, die dann so mitten im Raum stehen. Ja genau, hä? Ihr versteht das jetzt nicht.
Mal mein Omni-Graffel. Mach mal ein Organi.
Die Hörer sind schon längst weiter, ja.
Die Hörer sehen das ähnlich, genau.
Ne, das gibt es einfach.
Skip, skip, skip.
Also die haben da irgendwas. Nein, du brauchst jetzt nicht aufzuzeichnen. Oder? Muss das wirklich? Nein.
Sonst versteht ihr es ja nicht, ne?
Ja, aber jetzt musst du es auch dann für den Chat.
Ja, ich hab's dir gesagt.
Die Hörer sind ja nicht so blöd wie ihr.
Du machst halt einfach ein Foto und packst es auf den Twitter-Account.
Ja, so, guck mal hier. Bühne. Bildschirm, Bildschirm, Bildschirm, Bildschirm. Da ist Publikum, da ist Publikum.
Die Bühne war zwischen den Publikum.
Das sag ich doch. Ja, aber dann... Und in welche Richtung guckt der Typ, der mit dem schlechten Witz?
Die hüpfen halt in der Mitte darum wie in so einem Boxring und gucken halt mal in die eine, mal in die andere Richtung. Das ist ja das Absurde.
Aber das ist eigentlich eine coole Sache, weil du konntest in die Gesichter der Leute auf der anderen Seite gucken. Und was hast du da gesehen?
Hände, Hände wahrscheinlich.
Ich kann dir sagen, was ich gesehen hab. Ich hab gesehen, wie sie alle Entsätze in ihre iPhones und iPads reingetwittert haben. Ja, das war nur über iPhone und iPhone. Das haben auch alle nur über iPads geredet. Das war wirklich das Absurde. Du bist auf so einer Microsoft-Veranstaltung und jeder, mit dem du zusammenstehst, hatte irgendwie ein iPad in der Hand. Und alle zogen, also die ganze Zeit wurde immer alles damit verglichen. Das war wirklich Zeitenwechsel, also Zeitenwinde.
Times are changing, krasse Sache.
Aber ich wollte da noch auf irgendwas hinaus.
Ich will wieder in meine Nische zurück.
Diese Design-Geschichte, okay, meinetwegen, reduziertes User-Interface geschenkt. Ich bin nicht so ein Freund davon, aber meinetwegen.
Der Dennis möchte gerne in seine Nische zurück.
Dann gab es noch einen zweiten Talk, den ich noch mitbekommen habe. Da ging es ums Development. Da hat er gezeigt, wie man mit C++ und JavaScript da irgendwie entwickeln kann. Zitlantenzahler haben sie nicht auf dem Bildschirm gehabt. Aber gesagt, dass das geht. Aber der eigentliche Punkt, der mich wirklich verstört und was ich auch nicht verstehe ist, was eigentlich da jetzt die Stoßrichtung ist. Also warum sollte man sich ein Windows 8 kaufen? Ich rede jetzt nicht von, ich kaufe mir einen neuen PC und da ist es dabei. Das ist klar. Darüber werden sie immer irgendwie was in den Markt kriegen. Aber wie wenig Traktion das letzten Endes erzeugt, sieht man ja jetzt schon mit Windows 7. Man sich anschaut, wie groß noch die XP Installed Base ist. Also wenn die da nicht wirklich alle mitziehen. Wir wissen, wenn jetzt hier Snow, Mountain, Lion rauskommt, wie schnell das auch alte Versionen langsam vom Markt verschwinden lässt.
Ja, aber komm, jetzt bist du ein bisschen zweischlecht, weil unsere letzte oder vorletzte Sendung war noch immer, wo wir so etwas über Lion abgelassen haben. Also am liebsten wären wir noch alle bei Snow Lappert geblieben. Bei Snow Lappert ist unser XP.
Ich kenne nicht so viele Leute, die jetzt wirklich da bleiben.
Das ist nur eine Menge Leute, die den Namen haben.
Ja, aber wir haben alle nicht wieder gemacht, da war halt der alte Flex aus dem Rückenmark.
Beim nächsten Mal sind wir da ein bisschen vorsichtiger.
Es gab Gründe.
Es gibt immer Gründe.
Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt in Lion einen nichts gelockt hat. Es ist halt nur so, dass man danach irgendwie ein bisschen verarscht wurde.
Ich hab ein sehr gutes Feature, das mich gelockt hat und das kann ich danach erzählen.
Und Windows 8 ist halt komisch, weil sie bringen jetzt ein System. Ich meine das ganz ernst. Und ich würde das auch gerne verstehen. Vielleicht begreife ich ja nur irgendwas nicht und ihr könnt es mir erklären, aber sie bringen jetzt quasi ein neues User-Interface. Und auch auf diesen ARM-Tablets gibt es dann auch noch diesen Desktop. Was soll das? Also ein Nerd kann sowas schon auch benutzen auf einem Tablet, aber das ist echt nicht was du willst.
Nee, nur damit Office da läuft.
Du kannst das doch nicht ernsthaft auf so einem Tablet benutzen. Und ich meine überhaupt Office. Okay, dann hast du da Office drauf. Aber was ist denn jetzt ihr User-Interface-Paradigma für die Zukunft? Ich meine, alles was sie gezeigt haben mit diesem Metro, auch diese ganzen Developer-Demos, das war eigentlich immer dasselbe. Ja, wir ziehen jetzt hier Daten aus dem Netz über Bing oder aus einer Datenbank und zeigen das an und dann haben wir da so einen Browser. Also, ich hab die ganze Zeit nur Browser gesehen. Wo ist da, wie ist es so schön am Anfang, beim iPad, damit könnte man ja nichts createn, ne? Die Frage habe ich jetzt irgendwie an dieses Metro-Interface. Also, ich habe keinerlei Beispiele dafür gesehen, keinerlei Visionen, wie man damit eben jetzt auch wirklich arbeiten soll.
Createn kann.
Ja, das ist immer alles nur so im Prinzip so ein besserer Browser.
Ein schlechterer Browser, weil hast du mal den Browser ausprobiert?
Und ich sag dir, Leute, die das sehen, die dieses Windows 8 sehen, die laufen schreiend davon, weil das alles anders macht als das bisher war, beziehungsweise ignorieren es total und benutzen ihr Windows genauso wie vorher. Aber es gibt irgendwie wenig Incentive, außer ich kenne jetzt die Bulletlist für die Verbesserung in dem eigentlichen Desktop OS nicht. Aber davon ist ja nicht die Rede.
Nö.
Genau, also warum sollte jemand upgraden? Und der Enterprise-Bereich, der wird schon überhaupt nicht upgraden.
Eher nicht.
Also warum? Die haben jetzt irgendwie 10 Jahre gewartet, bis sie dann mal sich auf Windows 7 trauen. Die werden jetzt nicht gleich anfangen, den nächsten Düsselkram zu machen. Vor allem nicht, wenn da dieses komische Kachelteil drauf.
Aber man fragt sich schon, wie ist es dazu gekommen? Also ich meine, außer dass Steve Ballmer nicht so lange Leinen gezogen hat, kann man sich eigentlich keine Erklärung zusammenräumen.
Ich glaube, der Grund dafür ist relativ simpel, weil sie halt, also sie wollen in den Tabletmarkt rein. Sie wissen, da sind sie zu spät für eigentlich. Und dass sie so richtig keine Chance mehr haben, weil das wird gerade von Apple dominiert. Und wenn Apple mal die Fahnenstange abgeben muss, dann wird es wahrscheinlich an Android gehen. Also mussten sie schnell auf Masse kommen. Da musst du schnell Entwickler hinkriegen. Und wie kriegst du schnell Entwickler, indem du sagst, du hast eine große Userbase. Wie kriegst du schnell eine Userbase? Indem du den ganzen Klatsch einfach auf den Desktop nochmal packst und darauf hoffst, dass die Leute über kurz oder lang upgraden. Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass Windows 8 ist so nur über Bande überhaupt die Notwendigkeit, ein neues Betriebssystem oder so. Es geht nur darum, schnell eine Userbasis aufzubauen. Und damit du den Entwickler sagen kannst, guck mal, wir haben schon 5 Millionen Leute vom ersten Tag an auf Metro. Und das lohnt sich da, für Apps zu entwickeln. Und da wollen die, glaub ich, hin.
Ja, aber sie erreichen halt das Gegenteil. Du guckst dir das an und denkst dir, Microsoft ist doch Toast. Hier geht's doch nicht mehr weiter.
Ich hab jetzt auch gerade parallel versucht auf der Microsoft-Seite die Features von Windows 8 herauszufinden und es ist wirklich...
Ich kann keine DVDs mehr abfüllen per default.
Ja, das ist auch so super.
Naja, hat sich ja nun wirklich erledigt das Thema. Das mit den vielen Warnungen davor, dass man nicht drauf probieren soll.
Kommen wir zu angenehmen Themen. Es war Republikar. Du hast ja auch deine Hände drin gebadet.
Ich hab meine Hände drin... Also ich war nicht daran beteiligt, weil jetzt irgendwie das Gerücht aufsteht.
Aber du warst voll in der Suppe.
Ich hab probiert, voll in der Suppe zu... Ich war voll in der Suppe. Ich hab nämlich am ersten Abend direkt eine Erkältung geholt. Dann war ich spätestens ab Donnerstag voll in der Suppe. Ja, aber ich war die ganze Zeit über da. Das war eine sehr, sehr schöne Republikar. Dieser Umzug in die Station, vor dem ich ja doch einiges an Angst hatte, weil viele Leute ja der Station gegenüber doch ganz ordentliche Vorbehalte haben, von wegen riesige Hallen. Nur, dass man alles mitbringen muss, nicht zu beheizen. Das Glück hatten sie alles nicht. Das Pech hatten sie nicht. Diese Probleme hatten sie alle. Die Kosten sind nach meinem Kenntnisstand durchaus wesentlich höher als die letzten Jahre. Aber sie haben es trotzdem, finde ich, sehr schön hingekriegt. Sie haben da echt was draus gemacht aus dieser Station, die ansonsten wirklich sehr kahl ist. Und ich fand es Republika Esker als die letzte Republika.
Sie haben sich aber auch sponsormäßig ganz schön verkauft, oder?
Ja, das gehört dazu, ne? Wieso, an wen denn so?
Ich weiß da. Es gab einige Sponsoren, aber das ist ja auch nichts Neues.
Aber das war echt gut.
Dafür ist halt der Eintritt niedrig. Also vergleichsweise.
Wie niedrig ist denn der Eintritt?
Das war der normale 90 Euro, glaube ich. Wally Bird und 130 Euro war so late, normal Ticket.
Kann man definitiv machen.
Für eine 3-Tages-Konferenz ist das kein hoher Betrag. Das zahlste normalerweise vielleicht für einen Tag.
Und sie haben sich halt das getraut, wovor sich der Kongress die ganze Zeit überschaut, nämlich das Wachstum. Das Einfach sagen, wir müssen größer werden. Und dafür sind sie eben dieses Risiko eingegangen, die Location zu wechseln. Dass das eventuell ganz total in die Hose geht und das mit Preleitern angehen. Ich hoffe, dass die Rechnung aufgeht und dass sie sagen, wir sind deutlich größer als die letzten Jahre und wir können weiter wachsen. Weil es ist ein Thema, was Leute interessiert. Und entweder man macht da so eine Elite-Haufen-Versammlung raus mit Ticket-Verlosung oder was, oder man muss halt größer werden. Also das fand ich gut.
Ja, ich fand das auch gut. Ich finde sowieso, dass die Republik eine total sinnvolle und wichtige Veranstaltung ist. Und eigentlich haben sie das mega konsequent fortgesetzt. Das Medienecho war ja nun wirklich gut. Oder? Vor allem auch das Speaker-Lineup war echt sehr erstaunlich breit. Da ist jetzt auch nicht alles gelungen, vortragstechnisch, wie das eben so ist. Aber der eigentliche Punkt, weswegen man da hinkommt und schon immer hinkam, ist halt Leute treffen, wie das eben so ist. Deswegen geht man auf Konferenzen, sonst kann man sich das Ganze auch im Stream anschauen. Und da war ein Gequatsche. So eine intensive Diskussionskultur. Also da wird von morgens um 10 bis Mitternacht standen sie da in diesem Hof und quatschten.
Der war echt geil. Dieser Hof, das war echt gut.
Das war wirklich top. Ich meine, man hat auch ein bisschen Glück gehabt mit dem Wetter, aber das scheint bei der Republik auch so ein Abo zu sein. Die andere Seite ist ganz stumm. Ihr wart alle nicht da, ihr habt was verpasst.
Ich hatte auch Spaß. Alles Mögliche.
2.
bis 4.
Mai.
Max, weißt du, wie das mit den Aufzeichnungen der Talks ist? Hast du da Einblicke?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich weiß nur, dass die jetzt nach und nach kommen sollen.
Ich bin jetzt schwer gespannt.
Ja, hoffe ich mal, dass da, also das hat ja irgendwie, da hat sich ja Spiegel online drum gekümmert um dieses ganze Streaming und sowas. Die haben das ja komplett gemacht.
Ach, siehst du am 4. Mai, da hat die Party.
Das Streaming oder die Aufzeichnung?
Ich glaube, die haben das einfach alles hingestellt, was dafür nötig war. Also die Kameras und so.
Ach echt, das war sozusagen gesponsort.
Ich glaube schon, ich bin mir aber nicht 100% nicht so glücklich.
Deswegen war alles bei Spiegel auch sofort immer...
Ja, das war ja auf der Homepage und so, ne?
Die waren ja auch mit Sponsoren. Ich hab mich ja prompt von einem dieser Sponsoren da anwerben lassen, da nehme ich von diesem, kann ich ja vielleicht mal erzählen, von diesem neuen Dienst, der jetzt hier in Berlin beworben wird, Car2Go heißen die. Weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt. Genau, sowas wie DriveNow, das sind so kleine...
Nur nicht von BMW, sondern von Mercedes.
Genau, die waren aber auch vor DriveNow am Start.
Darum mit Smarts und ohne Minis. Wie bei DriveNow. Und die hatten halt, da konnte man sich auf der Republika, normalerweise zahlt man da 10 Euro Mitgliedsgebühr, also Aufnahmgebühr, dass man Mitglied werden kann, das war da halt kostenlos. Da hab ich gedacht, mach ich einen ganzen Spaß mal mit. Und dann bin ich direkt am nächsten Tag mit so einem DriveNow-Auto dahingefahren.
Nee, mit dem...
Zu Republika.
Nicht mit dem Auto.
Mit dem Car2go Auto.
Mit dem Sponsoring-Vertrag gleich gekippt.
Naja, wir sind ja hier ausgeglichen und blablabla, müssen ja auch alle erwähnt werden. Und das ist schon ganz cool eigentlich. Also muss ich echt sagen, ich glaub ich werd mir jetzt noch so einen DriveNow-Vertrag holen.
Was ist denn jetzt anders bei Car2go als bei DriveNow?
Williger.
Ich glaub, vom Preis her nimmt sich das so ziemlich gar nichts. Was kostet's bei DriveNow?
Also bei 39 Cent oder 29?
Also bei 29. Die Preise sind ziemlich genau die gleichen.
Bei Car2go sind's auch 29. Also pro Minute, nicht pro Kilometer. Fürs Parken 9 Cent pro Minute. Und man sagt halt, es gibt eine iPhone-App, und dann sagt man, okay, jetzt hier, ich will jetzt Auto fahren, wo ist denn das nächste Auto? Dann gehst du jetzt zum Auto hin, wählst kurz mit deiner Karte vor dem Ding.
Das Ding blinkt vor allem, wenn du sagst, zeig dich mal wo du bist, dann blinkt's schon, dass du es aus der Ferne sehen kannst, wo du bist.
Achso, das ging jetzt bei Kartokon nicht.
Achso, bei DriveNow geht das.
Die haben aber eine API, mit der man, mit der man, glaube ich, sogar im Umsatz ein bisschen beteiligt wird, also da gibt es jetzt massenhaft Apps zum App Store.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Und dann setzt man sich rein, dann gibt man auch so einen PIN-Code ein, dann kann man losfahren. Das ist schon... Und dann steht man im Stau.
Wie jeder andere auch.
Das ist, wenn man ein bisschen aufstehen will.
Ein Kumpel von mir nutzt DriveNow eine ganze Menge, und der hat gestern Party gemacht, weil er einen neuen Job hat. Und dann hat er in seiner Freude vergessen, das DriveNow Auto abzugeben, und das war die ganze Zeit im Parken-Modus. Da musst du erstmal 40 Euro zahlen, weil Parken 10 Cent die Minute kostet.
Ja, aber für sowas ist das echt geil. Also wenn man mal was einkaufen will oder sowas.
Weiß nicht, man muss halt mit einberechnen, dass wenn man irgendwo hinkommt, also wenn man zum Beispiel mich besucht, bei mir gibt es keine Parkplätze. Da kann man locker mal eine Viertelstunde rumfahren. Und dann zahlt man halt 5 Euro für im Kreis fahren und dann hätte man vielleicht doch Taxi fahren können. Das stimmt.
Das muss man echt auf die Reihe kriegen, das mit den Parkplätzen suchen und sowas. Aber ansonsten, was ich halt finde, also das würde ich gern mal wissen, ich hoffe mal, dass er das noch machen lässt. Wenn man in so eine Karre einsteigt, eigentlich so dieses ganze, also da ist ein Navi drin, das Navi, dass ich das merke, also die letzten Orte, dass das irgendwie mit auf meiner Karte gespeichert wird oder bei denen in der Cloud.
So ein Profile hast du bei denen.
Genau, wo dann mein Radiosender wieder eingestellt wird, wenn ich das nächste Mal einsteige.
Das Radio, das ist ja jetzt schon so, oder?
Nee, also ich weiß es nicht. Ich hätt's gerne, dass das so die nächste Stufe, die nachkommen muss.
Habt ihr wenigstens einen iPod-Doc-Connector in den Teilen?
Ich hab keinen gesehen, hab ich aber auch nicht nachgesucht.
Man will es ja auch genau, per Bluetooth mach ich wieder keinen. Doch, laden will man ja vielleicht doch gleich.
Also die Tell-Taste ging nicht am...
Ich will das Teil da reinstecken, auf Play drücken und dann will ich meinen Podcast hören.
Du willst nur Play drücken.
Ich wollte ja noch mal, ich wollte ja noch nicht ganz die Republik verlassen, sondern nochmal so ein bisschen das, was wir da noch so gemacht haben, pluggen. Du hast ja auch live da Podcasts aufgenommen.
Genau, wir haben da einen WMR, haben probiert, den zu streamen, was sehr in die Hose ging. Wir haben es in Reden gemacht mit, wen hatten wir alles da? Wir hatten hier Zeitweise hatten wir da. Der hat sich sehr schön mit Ole Reismann von Spiegel Online über die Piraten gestritten. Und dann hatten wir mit hier HDS Julian und Nimor86 haben wir so probiert, mal dieses ganze, ich will das böse P-Wort nicht sagen, Thema auseinander zu klamüsern, wer da wo drinne steckt, was das böse P-Wort ist. Das andere böse P-Wort.
Ich dachte Picken.
Das war Mobile Max, Ausgabe Nummer 87. Wir müssen jetzt leider aus rechtlichen Gründen abschalten.
Es hat gerade geklingelt.
Okay, also WMR 41 von der Republika.
Genau.
Und du hast danach auch noch. Ich war nur zu Gast. Ich war zu Gast bei Wikigeeks, die da eine sehr schöne Berichterstattung gemacht haben. Auch das Wikigeeks Team. Genau genommen ist das eine Kooperation gewesen zwischen Wikigeeks und Anycast. Das sind beides Podcasts aus Göttingen. Die haben sich da zusammengetan. Von daher waren sie auch nicht vollständig vertreten. Aber das haben die sehr nett gemacht. Jeden Tag da so eine Sendung. Gibt es bei Wikigeeks und ich glaube auch bei Anycast im Feed. Dann habe ich noch ein Interview geliefert hier bei QWOPcast. Und ansonsten gab es noch einen schönen Artikel zu meinem Vortrag bei Zeit Online über Podcasts. Hast du gelesen?
Ja, habe ich gelesen.
Den Appel muss ich neu erfinden, nee, was anderes.
Nein.
Du hast Podcasts, so die flauschige Alternative zum allgemeinen Internet Shitstorm Diskurs sind und dass man doch mehr Podcasts hören sollte.
Das Netz muss sprechen lernen, heißt es da. Genau. Das war sehr, sehr nett von Kai Biermann, der ja wohl bekannt ist, denke ich mal, bei vielen immer kluge Dinge schreibt und so ein richtiger Internet-Versteher ist. Ja, das war eigentlich so meine Republika Experience.
Mit dem Ralf Stockmann, mit dem habe ich mich auch vorher noch getroffen. Also der von den Wiki-Geeks hier. Und der ist ja quasi durch dich ist er ja dazu gekommen, dass er sich da fettes das Equipment hinzustellen. Weil du dich mal bei Not Safe For Work gerade über sie so ausgelassen hast, was sie dann für eine unterirdische Soundqualität hätten. Und der hat da so richtig amtliches Zeug vorgelegt. Also der hatte da ein gutes Mischpult. Und dann habe ich da die eigenen Headsets mitgebracht. Und der hatte noch zwei dabei. Und dann haben wir das da alle schön aufgezeichnet. Der hat sich echt gut reinge...
Also der hatte DD297-PV-Podcaster-Standard.
Gibt es da jetzt schon eine ISO-Norm für?
Für Zeit, ne? Für Zeit. Dann können wir mal das Republikathema abschließen. Wollen wir mal wieder über Max reden?
Ich kann mal ein kleines Thema, so ein, ich...
Du bist doch grad wieder total evil grad.
Sind sie jetzt, wieso?
Na ja, da sind sie nicht evil, da sind sie nur einfach erstmal... Das File Vault Gate.
Ach das.
Also es gibt halt noch vier User auf dieser Welt.
Und vom ersten ist das Passwort.
Und die vier User, die haben halt noch File Vault und haben jedes Mal, wenn dieses Fenster auch kommt, dass sie doch bitte zu File Vault 2 wechseln, haben immer seit Jahren klicken, die dann, ne ich möchte nicht.
Ach da kommt eine Frage, ne?
Ja klar, da schlägt einem vor, dass man ja auf das Neue wechseln kann.
Das schlägt da immer nur einmal vor.
Wir haben auch ein bisschen Drama hier, ja?
Ey, lass mal einen anderen Programmpunkt stark machen.
Und die, immer noch FileWort benutzen, das Alte. Da gab es dann das 10.7.3-Update und irgendein Intern bei Apple. Natürlich muss es ein Intern gewesen sein. Der ist auch schon längst nicht mehr da und der wurde entlassen, weil der war nicht so gut und blablabla.
Genau, die, die an den Line-Quellcode gelassen werden.
Ja, genau, aus Versehen haben die da was verwechselt und dann haben die so den Debug-Scheiter fürs Logging irgendwie angelassen. Das Passwort wurde in Klartext irgendwie da mitgeschrieben. Für die vier Leute. Die Passwörter sind auch bekannt, kursieren im Internet.
Das ist ganz spannend, weil in dem die Bucklogs stehen halt die Aufrufe von bestimmten Funktionen drin. Und zu diesen Aufrufen halt auch die gesamten Parameter, die diese Funktionen benutzen.
Hast du auch Fall wollte oder hast du Artikel gelesen?
Nee, ich hab das bei einem Rechner, wo es noch an war.
Warte mal, welches von diesen Passwortern sind das jetzt?
Hier, ich poste mal so ein Terminal-Kommando in den Chat, wo man sehr relativ schnell rausfinden kann mit, ob man da betroffen ist von. Weil da steht halt dann als ein Parameter, Passwort ist gleich und dann steht das dann da halt.
Das war noch so UTF-8-Passwort oder UTF-8-encoded-Passwort oder sowas?
Nein, es steht einfach nur Passwort. Ich werde das auch mal in den Chat posten. Diese nette Ausgabe. Na, das Passwort ist natürlich unkenntlich gemacht mit den paar Sternen. Aber das ist einfach super. Das funktioniert einfach wunderbar. Ich dachte, ich werd nicht mehr. Also man kann natürlich nach jedem Einloggen ein RM auf dieses Pfeil machen. Sudo RM. Dann ist es weg.
Man kann doch einfach zum Pfeil Vol 2 wechseln.
Kann man auch.
Sollte man auch. Das ist auch wesentlich schneller, ne? Aber geht das überhaupt so ein Passwort, das nur aus Sternchen besteht?
Ja, das ist schon ganz schön peinlich von Apple, dass sowas durchrutscht. Gerade auch bei einem Update, weil da sollten ja schon ganz genau hingucken, was die da machen. Das ist ja eine Regression. Könnte man das ja so nennen, ja? Oder keine Ahnung, was denen eingefallen ist. Und ja, hat wohl keiner aufgepasst.
Also ich hab mir extra aufgeschrieben, der Artikel, wo das, glaube ich, bei Sophos, zumindest bei Sophos, war, der Artikel vom 6. Mai. Wir haben jetzt den 9. Es sind drei Tage. Wir können ja nächste Woche mal gucken, wie lange dieser Bug dann tatsächlich überlebt hat, bis Apple das Update dazu rausgepusht hat.
Ich kann dir sagen, was passiert.
Nix.
Genau. 10.7.4 wird kommen. Da werden sie es vielleicht fixen. Und dass die Bugfrag wieder zurücksetzen. Aber Apple wird sich auf die Position zurückziehen, Jungs, ihr sollt FileVolts wo benutzen?
Also so einfach können sie es nicht machen.
Ich glaub schon.
Passwörter in Klartext, in Logfiles reinschreiben, das ist schon ganz schön bäbä.
Um es mal freundlich zu vornehmen.
Das ist schon mega-fail.
Das ist schon echt mega-fail.
Microsoft würde man damit einfach nix. Und warten, dass 10.7.4 rauskommt.
Ja, das könnte jetzt sowieso, es könnte mal 10.7.9 rauskommen, weil gefühlt braucht es ja wohl noch so viele Releases bis dieses Line mal halbwegs Das heißt aber Mountain Line des 10.7.9, ne? Das ist ja noch schlimmer. Ich finde das schon ein bisschen frech, ein neues Betriebssystem release, ein Major Release rauszubringen, während das andere noch nicht mal so weit gepatcht ist, dass es zumindest halbwegs geht.
Zum Beispiel dieser Slider unten am Fenster, um die Icons größer und kleiner zu zoomen, geht immer noch nicht. Manchmal, aber...
Jetzt alle klicken, Jungs.
Ja, manchmal geht es auf Anhieb.
Wieso soll der nicht gehen?
Ja, nee, das hatte ich auch, diesen Eindruck, dass es doch eigentlich geht, aber es geht... Ihr werdet es feststellen. Früher oder später, ihr probiert es jetzt einfach den nächsten Tag immer mal wieder aus. Probiert es aber den nächsten Tag immer mal wieder aus.
Dann kann ich ja solange mal ein bisschen von meinem Drucker erzählen.
Gibt es die noch?
Hast du ja einen gekauft?
Ich dachte, hin und wieder will man ja doch mal was drucken. Also eigentlich war es eine Idee der Freundin. Ich dachte, wenn die Freundin sich mal Technik wünscht, dann werde ich dem nicht im Wege stehen. Ich habe einen Drucker gekauft. Ich habe bei Amazon eingegeben Air Print und Laser, weil ich wollte keinen Tintenstrahldrucker haben, weil Tintenstrahldrucker... Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, mir geht es halt so.
Und dann kam HP bei raus.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich irgendwo die Tinte... Also wenn man was drucken will, habe ich die Tinte eingetrocknet. Und dann kam HP bei raus und dann habe ich mir für 88 Euro, die Dinger sind ja echt billig geworden, einen HP LaserJet P1102W gekauft mit Air Print und allem Peppapo und ich...
Proven, setz die Nummer unter Ihrer Landesleiter....
kann euch nur dringend davon abraten, den zu kaufen. Achso. Also ich glaube, ich werde den zurückschicken, weil...
Er hat es jetzt ausgedruckt schon.
Die Seite ist gedruckt. Nee, ich habe wirklich, das ist... Der ist relativ klein, das ist alles soweit okay und der funktioniert auch per USB. Und da ist nämlich mal das schöne Line-Feature, was man dringend haben will. Er hat halt Air Print, also man kann vom iPhone und vom iPad aus problemlos drucken. Aber man kann mit einem Line-Macbook kann man auch ohne irgendwie Druckertreiber-Installation drucken. Und endlich ist drucken mal so, wie man es erwartet hat. Nämlich du sagst drucken im Fenster und dann erscheint da, ja ich hab hier dann hier einen Drucker gefunden, willst du auf dem drucken? Und so ja, druck da drauf, dann drückst du drucken und dann ist das gedruckt. So, halt eigentlich so, wie es seit 20 Jahren hätte sein müssen. Das ist alles total... Ach, meinetwegen auch nur 15, auf jeden Fall schon länger. Und das ist eigentlich ganz großartig und ist auch relativ schnell. Was halt die elende Scheiße ist, dass er sich mit meinem WLAN überhaupt nicht verträgt. Also ich hab, und zwar auf mehreren Ebenen gleichzeitig, so dass ich mir sehr sicher bin, dass es nicht nur mein Setup ist, sondern dass es auch ein generelles Problem ist, also dass das Ding echt ein Problem hat. Also zum einen ist es, ich hab da ja schlechten WLAN-Empfang in meiner Wohnung, habe ich mehrere WLAN-Stationen, die alle denselben Namen haben, weil sich jedes halbwegs intelligente Gerät einfach, dass die WLAN-Station mit dem besten Empfang raussucht und man hat damit keinen Stress. Jetzt ist ein HP-Drucker aber kein halbwegs intelligentes Gerät und schnappt sich offenbar einfach den ersten Hotspot, den es findet, der ist, ich weiß nicht welcher von denen das ist, auf jeden Fall ist es so, er sucht ne Weile, probiert, probiert, probiert, okay klappt nicht, geb ich auf. So, dann hat er halt keine WLAN-Verbindung. Dann hab ich extra dafür den einen Hotspot umgenannt, hab ihn damit verbunden. Ja, und das funktioniert auch alles so weit, also man kann drucken und dann geht er nach einer Weile, geht an Standby und dann kann man, wenn man dann sagt drucken, dann wacht er auf den Standby auf und dann kann man drucken und das ist alles gut, außer dass er nach einer Weile, erscheint er dann einfach nicht mehr. Dann hat er die Verbindung gekappt und dann erscheint er einfach nicht mehr an dem Auswahl-Dialog und dann weigert er sich auch, also dann kannst du ihn auch einschalten, dann verbindet er sich nicht erneut mit dem WLAN und dann musst du ausschalten, einschalten, Stecker rein, blablabla. Also jedes Mal, wenn man Stress hat, die gleichen Probleme. Und was halt wirklich auch noch, die Konfiguration ist auch ein Pain. Und die Konfiguration ist auch so scheiße gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie das geschafft haben. Also das ist kein HTML-Problem, sondern die müssen in dem HTTP-Stack, den die da eingebaut haben, Stress geben, weil der funktioniert mit Safari und mit Chrome. Hört der Drucker einfach zwischendurch, manchmal für mehrere Minuten aufzureagieren. Wenn du mit Firefox das ganze Ding konfigurierst, ist alles gut, dann lässt er sich auch konfigurieren, aber kommt da erst mal drauf. Aber wenn du dich jetzt irgendwie das probierst, zuerst mit Chrome, okay, dann probier ich es nochmal mit Safari, ob es damit geht. Genau das gleiche Problem, da wird du am Drucker liegen. Mit Firefox ging es dann problemlos. Also wirklich so ein Haufen Dreck. Und ich dachte, das könnten sie. Ich dachte HP könnte Drucker bauen.
Die können Drucker bauen, aber das Ding ist, früher hießen Laserjets nur bestimmte Drucker und das waren dann halt auch richtige Laserjets. Und die bauen sie auch immer noch, aber die kosten halt, die sind immer noch große Klötze und die kosten immer noch richtig viel Geld. Aber die performen auch, also da fliegt so das Papier nur so raus und die, die, die sind echt gut so. Aber alles andere so in diesem 80 oder Sub 100 oder Sub 200 Bereich, kannst du glaube ich direkt nehmen.
Das würde ich so unterschreiben. Abgesehen davon wireless, so für kritische Infrastruktur.
Kritisch wie jetzt?
Rocker ist kritisch. Ach!
Na ja, auf jeden Fall würde ich, ich würde glaube ich Drucker auch nicht ins WLAN hängen.
Soll ich jetzt anfangen wegen?
Also ich erwäge mir auch gerade einen neuen zu kaufen. Also ich erwäge das schon länger, bin aber noch ein bisschen zurückhaltend, weil ich aber nicht so richtig weiß, ob ich wirklich Farbe brauche. Aber dann doch immer ganz geil finde, wenn ich welche habe, so aus irgendwelchen Erwägungen. Und wie Huckel schon sagt, also bei diesen größeren Geräten, hab ich jetzt, also das kann natürlich immer passieren, gerade diese Web-Interfaces, so richtig überzeugend war das noch nie. Aber so im Großen und Ganzen sind die schon ganz gut und ich mag eigentlich auch diese ganzen All-in-One-Geschichten, weil die halt jetzt in letzter Zeit extrem gut integriert sind, weil das ist echt out of the box. Also du schaltest die Teile ein und du hast halt einfach mal ohne Treiberinstallation Scanner voll integriert in die Standard-Apple-Printer-Environments etc. Muss da nicht noch irgendein General-Universal-Installer, der dir dann erstmal 30% CPU dauerhaft wegnimmt, installieren und so ein Scheiß. Das gab es ja alles schon mal.
Aber ich meine, in der Uni haben wir gerade halt so wirklich die so richtig nur schwarz-weiß-laser-dicken-fetten Laser-Jet-Maschine, damit ohne Schnicken-Fatz und was find ich gesehen? Genau, das ist so wie Laser-Jet auch schon früher.
Aber ich finde das ist alles viel zu billig irgendwie. Das ist einfach so 80 Euro irgendwie ein Laserdrucker.
Wie machen die das?
Na ja, wie?
Also der dicke Laser-Jet hat irgendwas über 1000 Euro.
Also wenn sie es anbieten, soll es einfach funktionieren der Scheiß. Das klingt mir auch sehr nach einem Software-Problem und nicht nach einem Hardware-Problem, wenn sie das Setup nicht richtig auf die Reihe kriegen. Und ich will ja auch, also ich brauche das Ding im Wesentlichen, um hin und wieder mal ein Bahnticket auszudrucken. Ich brauche ansonsten keinen Drucker. Und ich will dafür keine scheiß 1000 Euro ausgehen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, diese Billig-Printer, da ist HP echt einfach die falsche Adresse. Da gibt es wirklich andere.
Ja, ja, also offensichtlich. Und jetzt gab es hier im Chat Empfehlungen, ob ich doch mal die Firmware updaten soll. Also ich habe jetzt, er hat mir direkt, als ich das erste Mal das Ding gestartet habe, gesagt, ich habe eine neue Firmware. Mach mal und soll ich installieren? Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, mach installieren. Und ich gehe mal aus, dass dann die neueste Version drauf ist. Kann natürlich alles täuschen und er hat danach immer noch nicht die neueste Version der Firmware drauf. Ich hoffe mal aber schon. Das nächste Problem ist, jetzt hat mir jemand hier so einen Link geschickt auf die Seite. Und jetzt ist, so soll ich das Betriebssystem auswählen? Jetzt habe ich hier Mac OS X ausgewählt. Jetzt sage ich hier weiter und dann fragt mich das Ding, Sie befinden sich auf der HP-Kundendienst-Webseite in Deutschland. Möchten Sie auf dieser Webseite fortfahren? Ja, was weißt du, warum ich weitergeklickt habe?
Sei froh, dass du nicht auf der Mobile-Page gelandet bist. Du wirst überhaupt nichts mehr wiederfinden.
Nee, also das ist, also...
Du prangerst das an.
Ich finde das furchtbar. Ich hätte mich echt gern positiv über diesen Drucker berechnet, weil eigentlich ist er klein und nett und passt in den Schrank und unauffällig und alles. Jetzt passiert nichts, nachdem ich weitergeklickt habe.
Diese Namen sind auch geil.
Was sind das hier für eine...
Diese Namen sind bei den Laserdruckern so ähnlich wie die Produktnamen bei Microsoft.
Hier passiert schlicht...
Ach, dein Na...
So, wollen wir mal zum nächsten Thema, weil es jetzt nicht so spannend mit dem Drucker, der nicht geht.
Gerne. Max. Wir bleiben noch bei Max. Oder? Gibt es noch was zu Max?
Ich hab mal eine Frage an die versammelte Mannschaft, weil... Ich hab mir jetzt so eine AirPods Express gekauft, so ein Musikstream. Gibt es eigentlich irgendwelche Software außer iTunes, die Airplay auf dem Desktop bildet? Okay, aber ich hatte zum Beispiel erwartet, dass wenn ich in einen Trailer auf Apple komm und gucke, mit QuickTime und so, dass ich dann im QuickTime Player auf Airplay klicken kann. Ja, aber warum nicht QuickTime?
Vor allem, weil es auf dem iPad geht.
Apple ist vorbei.
Mountainline, sobald ich mich erinnere, ist das jetzt dann mit drin.
Okay, Frage erledigt, gut. Aber ansonsten...
Aber du kannst mit deinem Telefon Videos abspielen.
Ja, mit dem Telefon und so, super. Ich sitze da manchmal halt auch mit dem Mac und hab kein Kabel drin und will kein Kabel reinstecken, sondern jetzt über die große Box, Trailer gucken und dann...
Ja, aber R-Foll kann man durchaus empfehlen. Das ist da so die Zwischenlösung, aber so richtig glücklich macht das auch alles nicht.
Okay, okay, dann war das eine kurze Frage für zwischendurch, die sich nun mehr... So, nächstes Mac-Thema. Kommen sie, kommen sie alle ran.
Da ist mal wieder so ein Patent veröffentlicht worden, das mir das Gefühl geben will, dass es irgendwann doch noch mal Mac-Box gäbe mit... Simkarte. Believer. Ich könnte skeptischer nicht sein. Ich sag nur, dieses Patent ist veröffentlicht worden. Was mir die Frage ist, was ist eigentlich genau der Zeitpunkt, wo diese Patente dann irgendwie öffentlich gemacht werden?
Da muss man mit Pavel vielleicht drüber sprechen.
Ist das irgendwie...
Wenn sie angenommen werden.
Ja, aber kann man dann irgendwie das auch noch verzögern? Verzögert Apple sowas?
Apple hat so viel komische Sachen patentiert.
Müssen die dann auch automatisch... Das ist ja eigentlich der Sinn von Patenten.
Nee, die müssen veröffentlicht werden. Das ist ja eigentlich... Ich glaube, die reichen einfach spät genug ein. Im Allgemeinen.
Spät genug einreichen ist natürlich auch nicht so eine gute Idee, wenn es um Patente geht.
Wenn ein anderer schneller war. Du reichst es einfach ein, kurz bevor du das Produkt rausbringst. Dann hat es noch keiner gesehen, im Idealfall.
Im Endeffekt wäre jemand anders... Wenn die offensichtlich ist.
Nee, das glaube ich nicht, dass sie das tun. Weil das ist, erstens riskierst du damit nur, dass irgendjemand anderes was ähnliches einreicht, womit du dann Probleme kriegst. Zweitens ist es bei Apple ohnehin seltenst so gewesen, dass man mit dem veröffentlichen Zeitpunkt irgendeines Patents, irgendein Produkt danach in sich weiter.
Ich verwechsel das gerade mit der FCC-Erlaubnis hier.
Exakt, das ist was ganz anderes.
Hast du einen Link auf das Patent irgendwo?
Das ist auf patentlyapple.com, die ja immer ganz fleißig da dran sind und sich da auch immer richtig durchlesen und beschreiben, wie denn das so ist. Und das handelt sich dabei um eine Antenne, die oben im Bildschirm ist, so links von der Kamera ungefähr. Und von wann ist das Patent? Das Patent, also das Posting ist von gestern.
Post doch mal in den Chat.
Bei patents.google.com ist das letzte Apple-Patent erst noch von Dezember 2011. Und da gibt es 80.100 Patente von Apple.
Ist ja auch so gut.
Also hier steht jetzt nichts. Apple Quills in Riegel, la. Which was originally filed in quarter 3 2008. Also das Patent wurde drittes Quartal 2008 eingereicht. Das ist schon sehr lange her. Und sonst steht jetzt hier nichts dazu. Aber ich nehme mal, wie ich das verstanden habe, ist diese Webseite quasi immer am Strom. Also wenn das jetzt veröffentlicht wird, dann kann das jetzt auch nicht so lange her sein.
Könnte das in der Zeit gewesen sein, als damals dieses 3G-Macbook auf, also es gab doch mal bei diesem 3G-Macbook auf eBay aufgetaucht, so ein Prototyp. Könnte der nicht grob aus der Zeit stammen?
Aber da hatten sie ja diese komische Antenne zum Ausfahren.
Na ja, da haben sie wahrscheinlich verschiedene Prototypen gebaut.
Das war wahrscheinlich wirklich so ein richtiger Prototyp, Prototyp, Prototyp, wo sie einfach nur die Usability getestet haben, was ihnen das eigentlich jetzt bringt. Unabhängig jetzt vom Hardware-Design, es war da so rangebammelt, damit es überhaupt irgendwie dran ist und möglich, dass sie sowas wirklich hätten ausliefern wollen. Naja, also mir fällt mir jetzt auch nicht ein zum Max.
Und zwar, heute Morgen ging das rum. Das ist so eine kleine, eigentlich sehr hübsche App, die heißt Dragndrop.
Hast du das schon ausprobiert?
Ich hab's ausprobiert, ich hab's sofort gekauft. Bevor ihr's kauft, es gibt eine Trial-Version, ich würde auch dringend dazu raten, die auszuprobieren, weil so 100% nicht damit zufrieden bin ich nicht. Aber es ist schon sehr geil. Es ist nämlich, wenn man mal zwischendurch, also was weiß ich, wenn man den Screen wechseln will oder wenn man will einen Tab wechseln oder so, während man mitten in einem Drag-and-Drop ist, dann ist das quasi so ein Ablageort, wo man die gedrackten Sachen ablegen kann. Davon gibt es jetzt relativ viele, die das machen, sodass die irgendwie im Dock irgendwie ein Alkenhau und dann lässt man das halt ins Dock fallen, dann geht so ein Fenster auf, auf dem man es direkt wieder rausziehen kann. Was bei denen das Schöne ist, die haben halt eigentlich einfach keine Fläche dafür. Sondern es ist, man muss kurz mit der Maus oder mit dem Trackpad so ein bisschen wackeln. Und dann erscheint direkt unter dem Maus-Cursor erscheint das Dragon-Drop-Fenster. Und da, das sieht auch aus wie so ein kleines Wurmloch. Und dann kann ich es dann direkt reinfallen lassen. Und dann ist das Fenster da. Also es ist nicht da, wenn man es gerade nicht braucht. Und sobald man es braucht, ist es da. Ich würde aber vorher, es kostet 5 Dollar, also hier diese mittlere Preissegment da. Und insofern würde ich raten, probiert mal die Trial-Version aus. Bei mir funktioniert das mit dem Dragon, also mit dem Wackeln, mit dem Maus wackeln nicht so gut, weil ich ein Trackpad habe. Da sollten sie noch nachbessern. Aber ansonsten sehr, sehr geile Idee.
Du hast keine Alternative zum Maus wackeln? Kann man nicht irgendwas anderes tun?
Du kannst auch ein Icon oben in der Menüleiste einblenden, wo du es drauf fallen lassen kannst. Das ist dann quasi die klassische Funktionalität. Aber genau das ist eigentlich das, was ich... So ein Shelf.... noch so ein Icon da oben drin haben, das finde ich ja doch eher doof. Nachdem er jetzt noch Google Drive mit sich breit gemacht hat und weiß ja toll, wird ja immer mehr, was da oben in der Dog-Leiste ist.
Daniels weist mich hier gerade noch im Chat hin auf eine kleine, nette App, die heißt Bartender. Die sieht auch wirklich ganz schnuckelig aus.
Die habe ich wieder rausgeschmissen.
Ja, das ist so ein Tool, was dir die Menu-Bar-Icons irgendwie konfigurierbar und separierbar macht, sodass du die alle raus aus dem Menü rausnimmst oder überhaupt laufen lässt, aber nicht einblendest oder separat anzeigen kannst und halten kannst, dass da oben nicht so viel Alarm ist.
Was bei mir damit das Problem war, der konnte gar nicht so unglaublich viele von diesen Menu-Items ausblenden. Und dann hatte ich oben dieses Bartender-Icon da oben in der Menüleiste drin und hatte insgesamt nur zwei Icons überhaupt, die dann in dieser separaten, also es macht so eine separate Menüleiste nochmal für so ein paar Icons, die man nicht die ganze Zeit in der Menüleiste haben möchte, was eigentlich schon mal darauf hindeutet, wie kaputt dieses Konzept eigentlich mittlerweile ist. Und das funktioniert nicht wirklich gut, wie ich finde.
Dann sollten wir mal darüber reden, was wir alle so in unserer Menüleiste haben.
Gleich.
Nach der Werbung.
Wenn wir weit schnappen der Werbung.
Ich habe noch eine Frage zum Thema Airport Stations. Ich habe ja meine Airport, ich habe eine Extreme nur, ich habe die lange nicht angefasst und ich kann mich noch an die goldenen Zeiten erinnern, an denen wir davon schwärmten, dass ja die Airport Stations von Apple signifikant zum IPv6 Traffic der Welt beitragen würden, weil es ja diese Optionen gibt, sobald da irgendwas am Warnport hängt, dass sie dann halt 604 IPv6 Tunnel foo machen. Jetzt, verschiedene US-Generationen später und diverse Airport Utility Updates später, komme ich mal wieder dazu, die Konfiguration meiner Airport Extreme anzuschauen, weil ich feststellte, Moment, das hängt was am Warnport und ich hab keinen V6 Tunnel. Guck also rein, an dieses Airport Utility ist jetzt komplett so ein Kinderspielzeug geworden. Da gibt es ja nix mehr.
Da gibt es ja nix mehr.
Gibt's die noch? Und dann kann man noch den Tunnel einschalten.
Was ist da los?
Airport Utility und es gibt Airport Utility 5.6 und das brauchst du.
Guter Tipp, Freunde.
Aber da geht gerade irgendwas mit IPv6. Also ich hab auch irgendwas gelesen, aber noch nicht so richtig recherchiert, was es damit auf sich hat.
Irgendwie haben sie es aus dem neuen Utility herausgenommen.
Für Mountainline, wo du jetzt sogar IPv6-Pflicht hast oder so was. Dass jetzt deine Ups, wenn sie Networking machen, auf jeden Fall auch IPv6 können müssen.
Du hast ja auch hier V6, ne? Ich hab grad gesehen, dass ich...
Ja, ich hab hier richtig V6.
Du hast Native V6? Hast du getunnelt V6?
Na, 6SS, aber halt eigene Adressen. Und nicht jedes Mal wieder dynamischer.
Darf ich dann vielleicht noch so einen kurzen nicht-Apple-Themen-Abzweig machen? Weil wir gleich schon da sind, bei diesem spannenden V6-Thema? Ich hab mir jetzt ja einen eigenen Server geklickt, ne? Mein erster, eigener Server?
Eigentlich wollte ich dich ja überreden, dass du auf meinen kommst. Das heißt, bei mir ein bisschen, wir teilen uns.
Den.
Und ich hab mir den hier...
My Little Server, My Little Server.
Oh, jetzt ist er schon wieder in der Pony-Welt.
Und die Staubsetteln lassen.
Also, My Little Server und was da drauf?
Nee, völlig gut. Weil ich bin ja auch so ein BSD-Junge. Alte CCC-Schule. Und dann ist ja die Wahl schon mal für einen Hoster schwierig. Und ich bin tatsächlich erstmal bei Hetzner wieder gelandet. Ich hatte ja früher so ein schlechtes Bild von Hetzner, aber in der Firma benutzt man das ja auch gelegentlich als Hoster. Geben wir dem noch mal eine Chance. Und die werben auch damit, dass FreeBSD geht.
FreeBSD ist Magic.
Und bei Hetzer muss man ja, wenn man seinen eigenen Server jetzt will, muss man verschiedene Dinge wissen. Erstens, Hetzer hat halt keine Server-Grade-Hardware, sondern so nicht richtig Desktop, aber auch nicht so richtig Server-Hardware. Also es ist schon eher Desktop-Komponenten als Server-Komponenten. Das heißt, du kriegst zwar einen Quad-Core, das ist ein i7, aber kein Xeon halt. Oder du kriegst schon eine Gigabit-Ethernet-Karte, aber es ist halt nicht eine Intel-Karte, sondern ein Realtek. Also, wenn man so richtig performance-mäßig da irgendwie ans Limit gehen will, hättest du eine?
Jetzt kommt gleich Hetzner an.
Aber wenn man so einen privaten Server haben will, für günstiges Geld und mit coolem Interface, dann ist Hetzner vielleicht schon eine Option. Denn ich hab da geklickt und dachte mir, ok, FreeBSD, super. Klick den Server, steht dann bei der Installationsauswahl natürlich kein FreeBSD-Image mehr, sondern nur noch Linux-Images. Da dachte ich mir schon, geil, gleich zu Beginn verarscht. Ok, klick mal erstmal weiter. Und dann konnte man aber ein FreeBSD Rescue-System booten und sagen, jetzt dachte ich so, da hab ich mich schon darauf eingestellt, jetzt muss ich alles manuell mal einen ZFS booten und den ganzen Kram, das dauert ja dann immer einen halben Tag. Aber nee, Hetzner hat so ein Install-Image. Gibt's einfach ein Install-Image und zack, kommt so eine GUI hoch und sagt dir, hey, hier FreeBSD installieren willst du, willst du vielleicht ZFS?
Die kommst du ja auf die GUI drauf.
Ist das Haar-GUI?
Ja, das ist so Endcurses, aber ist schon so ein bisschen clicky-bunt. Überraschend gut, ja.
Aber ohne clicky.
Na, jetzt bleibt er aber ruhig.
Also, wenn du den Terminal mit Maus-Click-Events, also egal, auf jeden Fall, wenige Klicks später, also wirklich innerhalb von wenigen Minuten, einstattig Minuten, hatte ich einen FreeBSD mit ZFS und Mürrer und Booten, drei Terabyte gemürrerte Platte, 16 Gigagramm, Quad-Core, nee, ja doch Quad-Core mit, nee, 8, doch Quad-Core mit Hyperthreading, aber immerhin. Und clicky-bunti, zack, am Start. IPv6 gibt's auch gratis dazu. Hast du dann halt, gibt's ja jetzt überall wahrscheinlich bei den Hostern, aber hast ja halt auch so dein eigenes Slash64 am Start. Und IP-Adressen sind auch vergleichsweise billig. Also kann man schon mal machen. Wenn man mal einen eigenen Server, wenn man so diese Schritte von Tumblr-Block, Webspace mit eigenem WordPress, vielleicht einen Shared Host und dann jetzt den Schritt zum eigenen Server machen will, dann ist glaube ich Hetzener so preis- und leistungstechnisch doch eine ganz gute Alternative.
Der kleine Huckel wird langsam flügelt.
Ja, ich bin ja schon...
Ich erinnere mich damals noch.
Als wir sein erstes Blog aufsetzten.
Am ersten Macintosh im Kinderzimmer.
Und mein erster Router. War ja so ein zusammengebröseltes Board mit Platte daneben liegen, Netzteil daneben liegen und ein FreeBSD natürlich. FreeBSD 4, irgendwas.
Heute bin ich selbst der Opa und installiere meinem Enkel das FreeBSD.
Auf jeden Fall. Das Coole ist, bei Hetzener gibt es halt ein echt schickes Webinterface. Also da haben sie sich extrem Mühe gegeben, das hab ich bei anderen Hostern so noch nicht gesehen. Du kannst halt wirklich echt viel machen. Du klickst dir deine IPs, kriegst du sofort, kriegst deinen IPv6, kriegst du sofort, kannst deinen Rechner neu starten, was auch immer du hast, wenn du eine Lienung hast, auf VNC-Konsole gleich im Browser und alles. Also schon.
Ich bin schon ewig bei Hetzener und bin eigentlich immer ganz zufrieden mit denen. Der Reset-Button kostet bei denen extra, das ist sehr, sehr nervig. Und was die bei Strato, das ist zum Beispiel inklusive, das gibt es bei Hetzener auch nicht. Die haben eine Konsole, an die du auch noch rankommst, wenn dein Rechner keine Netzverbindung mehr hat. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool, aber habe ich auch nie gebraucht.
Noch eine Sache, die man bei Hetzener wissen muss, ihre Netzwerkinfrastruktur ist auch ein bisschen broken. Wenn man so richtig Performance und hohe Zuverlässigkeit und so weiter braucht, dann geht es woanders hin, aber für eigenen Server und Webseite und ein bisschen Traffic machen, super.
Also wir hatten ja immer die verrückte Idee, unseren Trecker bei Hetzener irgendwie zu hosten. Und dann ging der auf einmal nicht mehr, haben wir irgendwie mit denen ge-emailt, was los ist. Und da meinten sie, das wäre halt eine DOS-Attacke auf unseren Server. Dann meinten wir, das wäre alles schon direkt und unser Server kann das ab. Und dann haben sie das, glaube ich, wieder eingeschaltet oder so. Aber dann ist davor deren Router zusammengebrochen, weil sie den Storm nicht ausgehalten haben. Und dann meinten sie, wir sollen mal weggehen.
Ich hab ja hosten damit die ganzen Podcasts, also nicht die ganzen, sondern WMR, also meine Podcasts da drauf. Und das ist mittlerweile so, dass es einfach die 100 MBit vollkriegt. Und das halten die auch gut durch.
Aber jetzt die entscheidende Frage, sind deine Podcasts schon über IPv6 verfügbar?
Äh, garantiert nicht.
Ja, weil das war, das habe ich jetzt heldenhafterweise gleich getan, alle meine Webseiten darüber portiert, alles auf IPv6 an den Start gebracht. Also ich bin bereit für die Zukunft, die sich so seit 20 Jahren, oder wie lange gibt es IPv6 schon? In der Mache ist, ja.
Zukunft, Huckel steht schon da.
Genau, und Hausaufgabe zum nächsten Mal, liebe Mobile-Max-Hörer, eure Webseiten, auch eure Webseiten, sollen bis zum nächsten Mal über IPv6 verfügbar sein, jawohl.
Na, solange die Leute zu Hause nicht mit DSL IPv6 haben.
Solange man in FreeBSD-Jails keinen IPv6 kriegt. Seit wann?
Schon lange, seit acht irgendwas.
Schnarchnase.
Schnarchnase, echt mal. Also ich habe ja schon seit über einem Jahr schon vor sechs in Jails, oder zweien.
Du kriegst sogar Local Hosts inzwischen, richtig?
Ja, FreeBSD ist super, Jungs.
Muss ich dich gleich mal einklagen irgendwie? Also ich kann ja...
Das FreeBSD Reinheitsgebot herrscht.
Das wird auf jeden Fall da durchgezogen.
Praktiziert.
Und ja, da läuft auch mein Metaebene, ME-Kram und so weiter, läuft auch alles auf FreibSD.
Ja und dann du auch...
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich da FPV6 habe.
Nein, das musst du dir halt mal rauf konfigurieren lassen. Nee, aber deswegen fragte ich eben auch. Dann hatte ich halt V6 auf dem Server und dachte mir, geil, jetzt muss ich das über die Uni oder überall meine anderen Server testen. Warum habe ich kein V6000? Okay, dieses Airport-Utility, das gibt es irgendwo auf der Apple-Seite. Na herrlich.
Ja, kann ich dir sonst auch noch geben. Was sie da geritten hat, weiß ich nicht, aber ich vermute mal, sie wollen irgendwie da die Automatiken befördern und...
Aber warum, warum? Ich meine, ist doch okay, wenn sie das hinter so einem Advanced-Button oder so verstecken. Soll ja vielleicht nicht jeder mit rumspielen, aber die, die mit rumspielen wollen, warum lassen sie den?
Vielleicht ist der Advanced-Button einfach so gut versteckt, dass er ihn noch nicht gefunden hat.
Da war ja auch einmal die Presse rauf und runter.
Da finden wir eine richtige Advanced-Ute.
Das war doch aber auch in der Presse rauf und runter, dass Apple jetzt alle machen V6 und Apple nimmt es raus.
Echt?
Ja, das haben wir die Konfiguration rausgenommen.
Ja, aber das ist klar.
Ja, aber wenn jetzt die Telekom auf V6 umschaltet, dann machen die halt wahrscheinlich auch sofort V6.
Genau, der Advanced-Button ist nur bei iFly V6 erreichbar.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich schon... Ja, nee, das kann ich mir sogar vorstellen, dass die sofort iPV6 machen, aber ich will es einstellen. Verdammt, da gibt es halt Optionen, die man schon mal einstellen will.
Naja, ich meine, da hast du wirklich Konfigurations...
Ja, so langsam hätte ich da auch tatsächlich Bock drauf, weil mich dieser irgendwie...
Das unterstützt halt auch diesen 6XS.
Ich bin ja mit 6 to 4... Ich brauche ja zuhause keinen Reverse Resolvable V6, aber...
Naja, feste Adressen sind feste Adressen.
Ach, ich bin ja mal drauf gespannt, wenn alle langsam drauf kommen, dass es mit iPV6 dann feste Adressen gibt und wenn dann die Datenschützer das bemerken, dass man ja keine...
Das haben die schon lange bemerkt, aber das ist ja schon entgegengearbeitet worden. Das Thema ist eigentlich schon wieder durch, aber es wird trotzdem wieder aufgeholt.
Ach, das kommt noch ein paar Mal.
So, wollen wir uns mal ins iOS-Land aufmachen?
Das ist nicht so genau.
Da gibt es auf jeden Fall mehr.
Ach so, na dann.
My Little iOS.
Vor allem im Bereich... Also erstmal gab es ja iOS 5.1.1.
Und ich sag mal, hier eine 5.1-Update, da hat meine Freundin auf dem iOS kein mobiles Internet mehr, und da war 5.1.1 die Rettung, hat wieder mobiles Internet enabled.
Wie, und die ganze Zeit zwischendurch ging das nicht?
Na, sie hatte erst vor ein paar Tagen, also kurz bevor 5.1.1 rauskam, abgegradet und dann irgendwie so, weiß ich, ich meine so die ganze Zeit, ja, ich war immer die letzten Updates, da war immer irgendwas und so, und jetzt so kurz vor Schluss hat sie dann upgrade und hat so drei Tage lang kein mobiles Internet. Ich meine, das ist schon so die Rage-Fiste, die ganze Zeit in der Luft und dann, hier, probier nochmal das Update und das Update hat glücklicherweise geholfen.
Die Beziehung ist wieder.
Drei Tage lang ohne mobiles Internet ausgerettet.
Ja, das war schwierig, ja. Wie gesagt, jeder soll keinen Zucker schlecken.
Darf ich mir vorstellen, das sorgt bestimmt für Verspannung.
Ja, aber 5.1.1 gepriesen sei der Herr.
Ich glaube, dieser Podcast-Bug ist nicht behoben worden, wo die Kapitelnamen dann irgendwie mal auch wieder angezeigt werden.
Die haben es ja auch nur schnell rausgeschoben, um die drei Security-Bugs zu fixen, oder? Mal ehrlich, der Rest, den hätten die auch erst mit 5.2.0 oder 6.0 irgendwie gemacht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube schon. Apple ist ganz schön faul geworden, was Bugfixes angeht, so lange, so lange es nicht irgendwie Security-Geschichten sind. Und selbst dann sind sie, glaube ich, ganz schön hinterher.
Ich glaube, da sind ein paar Leaks weg, weil wir hatten vorher, hatten wir bei Screenfeeder so das Problem, dass der nach ein paar Stunden offensichtlich uns der Speicherfolge laufen ist. Und die sind nicht komplett weg, aber deutlich besser geworden. Also da scheint, und das ist dann offensichtlich nicht auf unserer Seite gewesen, der Bug, sondern auf Apples Seite. Also wenn ihr Probleme mit App-Absturzen habt, nach längerer Zeit, die lange durchlaufen müssen oder sowas, dann ist 5.1.1 vielleicht das Richtige für euch.
Ja, also ich hab's mir installiert, keine Änderung. Was vielleicht auch mal ganz beruhigend ist. Ja, ansonsten gab es aber noch ein sehr interessantes Update, auf das ich euch alle hinweisen möchte, wenn ihr es nicht sowieso schon bemerkt habt. Nämlich Instacast, der Podcast-Client meiner Wahl zumindest, der hat den Sprung auf die 2.0 gemacht. Ich war auch schon längere Zeit Beta-Tester und das ist alles sehr nett, was da dazugekommen ist. Erstens finde ich, hat das User-Interface deutlich an Einfachheit dazugewonnen, aber vor allem auch an Features.
Wobei ich nicht alle Buttons verstehe in diesem Interface.
Ja, habe ich am Anfang auch nicht.
Wo fürs denn der mit dem Pfeil drauf?
Tja, der ist komisch. Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es die Einstellung, ob er automatisch zum nächsten Podcast in der Playlist weiterspringen soll oder nicht. Oder ob du sogar rückwärts...
Immer wieder von vorne denselben.
Also du kannst sozusagen vorwärts und rückwärts durch eine Playlist automatisch. Wenn da sozusagen mehrere drin sind, die du auch wirklich nacheinander hören willst, was du ja wahrscheinlich normalerweise nicht willst, dann kannst du das in diesem Player jetzt umstellen.
Es kommt immer auf die Länge der Podcasts an, finde ich. Es gibt so viele so kürzere Sachen aus dem öffentlichen rechtlichen Radio. So drei Minuten Beiträge, fünf Minuten Beiträge. Wenn man die hört und du hörst einen und danach ist wieder Ruhe. Und dann musst du wieder den nächsten annavigieren und dann hörst du wieder drei Minuten was, dann hast du wieder Ruhe. Das finde ich total nervig. Also für sowas finde ich das sehr gut, wenn die einfach weiterlaufen.
Genau, dann macht es eigentlich auch Sinn, dass das im Player-Interface drin ist. Und nicht nur so ein Hidden-Feature und per Podcast eingestellt etc. Aber gut, das benutze ich jetzt nicht so sehr. Was interessant ist, es gibt jetzt generell so Playlists und da auch die sogenannten Smart-Playlists. Und damit hat ein Feature-Einzug gehalten, was ich ja selbst vermisst habe, nämlich mal eine Playlist zu haben, die mir eben sagt, was ich denn zuletzt gespielt habe. Weil ich halt häufiger mal in einen Podcast reinhöre, dann den irgendwie nicht fertig höre, dann muss ich irgendwas anderes nochmal anhören und dann habe ich schon wieder vergessen, was ich eigentlich zuletzt gehört habe und kriege es nicht zu Ende gehört und finde es nicht wieder. Und das ist jetzt quasi weg. Jetzt kann man sich eben unter anderem auch so eine Liste anzeigen lassen, mit was man eben zuletzt alles so angespielt hat und sehen, ob man das schon zu Ende gehört hat und gegebenenfalls da eben nochmal einsteigen. Ja, dann kann man auch noch so irgendwie, was überhaupt geladen ist, ungespielte Sachen, Favoritendisten etc. Also die Funktionalität, die vorher da war, ist jetzt auch da, aber irgendwie anders. Und was da noch dazukommt, ist halt voll cool, ist so Bookmarking. Du kannst jetzt irgendwie an einer beliebigen Stelle sagen, hier Pause, jetzt mache ich mir eine Bookmark, die abspeichern oder auch posten. Das heißt, du kannst dann irgendwie raus twittern, hier, Mobile Max, alle drehen total am Rad, klick hier und dann bei default geht es dann eben auf so eine von Instacast auf der Webseite gehosteten Mini HTML-Interface zu diesem Podcast, wo du dann eben genau die Stelle dann auch sofort anspielen kannst. Also du kannst sozusagen direkt Deep Linking machen an der Stelle.
Ich habe auch direkt mehrere Links geschickt bekommen.
Und man kann Feed in seinem Feed sagen, in seinem Podcast Feed übrigens, ich unterstütze das auf meiner eigenen Seite. Ich habe es noch nicht getestet, obwohl es mein Wunschfeature war.
Genau. Und da gab es ja auch Kooperation zusammen mit dem PodLav Projekt, was ich da vor einiger Zeit mal angestoßen habe und dazu habe ich jetzt auch die passenden Spezifikationen veröffentlicht, die auf podlav.org zu finden ist, zum Deep Linking. Das ist halt eine Änderung, die in den Feed muss. Das ist jetzt derzeit noch nicht so einfach, weil es gibt eben noch keine Software, die das so out of the box unterstützt, es sei denn, man fängt dann irgendwie an, da seine Plugins zu patchen, oder man schreibt ohnehin seine, also wenn man seine Feeds ohnehin selber generiert, dann ist man da besser dran. Allerdings erfordert das eben, dass der Player, der muss dann eben aus der URL auch noch diese Informationen wiederum übernehmen.
Genau.
Also das wird sicherlich noch ein bisschen auf sich warten lassen und den Weg, den ein Instacaster geht, ist erstmal ganz cool, weil es geht jetzt sozusagen immer bei jedem Podcast und wenn der Podcast das selber unterstützen möchte, also gerne möchte, dass dieser Link dann auch direkt auf die eigene Seite geht, dann kann man das eben im Feed ausdrücken und dann wird das eben auch berücksichtigt.
Boah, hier beim Screenshot von Instacaster ist Mobile Max sogar ganz oben. Traum.
Genau, die haben auch so eigene Charts, da sind wir auch immer ziemlich weit. Jetzt war irgendwie Not Safer Work mal für ein paar Tage ganz oben, mal gucken, wo es jetzt gerade aussieht. Popular, German, immer noch ist Not Safer Work ganz oben.
Na so war's.
Die kriegen leider noch die Schokolade, das ist echt unsicht.
Daraus entnehmen wir, dass dieses Programm für unsere Hörerschaft auch durchaus relevant ist. Von daher sollten wir auch noch auf andere Eigenschaften hinweisen.
Auf die Autofletter-Funktion?
Ja, die ist ja nicht neu.
Ja, aber die ist trotzdem geil.
Ja gut, aber die gab's auch schon vorher. Super.
Was ist denn noch neu?
Was ist noch neu? Ich grübel gerade. Muss ich gerade mal nachdenken.
Ich probier das mal aus. Ich höre so selten Podcasts, aber weil ich alles schon leer gehört hab, die mich interessieren.
Also neu ist Push Notifications.
Stimmt.
Da gab's auch einige Konfusionen, weil alle meinten so, ich hatte doch schon vorher Push Notifications und jetzt soll das Geld kosten, weil es gibt jetzt Instacast Pro als In-App-Purchase. Das heißt, diverse Features. Also ich glaub, die normalen Playlisten sind jetzt irgendwie schon dabei oder werden dabei sein und die advanced Features, die kosten halt extra?
Ich glaub, die intelligenten Playlisten sind dabei und die normalen Playlisten sind pro Feature. Ich glaub, so rum war's.
Ich glaub, das wird sich im nächsten Update ändern. Aber Push Notifications etc., das ist halt nochmal ein Aufpreis. Und dann gab's irgendwie wieder Gemecker, weil das ja so unglaublich viel Geld ist. 1,80 Euro für zusätzliche Features. Aber Push Notifications kosten halt auch Geld. Da muss ein Server betrieben werden, etc. Also ich finde das mehr als nachvollziehbar.
Push Notifications Server zu schreiben, ist auch echt unangenehm.
Gar nicht.
Na ja, doch schon.
Ich hab schon Erlang gehackt, super. My First Erlang Project läuft.
Die Frage ist, was du da pusht. Also in dem Fall musst du halt tonnenweise Feeds die ganze Zeit durchchecken. Das erzeugt auch richtig Treffig und Last.
Aber die Push Notifications kannst du ja eh nicht so viel reinstecken und so. Also das ist jetzt...
Ja gut, aber du musst halt wissen, ob sie getriggert werden sollen oder nicht. Und dann musst du sie auch irgendwie rausschicken. Ja, also es gibt da allerlei Kooperationen mit dem Potluff-Projekt. Das finde ich sehr schön, weil das war nämlich der Sinn der ganzen Geschichte. Neben diesem Deep Linking halt auch noch so die Sache mit Alternate Feeds. Das muss ich auch erst noch ein bisschen rumsprechen, aber das ist ja auch alles noch ganz frisch. Und ich kann auch jedem Podcast-Autor, der hier zufälligerweise auch noch reingehört hat, nur ermutigen, da auf uns zuzukommen und vielleicht sich da ähnlich inspirieren zu lassen, damit das künftig alles noch viel toller wird. Jetzt nochmal, was war da noch neu? Also dieses ganze Player-Interface ist halt neu. Also das jetzt mit diesem Hochschieben und so weiter, das ist sehr viel netter. Es gibt jetzt so eine Download-Liste auch. Du kannst auch deine Downloads, wenn du mehrere hast, dann in der Reihenfolge sortieren etc. Also ist schon alles sehr viel eleganter geworden. Und auch Show Notes sind besser geworden. Also in diesem Player-Feld hast du jetzt nicht nur die Kapitelmarken, wenn es welche gibt, sondern wenn in den Show Notes Links sind, dann werden auch diese Links tabellarisch aufgelistet. Selbst wenn das so ein Linkwald ist, wie das jetzt bei Mobamex zum Beispiel der Fall ist üblicherweise, dann sind die da eben hintereinander, Zeile für Zeile, Link für Link gemacht.
Ja, das hab ich auch schon gesehen.
Das verbessert das alles. Ich denke, dass auch in diesem ganzen Show Notes Bereich da müssen wir noch eine ganze Menge machen. Also so spezifikationsmäßig. Aber das wird schon. Ich kann euch also alle nur empfehlen, da einen Upgrade zu machen, bzw. das überhaupt erstmal zu kaufen. Und auch gleich die Pro-Versionen dazu, weil da hat man ja auch noch diese netten Push Notifications. Ich kann jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau sagen, was jetzt eigentlich Pro ist und was nicht Pro ist.
In Other News, auch mit Sound, gerade eben ist die neue Soundcloud-Website als Beta gelauncht.
Wir sind für die schleichende Sachsifizierung dieses Podcasts.
Geht die wieder seitdem die Table gedroppt?
Ich wollte das noch kurz zurückstellen.
Das können wir kurz zurückstellen.
Weil ich wollte, wo wir jetzt noch gerade bei dem Podlauf waren, da nochmal kurz die Neuigkeiten zusammenfassen. Das dürfte euch ja auch interessieren, bzw. ihr habt es wahrscheinlich schon mitbekommen, Muckel und Dennis.
So halb, ja.
Bitlove. Neben Podlove gibt es jetzt auch Bitlove. Und das ist?
Die Ponys.
Friendship is love.
Das hat alles was mit Liebe zu tun, Max.
Guck mich dabei nicht so an.
Naja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein altes Wunschprojekt von mir, was der Astro gemacht hat, aus Dresden, der ja schon mal dieses BitTorrent gemacht hat, was überhaupt so BitTorrent Sealing macht. Also, dass man überhaupt Dateien mal per BitTorrent anbieten kann, weil alles andere ist ja immer auf Download orientiert. Was aber irgendwie fehlte ist, wenn man jetzt seine Podcasts per BitTorrent verteilen möchte, ja, etwas, was einem das einfach macht. Und klar, kannst du das jetzt irgendwie alles in deinen Workflow mit einbauen, dass wenn du eine Podcast veröffentlicht, dass du dann noch einen Torrent-File machst und dann hast du noch einen Tracker, der das irgendwie mitmacht oder so. Beziehungsweise der Hauptproblem ist, du musst halt erstmal irgendwie seeden, also musst die Datei, wenn sie dann online ist, auch irgendwie mitteilen, dass die jetzt auch noch mit geseedet wird, etc. Das ist irgendwie alles machbar, aber am Ende weist man sich dann die Zähne daran aus. Und bit.lav.org ist halt jetzt eine Webseite, die das komplett automatisiert. Das heißt, wenn man da seine Feeds anmeldet, dann checkt der irgendwie automatisch die Podcast-Feeds, lädt die sich runter, macht einen Torrent draus, seedet die, trägt die und dann gibt es eine Kopie von dem Original-Feed, wo halt alle Links, die direkt auf die Datei zeigen, eigentlich durch Links auf Torrents ersetzt werden. Das heißt, das ist jetzt eine Plattform, wo du einfach jeden Podcast zu betoren machen kannst. Schwerter zu Flugschanen, direkte Downloads zu betoren Downloads. Ich finde das total cool. Das ist wirklich ein mächtiges Prinzip, weil du musst halt als Podcast einfach nichts tun.
Und der Astro hat dann die ganzen Stats, die du haben wolltest, in den Trecker mit für dich eingebaut.
Das ist jetzt noch nicht in Alpha-Modus. Das heißt, es läuft jetzt erstmal an sich alles. Es gibt noch kein User-Interface, da wird aber dran gearbeitet. Und Statistiken werden schon fleißig gesammelt. Jetzt schon. Das ist ja der riesen Vorteil von BitTorrent. Die kleinen Sachen selber, wenn sie es runtergeladen haben. Das heißt, als Podcaster erhält man dann eben auch noch detaillierte und extrem akkurate Statistiken darüber, wie sehr das jetzt genutzt wurde. Jetzt wissen wir alle, dass BitTorrent Podcast-Clients nicht unbedingt in jedem Betriebssystem mitgeliefert werden heutzutage, sondern dass das noch eine sehr exotische Sache ist. Ich kenne tatsächlich nur zwei. Ich kenne Miro. Und U-Torrent hat das Feature mit drin.
Mikrotorrent.
Mütorrent.
Dass man aus dem RSS-Feed abonnieren kann. put.io hat es auch.
Was ist das?
Das ist so ein Online-Dienstleister für BitTorrent.
Online-Klient. Was heißt das? Das heißt, der lebt...
Die torrenten für dich.
Die torrenten für mich? Also die laden für mich runter?
Die laden für dich oder auch hoch. BitTorrent geht dir in alle Richtungen.
Und die machen Feeds.
Die machen auch Feeds, ja.
Das heißt, ich kann da einen BitTorrent Podcast Feed eintragen und dann?
Dann laden die das alles zu sich runter.
Ja. Und dann?
Und dann kannst du damit machen, was du willst. Kannst du bei denen laden, wenn du magst. Oder es gibt... Die haben auch so Clients. Oder kannst du das da auch konvertieren lassen in zum Beispiel ein iPhone taugliche Formate. Oder, oder, oder, oder.
Tun die mir das dann auch in die Dropbox?
Das weiß ich in nichts nicht.
Benutze das?
Gelegentlich.
Wofür?
So für Ubuntu-Distribution und so.
Achso.
Wofür man BitTorrent halt so nutzt?
Wikipedia-Dums. World of Warcraft-Updates.
Genau, dieses ganze Zeug, was man halt...
Ja, ich hatte in letzter Zeit auch totale Probleme, irgendwie an richtige Ubuntu-Updates ranzukommen.
Und du hast dich da natürlich mit deinen hochamtlichen, personenbezogenen Daten angemeldet?
Ja, du bist dir sicher, dass das geht, ja?
Mit RSS-Feed.
Und auch... Okay, alles klar, da steht's ja hier. Works with Torrents, alles klar. Was ist denn mit eurem Projekt, Huckel, Dennis? Ihr seid doch auch an einem BitTorrent...
Ja, das sind ja Macher, aber wir haben ja auch noch andere Sachen zu tun, obwohl Dennis...
Ich kann jetzt hiermit stolz verkünden, ja, dass ich ein bisschen BitTorrent gemacht habe. Was ja nicht so schwer ist, weil da kann man ja verkacken, weil da guckt ja keiner drauf. Aber, Huckels Co-Partner hier, so ist ja auch so ein kleiner Erlang-Experte, ne? Der ist gerade so ein bisschen aktiver als du, muss ich ja schon mal sagen, ja. Naja, ich meine, ich bin ja nicht so der GitHub-User, das ist ja auch mein Ding, jetzt mal so ein bisschen mehr GitHub dazu machen und der hat gleich irgendwie, ich hab nicht mal einen Push, ne was, Pull-Request gestellt und der hat's trotzdem nur noch mal Huckels gepetzt und voll toll.
Also wir sind jetzt so am, schon ein Vierer-Kollaborationsteam, aber es geht trotzdem erstmal noch schleichend voran. Aber eines Tages werden wir die bitteren Trecker-Weltherrschaft an uns reißen.
Na jetzt ist Astro auf jeden Fall schon mal vorne weg.
Macht der auch Erlang?
Naja, Astro schwitzt Erlang.
Das heißt der hat schon Trecker auch in Erlang?
Bit.Lav ist alles in Erlang.
Das wusste ich ja gar nicht. Verstehe, verstehe.
Alles in Erlang.
Das ist ja voll scheiße, der Konkurrenz.
Das ist ein BitTorrent Cedar, ein BitTorrent Trecker und ein RSS-Parser und ein Schwieb-Reiter.
Wir spezialisieren uns nur aufs Trecker.
Kann man das so wie benchmarken?
Ja klar.
Wie, womit?
Also ich kann dir jetzt mal verraten, wir sind jetzt hier unter uns zu fünf, wir sind unter zehn Augen sozusagen. Und wir haben mal in so einem kleinen Wahn, haben wir mal an einem, was war das, an unserem Wochenende so spät abends, viele Mathe schon sehr betrunken, ganz delirös vom Koffein. Da haben wir mal kurz Huckels Beta Erlang-Version auf Trecker ccc.de fahren lassen. Also es ist nicht zusammengebrochen.
Der erste Schuss hielt erstmal Stand, sagen wir mal.
Die Software hielt Stand, sie hat glaube ich nicht das gemacht, was sie machen sollte, aber sie ist nicht zusammengebrochen.
Was hat sie denn stattdessen gemacht?
Sie hat Pakete angenommen ohne Ende und hat eventuell auch sogar welche rausgeschickt. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob sie richtig waren.
Na doch, die, die sie rausgeschickt hat, hat sie auch rausgeschickt. Aber das Ding ist halt, auf Trecker ccc.de kommen halt 40.000 UDP-Pakete die Sekunde, so in Spitzenzeiten und da wollten wir halt mal gucken, ob jetzt so die naive Implementation in Erlang da schon genug von der Umgebung, sozusagen von diesem Erlang, nutzen kann, um trotzdem damit klarzukommen. Und es ist nicht sofort zusammengebrochen, aber der erste Schuss war jetzt noch nicht superoptimal. Aber jetzt haben wir sozusagen das UDP-Socket-Handling schon soweit optimiert, dass wir auch mit 100.000 Paketen klarkommen können.
Und ich mach halt mit meinem Kumpel aus Karsten. Wir lernen gerade ein bisschen Erlang und machen da so ein bisschen mit.
Okay, meine Frage war, seht ihr eine Methode, wie man das benchmarken kann? Also dieses bricht nicht zusammen unter Last. Das ist klar, aber wie kann man das messen?
Du kannst halt zum Beispiel grade-limited BitTorrent-Klines schreiben, die halt immer statische, also definierst halt die verschiedenen Message-Typen, Paket-Typen, also einen Connect-Request, einen Announce-Request, einen Scrape-Request, was auch immer. Dann schreibst du dir einen Client, der definiert zum Beispiel 40.000 Pakete, die die Kunde rausballert.
Ja, aber dann müsste man den auch noch so schreiben, den Client, dass er von möglichst irgendwie Millionen von verschiedenen IP-Adressen kommt und so.
Es gibt halt auch Software dafür, für sowas. Aber fang erst mal mit einem an. Und wenn du dann 40.000 rausbläst und beim Trecker auch 40.000 ankommen und auf 40.000 wieder rausgehen, kann man mit Netzdat und so weiter ja auch überprüfen. Da gibt es ja auch Statistiken mit Netzdat, wie viel Pakete gedroppt wurden, weil die Socketbuffer voll waren, weil du nicht schnell genug annehmen konntest und so weiter und so fort. Also es gibt schon Mittel und Wege, das auch so zu überprüfen.
Macht ihr auch schon IPv6 mit dem Trecker?
Nö, aber das ist relativ einfach.
Nicht ganz, weil die IPv6-Adressen im UDP, die sehen ja anders aus. Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob...
Ja, wir machen auch IPv6. Ist alles noch sehr frühes Stadium, wir spielen da ein bisschen rum.
Aber, also ich glaube, was der Astro macht, da geht ja gar nicht so mehr auf Performance, da geht ja wahrscheinlich mehr auf Features und wir gehen mehr auf Performance und nicht auf Features. Also genau...
Jetzt laufen gerade seine Augen rot an. Das kannst du aber mal schwer davon ausgehen, dass da Performance eine ganz große Rolle spielt.
Naja, wir haben ja auch den Erdgeist noch, der das gleiche in C kodet und so. Das ist ja sozusagen das Ziel. Und das ist aber auch so, das ist natürlich voll der Sack. Jedes Mal, wenn wir ein Stück näher kommen, so bei unserem Race, dann kodet er natürlich wieder mal für ein paar Stunden und rennt uns wieder davon. Weil so macht er das immer. Also letztens hab ich auch gesagt, hier Erlang ist am Kommen. Schwupp hat da irgendwie das UDP annehmen, hat da irgendwie gleich mal Multis reddet und auf die 8 Chores verteilt. Und das gleiche wird er dann demnächst mit TCP machen. Und dann ist er wieder weg.
Ich werde gerade darauf hingewiesen, dass am 6. Juni 2012 der World IPv6 Launch Day ist.
Genau, deswegen. Da müssen wir alle bereit sein. Deswegen mach ich ja hier schon Hausaufgaben für die Hörer.
Du machst Werbung, aber ich hab auch das Gefühl, der Tag wird anders.
Wenn der Treckerer keinen IPv6 macht, wohin soll das dann führen?
Nein, noch ist er, also unseres ist ja noch nicht, ist noch weit entfernt von Produktiv-Einsatz.
Was ist denn das für eine Einstellung?
Na du, warte mal ab, wir haben ja auch noch andere Sachen zu tun. Das ist nicht so wie der Astro, der ist da, der jetzt nichts anderes zu tun hat, als deine Bit.Love zu produzieren. Wenn ich jetzt vier Wochen nichts zu tun hätte oder mehr, dann sähe die Welt auch gleich anders aus.
Aber noch hier, ist das Repo von dem Astro, ist das irgendwie auch bei GitHub?
Ja, hat er doch schon alles gepostet, guck mal da. Ah, das ist der Load-Tester, stimmt. Er hat sogar einen, siehst du?
Guck an, siehst du mal, kannst du gleich mit testen. Report throughput and timing, more aggressive timing.
Ja, ist jetzt ein bisschen übersichtlich, weil du musst halt natürlich auch immer die Gegenseite noch beobachten, denn bei UDP ist ja alles hier stateless und so weiter, sind ja keine Connections, sind ja nur Pakete, die durch die Gegend gefeuert werden und da kann man auch...
Mal was verlieren.
Da kann man was verlieren, aber ich traue dem Astronaut natürlich zu, dass er die Gegenseite dann auch unter Beobachtung hält.
Astronaut, haben wir irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen hier? Aber ich glaube, im Wesentlichen haben wir es rübergebracht.
Also unser Trecker heißt ja Bit turret, ja? Also so ähnlich wie Bit Tourette, nur statt Tourette turret.
Was ich ja nicht verstehe. Bit Tourette fände ich ja wirklich einen echt coolen Namen. Wollt ihr das nicht noch umbenennen?
Der scheiß Server.
Der Trecker sich so verhält, kommt dann irgendwie so...
Ich freu mich schon auf die Logfiles.
Weil die, äh, genau, ja.
Ja, sobald das Spruch oder Schrei reif ist, werden wir da sicherlich auch nochmal ausgiebig bei Mobile Max darüber sprechen.
Bitturettu Arschloch.
Das ist ein schöner Claim eigentlich dann auch. Der steht aber nur irgendwo im Source-Code versteckt.
Ja, aber vielleicht noch ein Name für diesen Podcast. Nee, einfach Bitturett.
Bitturett ist eigentlich schön, ja. Ob er damit jemals dann allerdings bei Apple gefeaturet werden darf, bezweifelt werden.
Ach so, aber gerade eh schon, oder?
Jedenfalls gibt es die Leute, die einen 64er ohne Floppy haben und viele Disks und die vielleicht gerne digitalisieren würden, zum Beispiel damit sie die auf ihrem Emulator spielen können.
Digitalisieren?
Ja, auf der Floppy halt einen File machen, einen Image.
Ach so, einlesen.
Ja, digitalisieren.
Virtualisieren.
Weil die Floppy ist ja nicht digital, die ist ja magnetisch und Zeugs.
Floppy ist für ihn schon so alt, das hat schon so was Analoges.
Darum ging es ja in dem Vortrag von Felix Schwenzel auf der Republika, ich weiß nicht, ob du ihn gesehen hast, der ganz toll war, wo es nämlich genau darum ging, dass alles, was nicht so ist, wie man es erwartet, nennt man virtuell. Und Dinge, die eigentlich auch total virtuell sind, die man schon mit unter 30 benutzt hat, die nennt man nicht mehr virtuell. Geld zum Beispiel. Geld ist ja eigentlich extrem virtuell, aber man bezeichnet es trotzdem nicht als virtuell. Und genau so nennst du es jetzt, hast du es digitalisiert.
Wirtuell gar nicht gesagt. Ja, stimmt, das war Tim.
Aber analog.
Jedenfalls kommen wir wieder zurück. Also C64, Floppy-Laufwerk 1541 oder 1571 oder was auch immer. Und früher gab es halt so auf dem PC so spezielle Kabel mit Parallelport. Und dann kann man das nur unter DOS machen, weil das Timing war halt wichtig. Und das ging unter Windows nicht, außer du hast irgendwie dein System so angehalten, dann lief aber die Uhr danach immer falsch von Windows. Das war alles eine totale Katastrophe. Und jetzt gibt es seit einer Weile, ich gebe zu, schon wieder seit zwei Jahren inzwischen und so weiter, aber langsam, so kennt es auch jeder, gibt es so ein Device, das heißt Zoom-Floppy. Also Z-O-M-Floppy. Kann man irgendwo bestellen, weil so ein Typ mit dem tiefsten Amerika hat auch sechs Wochen gedauert, bis es bei mir ankommt. Jedenfalls konnte ich mir jetzt zwei Tools hier so unter, auf dem Mac irgendwie kompilieren, geht doch unter Linux. Und Windows-Software gibt es auch. OpenCBM heißt das und NIP-Tools. Und dann kann man irgendwie auch mit dem Apple jetzt irgendwie ganz entspannt prima seine Floppy-Discs von so einer 1541 oder sonst wie 1571 einlesen.
Wie schließt man das an?
Also das ist halt so ein kleines Ding, mit einem Atme-USB-Steinchen drauf und halt USB-Anschluss in Richtung Macintosh. Und dann hat es noch dieses IEC-Anschluss, der halt zum 64er oder zur Floppy geht, in dem Fall zur Floppy. Da ist ja ein Bus, also theoretisch auch 64er. Weil ich glaube, mit diesem OpenCBM kannst du ja natürlich auch deinen Rechner, eine Floppy simulieren lassen, dass der C64er deinen Rechner als Floppy nimmt. Hab ich jetzt zwar noch nicht machen können, aber ich glaube, das ging auch weißer als ein Bussystem. Und dann hat das Ding sogar noch, wenn man die dickere Ausgabe nimmt, die kostet dann irgendwie 5 Dollar mehr oder 10, hat es so ein IEEE488-Stecker. Das ist für diese noch uralteren Commodore-pré-C64- Floppy-Disc-Laufwerke, so 82,50 heißt das. Und das ist so richtig der alte Scheiß. Und das kann man alles anschließen und dieses OpenCBM kann das halt alles irgendwie auslesen, weil es ist halt so ein Standard-Protokoll und Standard-Bussystem.
Aber wie schließt du das an den Mac an? Echt?
Zwischen dieser Buchse...
Könnt ihr gleich mal auf die Seite... Habt ihr das schon verlinkt? Könnt ihr mal reinschmeißen, Zoom-Floppy. Genau, da hat schon jemand das IEEE488 reingehauen. Na ja, jedenfalls hab ich so einen Teil und hab mir auch gleich ein Parallelkabel dazu geholt. Weil es gibt's ja so, wenn ihr das noch kennt, ich hau mal die Namen raus, irgendwie Speedos, Dolphinos und so weiter, die braucht ja so einen Parallelanschluss, damit sie schneller irgendwie die Floppy zugreifen können. Und das hat auch diesen Parallelanschluss. Das heißt, wenn ihr Laufwerk noch habt mit Parallelanschluss, dann könnt ihr das da auch benutzen und dann könnt ihr noch mehr Low-Level-mäßigen Nibbel-Copy, nennt sich das, könnt ihr da auch irgendwie die Disks mit Kopierschutz und alles auslesen und halt auch sogar wieder schreiben und so weiter und so fort. Ich sag nur, es gibt noch eine Seite, die heißt, ich hab schon mal öfter drüber berichtet, aber...
Berichtet? Das klingt so, als wäre das so ein total heißes Thema.
Nee, aber ich hatte das schon mal in der Sendung hier, glaube ich.
Alle lenken sich die Finger nach neuen Updates aus der C64-Copycopy-Serie.
Sind fast so viele Leute, wie das alte Pfeilwort haben, oder?
Irgendwann gibt es hier dieses C64-Preservation Project, die sammeln halt die Original-Discs und die kann man sich mit diesem Zoom-Floppy dann auch wieder schreiben, solange man halt Parallelport hat oder eine 1571.
Mit der 41 geht's nicht?
Nee, der Unterschied ist die 1571, die war ja eigentlich für den 128er und deswegen ein bisschen schneller. Und da gibt es eine Leitung, die irgendwie SRQ heißt, und die haben da jetzt wieder neue gekodet und nutzen diese Leitung und können jetzt ohne diesen Parallelanschluss, den sie früher brauchten, können sie jetzt trotzdem in real time speed den Track in einer Umdrehung einlesen, was man irgendwie braucht, damit man den Kopierschutzsystem übergeht oder einliest und auch wieder schreiben kann und das können sie und das geht aber nur mit einer 1571.
Ich hatte nie eine 1571, das ist neu.
Du hast das Zeug. Jungs, gibt es bei Ebay, kann man sich das shoppen, habe ich es voll toll.
Diese kurze Session, also diese gefühlten 30 Sekunden am Stück irgendwelche Worte aneinander rein, die für mich persönlich sehr wenig Sinn ergeben haben, bestimmt sehr viel Sinn haben für C64 oder Commodore reingeweiht, die hätte ich gerne irgendwie mal rausgeschnibbelt aus diesem Podcast.
Als Klingeltuch oder was?
Das ist halt einfach so ein Fach Chinesisch, gerade diese Milch, die ich selten gehört habe.
Das ist doch genauso, wenn du jetzt über Rubiroloos hottest, dann kommt doch genau das Gleiche weiter raus.
Alles völlig normal.
Ich finde das ja auch total super. Das ist ja...
Und der Witz ist, ich hatte damals...
Wie viele Disketten hast du denn noch? Ich überlege gerade, also ich hatte mal einen größeren Vorrat, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich die überhaupt noch besitze.
Also ich finde es, ich brauche auf jeden Fall... Du brauchst noch eine vierte. Ein Kumpel von mir hat mir fünf ein Viertel Zoll Disketten gegeben, aber es war irgendwie HD Zeugs und das geht in diesem 1541 Laufwerk nicht. Das waren irgendwie HD Disketten. Deswegen habe ich nur drei, die wirklich funktionieren und auf der einen ist irgendwie vorne Loudrunner und auf der Rückseite ist Championship Loudrunner und die anderen beiden sind irgendwie so Spiele, Sammlung, Zeug. Ich hätte gerne noch ein paar mehr, weil ich kann mir wirklich mit diesem Teil jetzt, mit diesem Zoom-Floppy, Boulder Dash, direkt auf die Floppy machen und dann direkt an meinem Fernseher mit irgendwie 64 Floppy.
Also ich grabe noch mal in so ein paar Kisten. Vielleicht habe ich tatsächlich, es kann echt sogar noch sein, dass ich noch so zwei Boxen habe. Oh man ey, meinen alten Sourcecode wieder finden, das wäre schon ein Kick.
Ja, kann ich dir alles digitalisieren.
Kann man jetzt so einen 3D-Drucker, so eine Disketten, so eine Floppys drucken oder so? Es gibt doch bestimmt auch ein Projekt, das man direkt so... Kann doch nicht so schwer sein. Selbstbaukurse für Floppys, das muss doch gehen.
Ne, dieses Floppys, das ist so durch, das ist genauso tot wie Videorekorder, weil das so viel Mechanik, das ist unglaublich. Das gibt es heute alles gar nicht mehr.
Nur die Disketten selber, das ist doch nicht...
Das ist doch nur eine Magnetscheibe mit Hülle.
Ja eben, kannst du auch selber bauen.
Die Magnetscheibe könnte man theoretisch sogar weglassen, die Hülle, die Magnetscheibe nicht. Aber du könntest sozusagen die Magnetscheibe mit dem Loch reinschieben und die Hülle, ist ja egal dann. Obwohl, ich weiß nicht, ob es dann auf dem Metall da schleift. Könnte sein.
Ja, aber kannst du irgendwie aus Pappe, also irgendwie so selber kippen.
Du kannst sie dann aber nicht mehr beschreiben.
Warum?
Wegen der Markierung da, dieser Aussparung. Schreiben konnte man ja nur, wenn die Aussparung da war und nicht, wenn sie nicht da war.
Nee, aber ich meinte gerade, wenn man nur eine Magnetscheibe macht mit dem Loch in der Mitte, ohne die Hülle drum rum.
Nee, man muss ja so ein Ecker, sonst stinkt aus der... Der Schreibschutz war doch, dass du eine Ecke rausschneiden musstest.
Ja, da ist so ein Sensor, der checkt, wenn du die Disk reinschiebst, dann ist der Sensor ja zu und wenn es dann an der richtigen Stelle ist, dann weiß er, jetzt ist er komplett drin. So, das war jetzt mein Joke, jetzt hast du ja hoffentlich deine Themen zusammengesammelt.
Zusammengegoogelt?
Stimmt, dann hätten wir hier noch ein, das meinen gerade hier CM im Chat, von Prince of Persia ist ja der Apple II-Quellcode aufgetaucht und auf Github veröffentlicht worden. Na komm, wenn wir hier schon über irgendwelche Zoom-floppy-Dingse reden, dann können wir sowas auch erwähnen.
Ja, ich hätte noch was zur Hardware. Und zwar, wo wir gerade über Schnittstellen reden. So im Bereich Podcasting. Ich scanne ja immer, was es an Audio- und Hardware-Bewegungen gibt. Und es gibt da ja nicht sehr viele. Ich bin dann immer mal wieder sehr überrascht, wenn dann doch mal was passiert. Und es ist jetzt für alle Leute, die selber Podcasts aufnehmen, vielleicht interessant. Vielleicht ist es auch für Leute, die Musik machen, interessant. Weiß ich nicht. Die wissen aber vielleicht auch schon Bescheid. Ich grübel halt immer wieder, wie ich das so mit meinem mobilen Setup machen soll. Und derzeit habe ich ja da so eine Kiste mit 4 HE-Geräten, Mikrofonvorverstärker, dann so eine Expander-Kompressor-Kombination und dann eben auch noch so ein Interface, was mir den ganzen Kram mehr kanalig wieder in den Rechner reinbrennt. Da habe ich derzeit noch so ein Motu. Mark of the Unicorn hieß diese Firma irgendwann mal, bis sie sich einfach nur in Motu umbenannt hat, weil es irgendwie einfacher ist und sich das keiner merken konnte.
War auch ein bekloppter Name mit dem Unicorn, fand ich.
Naja, also Einhörner, das ist ja auch was Schönes.
Nein, ich sag nichts gegen Einhörner.
Friendship ist ja Pressung.
Aber ist es denn wirklich so einfach, sich den Zorn der Gemeinden auf sich zu ziehen?
Welcher Zorn, welcher Gemeinde, der Audiogemeinde?
Du ziehst dir ja nicht den Zorn, du ziehst dir ja die Liebe der Gemeinde zu. Das kann ja noch viel schlimmer sein.
Ihr habt ja mal gesagt, so richtig schön in die Fresse lächeln.
So, ich zeig euch das vielleicht mal hier, dass ihr da ein bisschen involvierter seid. Es gibt Neuigkeiten und zwar, es gab hier so Geräte, die für mich immer schon sehr interessant waren, die allerdings komplett ausfielen, weil sie halt nur Firewire machten. Und da bin ich wieder in dieser MacBook Air Falle. Auf der einen Seite gibt es keine Thunderbolt to Firewire Interfaces und USB hatte das alles auch nicht. Aber da ist jetzt irgendwie was passiert und sie haben ein paar von den interessanten Geräten nachgerüstet. Richtig geil finde ich zum Beispiel das MUTU896, MK3 Hybrid.
Das geht ja flauschig verletzt.
Das kommt gleich nach Microsoft Developer-Besuchnamen. Das ist ein cooles Gerät. Das ist so ein 2 HE Büchse, die irgendwie 8 Mikrofoneingänger hat und so Kompressoren drin hat und leider keinen Kopfhörerverstärker. Einen schon, aber eben nicht so 8.
Was passiert, wenn man da auf Beinau klickt?
Dann kauft man das gleich.
Ja, da wird einem deine Zahl angezeigt.
Das kostet so 950 oder so was. Und, naja, hat, wie gesagt, Firewire und USB und das klappt beim Moto auch ganz gut. Das heißt, damit kann man einfach mehr kanalisch aufnehmen und es ist mega kompakt. Also du hast wirklich so in einer Büchse ein Gerät, wo du so einen virtuellen Mixer mit drin hast. Du kannst also wirklich für jeden Output deinen eigenen Mix zusammenstellen. Auch optisch rein raus. Es gibt ein anderes mit SPDIF und ADAT, was man immer braucht, aber eben vor allem auch USB und kann darüber irgendwie ganz nette Setups machen. Das ist so das eine Teil. Es gibt da noch einen kleinen Bruder davon, das 828, was ich ja derzeit habe, was es jetzt auch in so einer Firewire-USB-Variante gibt, was es vorher nicht gab. Es gibt auch noch ein paar andere Geräte, die für mich persönlich aber jetzt nicht ganz so interessant sind bei Moto.
Warte, warte. Du hast gesagt, dass mit dem Firewire war für dich ein Problem, weil du nur MacBook airst und jetzt gibt es die aber auch mit USB oder was? Und deswegen kannst du die benutzen. Ich dachte, USB war immer irgendwie zu langsam, weil irgendwie Latenz und so. Oder habe ich jetzt?
Zu langsam für Systeme, wo du das Mixen in Software machst. Das ist nochmal ein anderes Problem. Also Latenz spielt in dem Moment eine Rolle, wo du deine Sprache in den Rechner schickst, in der Software prozessen willst und dann wieder zurück ins Gerät, was es auf deinen Kopfhörer bringt. Da ist mit USB wenig zu holen, mit Firewire ist es ein bisschen besser, aber das ist einfach ein grundsätzliches Problem. Das ist auch so ein grundsätzliches Problem, dass es auch vielleicht mit schnelleren Schnittstellen nicht so ohne weiteres zu lösen sein wird. Das muss sich zeigen. Ich habe hier bei den Internet-basierten Sachen, habe ich Hoffnung und auch bei den Thunderbolt-basierten Sachen, weil das ja PCI ist.
Es ist ja so, dass die schnelleren Schnittstellen nicht unbedingt weniger Latenz haben. Weil oftmals die schnelleren Schnittstellen halt nur dadurch schneller werden.
Weil sie einen größeren Buffer haben.
Weil sie größere Pakete schicken, dadurch ist der Buffer größer und dann wird die Latenz mitunter größer.
Die Bandbreite ist größer.
Das ist schon ein Grund, warum sie beim Telefonieren ATM mit ihren 56-Bytes-Paketen oder wie groß die haben da eingeführt.
Also man sagt, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, dass das USB 1 eine geringere Latenz hat als USB 2.
Nochmal bitte?
Was? Man sagt, ich weiß nicht, ob es stimmt, dass USB 1 eine geringere Latenz hat als USB 2.
Also ich habe einfach nur gelernt, dass da eben sehr viel davon abhängt, wie gut der Treiber purmiert ist. Also mit Standard-USB-Audio kannst du da irgendwie nicht viel reißen. So, jetzt gibt es aber noch eine andere interessante Entwicklung. Und zwar, was ich ja haben will, ist, ich will so ein Gerät, wo ich möglichst viele Mikrofone anschließen kann, wo ich flexibel sagen kann, wie das alles gemixt wird und wo ich im Idealfall auch noch einen Expander noch mit drin habe. Das ist der einzige Nachteil von diesem 896. Es hat zwar einen Kompressor, aber es hat keinen Expander. Und du willst halt irgendwie so Processing machen und du willst irgendwie flexibel mixen. Und da gibt es aber mittlerweile so eine andere Generation von Geräten, die, das ist so generell der Trend, die sind mehr so DSP-Plattformen. Das heißt, du kriegst einfach nur so ein Gerät und kaufst dir quasi die Funktionalität als Plugins dazu und schiebst sie da irgendwie rein. Und das Ding ist so komplett virtuell und du hast dann so eine Kontrollapplikation auf deinem Rechner und erst da stöpselst du diese virtuellen Komponenten erst zu einem realen Flow zusammen. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel noch ein anderes System, was für mich auch extrem interessant war. Und zwar heißt das Matrix Halo, heißt die Firma.
Na, die sind ja auch schon länger dabei.
Die sind schon länger dabei und da gibt es zum Beispiel das 2882. Das ist so ein heißes Gerät und das hätte ich auch schon total cool gefunden. Wir befinden uns jetzt hier allerdings auch schon im gestiegenen Preisbereich.
Ja, bei Matrix Halo auf jeden Fall.
Wobei, das sind jetzt auch nur noch irgendwie 1500. Das war auch schon mal extrem viel teurer. Aber da hast du das irgendwie in einem Hi. Und das Teil hat irgendwie auch acht Mikrofoneingänge und Pipapo. Hat aber leider nur Firewire. Firewire 400 sogar nur. Ist schon länger nicht mehr aktualisiert worden. Und ja, das ist mega kompakt. Also für so eine portable Lösung, wo du viele Mikrofone anschließen willst und so eine Mixer-Funktionalität haben willst und mehr Spur-Recording auf dem Rechner. Recording im Gerät haben die leider auch alle nicht. Das ist nochmal ein anderes Problem. So dieses Gerät fiel für mich eben auch aus, weil es nur Firewire hat und weil es einfach derzeit keine Möglichkeit gibt, ins R reinzugehen. Und jetzt wurde ich vor ein paar Tagen noch auf was ganz anderes Verrücktes hingewiesen. Das will ich mir jetzt nicht kaufen. Aber das fand ich einfach mal erwähnenswert. Und zwar, kennst du die Bude Universal Audio? Da drehen sie richtig durch.
Was ja bei Audio nicht allzu oft vorkommt.
Wir haben ja so einen richtigen DSP Plug-In Store. Also das ist hier schon so richtig das Business. Also so wie du so Plug-Ins für deine Software kaufst, so für deinen Logic mit irgendwie Audio-Units etc. Hast du das eben jetzt hier auch nochmal gerätespezifisch, wo sie das eben in diese High-Performance-Prozessoren reinballern? Und dann gibt es dieses Apollo Audio Interface. Und warum ich das jetzt überhaupt erwähne ist, das ist jetzt das erste Gerät, wo zumindest angekündigt wurde, was eine Option hat auf Thunderbolt. Das heißt da gibt es hinten einen Slot, lieferbar ist das jetzt auch erst wieder ins Summer 2012 und da wollen sie dann irgendwie gleich mit Thunderbolt durchstarten und da wird es natürlich dann auch mal wieder ganz spaßig. Aber da geht es irgendwie bei 2000 Euro los, das ist alles schon ein bisschen verrückt.
Ach, da ist hinten so eine Klappe dran, wo man irgendwas reinstecken kann.
Da schiebst du dann irgendwann mal das Modul rein, wenn es fertig ist. Also wahrscheinlich mussten sie das Teil rausholen und dann so, ja wir würden da gerne Thunderbolt drin haben.
Weil Out of the Box macht es ja jetzt auch nur Firewire, ne?
Genau. Und da ist wahrscheinlich intern ohnehin irgendwie PCI drin und da wissen sie, dass sie das rangeschlöpselt bekommen. Aber alle warten jetzt auf die nächste Generation von Thunderbolt-Chips, die Intel seit langer Zeit versprochen hat und die jetzt irgendwie auf sich warten lassen.
Da ich das irgendwo aufgeschrieben hatte, wann die kommen sollten.
Ja, aber wer so als Podcaster irgendwie noch so eine Mischpult-freie, flexible Hardware sucht, die man gut durch die Gegend schleppen kann, ist dieses Motto auf jeden Fall interessant. Ich glaube, Holger hat sich sogar schon eins geklickt.
Ach ja, bei mir steht das jetzt ja leider auch demnächst wieder an.
Kaufen, kaufen, kaufen, kaufen, kaufen, kaufen.
Du meinst jetzt das 896 MK3. Genau.
Sollten wir mal über Max reden.
Sehr interessantes Gerät.
Ja, aber braucht man acht Ausgänge?
Na, das hängt so ein bisschen davon ab. Also einerseits, was du halt nicht machen kannst beim Moto ist, wenn du da wieder was rein spielen willst, dann musst du tatsächlich den Umweg über die analogen Ports gehen. Du kannst da nicht über USB einen Input liefern, sondern du kannst hinschicken nur auf Output. Und wenn du das wieder in den Input haben willst, also wenn du in einen Mix vom Rechner aus was hinschicken willst, also wenn du auch von deiner Audio-Software einen Clip abspielen willst oder irgendeinen Return da reinpatchen willst oder so, dann hast du noch die Skype-Problematik. Da sind wir jetzt wieder bei diesem Audiotreiber-Wahnsinn auf Mac mit virtuellen Devices, die es nicht gibt. Damit fange ich jetzt erst mal nicht an. Aber dann kannst du es patchen und dann hängst du davon ab. Also du kannst ja natürlich dann auch irgendwie beliebige AUX-Mixer da zusammenbauen und die separat raushauen, wenn du für jeden Kopfhörer noch einen eigenen Mix haben willst oder sowas. Du kannst dir natürlich dann auch Monitor-Situationen vorstellen, gerade wenn du jetzt live bist, was weiß ich, machst irgendwie was auf einer Bühne, so Podcast zum Mithören live und willst halt irgendwie noch ein paar Monitore beschicken oder so. Also keine Ahnung, die musst du jetzt auch nicht unbedingt benutzen. Mir geht es halt vor allem um die Inputs, die müssen da sein und die ganzen digitalen Schnittstellen und eben irgendwas, was in so ein R reingeht.
Zum Thema Software. Mein Co-Audio-Buch, was ich vor zwei Jahren bei Amazon bestellt habe, ist jetzt gekommen. Es hat zwar nicht mehr den aufsprünglichen Titel und auch nicht mehr die ursprünglichen Autoren, aber sie haben es jetzt fertig geschrieben.
Hat es dann den ursprünglichen Preis?
Es ist auch relativ dünn, aber...
Ich glaube, die ursprüngliche Autorin hat aber das Vorwort geschrieben oder sowas, habe ich mitbekommen, ne?
Jaja, sehr martialisch und auch über drei Seiten. Aber ansonsten... Und? Taucht es was? Soweit bin ich noch nicht. Sie schreiben, also soweit wie ich jetzt bin, schreiben sie immer nur, dass es alles heitenkomplex ist und ganz schwierig und man muss alle Hoffnung fahren lassen.
Das sag ich ja auch immer wieder. Wie heißt denn das Buch jetzt?
Na, such doch mal nach Core Audio und Mike Lee. Der sollte das Buch ursprünglich schreiben. Inzwischen hat er Amsterdam gegründet, keine Ahnung. Hat es halt nur noch zu einem Vorwort gerecht.
Learning Core Audio? Hands-on Guide to Audio Programming for Mac and iOS?
Wahrscheinlich. Es gibt nur dieses eine Buch. Also es gibt nichts anderes über Core Audio. Also es ist glaube ich die schlechtest dokumentierte API, die Apple je produziert hat, ist dieses Core Audio. Das ist unglaublich. Man findet dazu so unglaublich schlecht Informationen. Also weil...
Ja, ich höre das einfach mal wieder, dass das wirklich ganz furchtbar sein soll.
Und es ist... Core Audio ist halt auch so komplexe Scheiße. Also es ist halt nicht irgendwie...
30 Euro.
Wieso?
Das ist halt ein Fachbuch, meine Güte.
Ja, eben deswegen. Ich erwarte von so einem Buch, dass das 85 Euro kostet und 600 Seiten stark ist. Ja, aber es hat mehr so... Das ist ja mehr wie so ein Flyer.
Es hat mehr eher so Richtung 300.
Okay, das heißt, die fangen an davon zu erzählen und dann, wenn es interessant wird, verweisen sie auf die Doku, die nicht vorhanden.
Das war jetzt gemein, aber möglicherweise richtig.
Dann sitzt du hier nächstes Mal als core audio wizard. Dann werden wir dich auch nur noch so ansprechen.
Also das, was ich bisher durchgeblättert habe, das habe ich auch schon so erarbeitet.
Aber hast du vorher schon core audio wizard?
Du hattest auch zwei Jahre Vorlauf gehabt.
Vielleicht so ein einäugiger. Weiß ich nicht.
Einäugiger wizard.
Ja, das Cover, was ist das da? Ich hatte ja keine Ahnung. Amazon hat mir ja immer alle drei Monate eine Mail geschrieben, dass das Buch, was ich bestellt hätte, sich leider noch mal verzögern würde und noch mal verzögern und dann kam irgendwann die Mail, naja, sie wüssten nicht so genau, ich könnte das jetzt auch irgendwie ganz stornieren und dann kam drei Tage später, ihr Buch wurde versendet und ich so, hm?
Aber es muss ein absoluter Bestseller sein. Ich kenne jetzt zwei Leute, die es gekauft haben, das ist wahrscheinlich so.
Ja, man kann es ja auch schon seit zweieinhalb Jahren oder drei Jahren bestellen. Also das ist irgendwie...
Das ist der einzige Grund, warum es geschrieben wurde, weil Amazon hat gesagt, das sind 10.000 Leute, die wollen dieses Buch haben, ihr müsst jetzt mal irgendwas machen.
Der erzählt nicht das Lager. Und dann packe ich mir das aus und dann ist da diese Frau mit diesem Kopfhörer so halb drauf und ich dachte, äh?
Würdest du denn sagen, das Chor Audio, also ist es nur scheiße dokumentiert oder ist es scheiße?
Also als Technologie ist es schon sehr geil. Es ist, naja, sagen wir mal so, Audioprogrammierung hat so seine eigenen Schwierigkeiten und eine API zu bauen auf einer Audioengine, die in einem Betriebssystem ganz weit unten sehr leistungsfähig Dinge tut, ist was, was ich mir jetzt auch nicht auf Anhieb zutrauen würde. Noch dazu, weil das halt alles in C ist und man da wirklich vorsichtig mit Puffern, die man so per Malloc sich zusammen bastelt, irgendwie agieren muss. So gesehen ist es schon okay. Also man muss halt eine gewisse Leidensfähigkeit mitbringen. Es ist kein Coco oder sonstige Hochsprache, sondern es ist halt richtig C mit Core Foundation Objekten. Und es ist dann aber auch wiederum so dokumentiert, dass man nicht auf Anhieb die Konzepte versteht, die dahinterstecken. Das ist nämlich das eigentliche Problem, dass man lange braucht, um die Konzepte zu verstehen. Also es ist das eine Problem. Und das zweite Problem ist, dass der gesamte Sample Code aufbaut auf so eine Art Zwischenschicht, die die dazwischen gepackt haben, die in C++ ist und ganz fürchterlich naja, fürchterlicher C++ Code halt ist. Das heißt, du lernst die eigentliche Schnittstelle Core Audio über diesen Sample Code, den es bei Apple gibt, überhaupt nicht kennen, weil du musst immer erst diese komische C++ Zwischenschicht runterschälen, um überhaupt zu verstehen, was da passiert. Und C++ Code kann man, wenn man will, schon extrem unleserlich schreiben. Also das geht ohne Probleme.
Das ist ihnen auch gelungen.
Sample Code von Apple sieht gerne mal ganz, ganz schlimm aus. Also gerade im Mac-Bereich hat man so das Gefühl, dass die da immer wieder nur so Interns dran setzen, die dann das einfach so hinschmieren. Und so, ja. Also inzwischen ist es besser geworden, aber früher auch so dieser ganze Sample Code für Coco und so.
Ich hör das immer wieder von Entwicklern. Ist das jetzt nur so verzerrte Wahrnehmung, oder handelt es sich generell da um ein Problem? Und ist einfach die Produktivität der Developer grundsätzlich gehemmt dadurch, dass Sachen scheiße dokumentiert sind? Würde Apple nicht am Ende mehr davon haben, wenn sie mal anstatt an dem nächsten Betriebssystem-Release zu arbeiten einfach mal drei Monate lang alle nur Doku machen?
Na, Core Oreo macht halt da unten niemand.
Wenn du dir anguckst...
Kein Wunder, wenn es nicht dokumentiert ist.
Wenn du dir anguckst, wie der ganze Sample Code auf iOS ist, der schon auf sehr hohem Niveau ist, und das dann damit vergleicht, wie halt der Sample Code für Core Audio aussieht, wo teilweise das Zeug nicht mehr kompiliert oder Tausende von Warnings ausspuckt, weil Funktionen nicht mehr benutzt werden oder nicht mehr existieren, dann muss ich sagen, das hemmt schon arg. Also es hat mein Verständnis der Sache befördert, dass ich erstmal deren Code fixen musste, bis es funktioniert hat, weil dann setzt man sich halt auch hin und versteht das mal, was da eigentlich passieren soll. Aber es ist schon, sie könnten das, also an vielen Ecken könnten sie da wirklich was machen, denke ich schon.
Aber mir geht es jetzt gar nicht mal nur um Core Audio. Also bei Core Audio scheint das Klagen und Wehen ja sehr groß zu sein. Ich meine so grundsätzlich alles.
Also ich finde nicht, man kann es so verallgemeinern. Also es ist schon so, dass ein guter Sample Code einem meistens weiterhilft als irgendwie meterlange Dokumentation. Also gerade so für den Einsteiger. Ich nehme halt ein Projekt, da drücke ich auf den Compile-Button und lasse es laufen und es tut. Und dann kann ich anfangen, daran rum zu patchen und zu machen und zu gucken, was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich da was ändere. Und wie kriege ich das hin? Und wenn ich nur die Dokumentation habe und ein leeres Projekt, dann kann ich nicht anfangen, weißt du so? Das ist halt der Sinn von Sample Code. Und zumindest bei Core Audio ist man da echt auch im Wald, weil man halt überhaupt nicht versteht, was da passiert. Also bei anderen Sachen ist es nicht so schlimm.
Also das ganze Core Foundation und so, das finde ich super dokumentiert.
Core Foundation schon, ja klar. Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, ob es Core Foundation Sample Code gibt, in dem Sinne.
Naja doch, also gibt es ja immer für die ganzen Methoden und was es da alles gibt und GUI-Kram und so, immer wenn du irgendwie was suchst, bietet da ja an, hier irgendwie pro Core hier, da gibt es irgendwie ein passendes Beispiel, also in dem passenden Sample Code wird das auch benutzt und sonst wird ja mal aufgelöst, kannst du klicken, das Xcode lädt das gleich runter, packt das aus, hast du gleich das ganze Projekt da und kannst dann da ein bisschen rumfummeln. Manche davon sind besser, manche sind schlechter. Manche sind auch einfach wieder zu fett, das ist dann so ein großer Sample Code, das ist dann eigentlich das Problem, da ganz tief in irgendeiner unteren Ebene, da irgendwie so voll versteckt ist und du das erstmal alles wieder rausdröseln musst, aber eigentlich geht das schon.
Bei dem Core Audio Sample Code ist das sehr oft so.
Na gut, da geht es dann vielleicht aber auch nicht anders.
Was auch relativ schwierig ist, so Keychain.
Naja, aber das ist alles, was mit Krypto zu tun hat, oder? Also das ist alles böses C, sobald irgendwie in den Security-Bereich kommt.
Ja, aber wenn du mit der OpenSSL-Library zum Beispiel rumbaust, das ist alles relativ easy.
Das hat fast auch mit Apple wieder nichts zu tun.
Ja, aber das ist halt auch Krypto und das ist Standard-Krypto und das kriegst du auch hin. Aber dieses Keychain Zeug, das ist echt sehr strange.
Da gibt's, wie heißt der diese Bibliothek, die nur jeder sofort rumpackt gleich, dieses Objective-C-Map. Ne, ne, nicht ESL, die Keychain Access. Für den Krypto-Scheiß muss ich ja auch runter aufs, also auf eklige C-Ebene und das hat auch keinen Spaß gemacht.
Eklige C-Ebene.
Es gibt noch so ein paar Überbleibsel von Carbon gibt's noch, die sind auch ganz unglaublich schlecht. Also ich glaube, die haben sie inzwischen fast alle rausgebaut, aber so manche Sachen haben sich rüber gerettet und das ist dann auch fies, aber ansonsten.
Wo wir jetzt schon beim Programmieren sind, dieses Ruby-Motion hat ja noch ein bisschen Welle gemacht. Weiß da irgendjemand irgendwas drüber?
Ruby in Motion.
Ich weiß nur, dass der Typ, der früher Mac-Ruby-Haupt ehrenamtlich gemacht hat, sich gedacht hat, ach scheiße, jetzt will ich mal damit Geld verdienen. Und so, als ich das verstanden hab, ist das ja eine kommerzielle Entwicklungsamgebung mit Ruby, iOS.
Meinst du, der ist schon gar nicht mehr bei Apple?
Nee, der ist nicht mehr bei Apple, der ist bei Apple rausgegangen und hat dann mit Ruby-Motion angefangen.
Wahrscheinlich hat Apple immer irgendwann gesagt, wir wollen unser Ruby doch nicht aufs iOS bringen, weil Objective-C ist jetzt in der ersten Liga angekommen und wir brauchen das gar nicht mehr.
Vielleicht, vielleicht auch wegen der Garbage-Collection, wobei ich auch nicht weiß, wie er das gelöst hat. Also das Problem ist ja, dass Mac-Ruby braucht ja die Garbage-Collection und die gibt es ja unter iOS nicht und die gibt es ja unter iOS nach wie vor nicht. Und wie hat er dieses Problem eigentlich gelöst?
Und unter Mountain Lion ist der Deprecate?
Na ja, es gibt halt...
Ach so, wegen ARK.
Na, es gibt halt seit kurzem, ich weiß allerdings nicht, ob das das benutzt, tatsächlich gibt es ja einen Embedded Ruby, von der japanischen Regierung gesponsert und von Yukihiro Matsumoto ist ehrenamtlich und persönlich umgesetzt, mit dem Ziel, Ruby auf Embedded-Plattformen halt zu bringen und da gibt es halt auch irgendwie Workarounds für, also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ehrlich gesagt, aber ich bilde mir ein, dass sie da auch dieses Problem Garbage Collection angefasst haben und vielleicht, dass es jetzt allerdings, wie gesagt, ich habe es mir leider noch nicht genug angeguckt, ob der jetzt auch dieses Embedded Ruby benutzt oder ob er tatsächlich der Mac Ruby noch weiter benutzt oder hat doch der Chat vielleicht schon genauere Informationen?
Also ich habe mir mal so ein Review von diesem ganzen Zeug durchgelesen, der offensichtlich auch damit entwickelt hat und der war halt, also es hat viele Vorteile, du kannst halt in Ruby und dann gibt es natürlich schon, es gibt in, also Objective-C ist keine schlechte Sprache, aber du hast in Ruby brauchst nicht diese Header-Files und irgendwie ein Array zu definieren ist wesentlich einfacher und so dieses ganze Zeug ist halt geil, du nimmst halt, wenn du ein Ruby Array definierst, dann Dann hast du ein NS-Array da unten drunter, also das native Objective-C Zeug, genauso wie man es erwartet und ist dann auch mal in einer Rapper-Klasse drinnen, sodass du auch die ganzen Ruby-Methoden nutzen kannst, aber du brauchst ja nicht irgendwie hin und her zu konvertieren und so ein Scheiß. Und du kannst halt, wenn du Ruby schon kannst, dann kannst du halt weiterhin in der Sprache programmieren und kannst dabei bleiben. Was ich aber vom ganzen, also ich, du musst halt die gleichen Apis lernen, die du für Objective-C auch lernen musst. Und das ist ja das eigentliche Problem. Also es geht ja nicht so sehr darum, dass ein bisschen neue Syntax da ist und vielleicht du ein bisschen mehr wissen musst. Okay, aber die ganzen Frameworks kennenzulernen, die sind glaube ich das eigentliche Problem. Also ich glaube, wenn man Coco Touch nicht vorher kann, dann hat man damit auch richtig massive Probleme, weil du musst ja die ganze Api, die ganze Doku, die du findest, musst du erstmal in deine Ruby-Welt übersetzen und so. Und die Syntax ist ein bisschen ungewohnt. Ich weiß nicht, womit man das bearbeitet, weil also Objective-C und diese ganzen Frameworks ohne Autocompletion ist echt ein Schmerz, weil die Methodennamen halt unglaublich lang sind.
Da gibt es ja auch Ruby-Highlighting.
Ob das dann so funktioniert? Also die hatten jetzt alle tapfer Wim am Laufen in ihren ganzen Demos und so. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jedes Mal komplett eintreten möchte.
Also kurzer Einschub, also es ist immer noch basierend auf Mac-Ruby und das mit der Garbage Collection machen sie. Our memory model, similar to Objective-C Arc in design, does not require any extra memory or processor footprint to allocate. Ach so, dann schreibt der hier, Ruby Motion will by itself release the objects you create, when they are no longer needed.
Also auf Compiler-Ebene quasi. Was sehr geil sein soll, auf der anderen Seite, dass du halt, wie heißt diese Ruby-Konsole? Genau, das ist das entsprechend für iOS haben. Dann kannst du dann im Simulator direkt in der laufenden App kannst du Objekte auf dem Bildschirm manipulieren und so was. Macht wohl ein bisschen den fehlenden Debuggerwett. Aber auf der anderen Seite so hier Interface-Bilder und so was, kannst du halt komplett klicken und so.
Also ich würde das ja, glaube ich, wenn ich das tun würde, schon mit Xcode bauen, weil es gibt ja da, wir hatten ja schon Ruby-Templates für Mac-Ruby da drin.
Ja, keine Ahnung, wie gut das... Ich weiß nicht, das war, glaube ich, noch zu Xcode 3 Zeiten. Keine Ahnung, wie viel davon jetzt in Xcode 4 noch übrig geblieben ist. Und testen können sie wohl. Testen können sie wohl auch wesentlich besser als nativ mit Objective-C. Weil das ist ja wirklich schmerzerregend, da das Testen. Und das soll wohl wirklich ganz fantastisch funktionieren hier. Und also vielleicht ist es ja für den einen oder anderen, macht es die Umstellung ein bisschen leichter. Aber ich glaube, ich würde dazu tendieren, doch die eigentliche Sprache, so schwer ist es echt nicht.
Ich hab ja auch mal eine Zeit lang mit MacRuby und so rumgespielt. Und mir war das im Prinzip auch so. Ja, es ist zwar ganz geil, dass du nicht NSMutableString und haste nicht gesehen hinschreiben musst. Sondern du kannst halt einfach so einen String benutzen, wie man halt so einen Rubin-String benutzt.
Wobei das ja das einzige, was geht. Add-Zeichen davor, zwei Anführungsstriche, haste ein NSMutableString.
Ja, gut, falsches Beispiel.
Und das wird mit Mountain-Line noch mehr.
Aber am Ende, wie du schon sagst, ist man halt die meiste Zeit doch damit beschäftigt, in der Doku nach den richtigen Api-Calls, weil man will ja halt, man will ja eine Coco abmachen oder eine iOS ab und deswegen muss man...
Kriegst du das überhaupt ordentlich debugged? Also, du musst ja eine Debugger-Unterstützung dafür haben, ordentliche.
Das ist schon, aber eigentlich alles...
Hat er wohl im Augenblick noch überhaupt keine Debugger-Unterstützung, sondern ist halt... Du bist halt komplett auf diese Ruby-Konsole angewiesen. Und mit der kann... Und die wirst du dann wohl geschmissen, so quasi. Und dann kannst du dir deine Objekte angucken. Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, also es soll wohl so... Dieser Ruby meint, das fühlt sich so ein bisschen an wie Fire... Als das erst mal Firebug in Firefox zu benutzen. Also dieses Tool, mit dem man HTML live bearbeiten kann, was auch sehr, sehr geil ist. Was echt die Arbeit wesentlich einfacher macht, so mal eben rasch CSS zu bearbeiten, auszuprobieren. Und so ist das wohl in dieser Konsole auch. Du kannst halt deine ganzen Objekte am lebenden Objekt, also live manipulieren. Das stelle ich mir schon ganz geil vor. Aber ob es das wert ist?
Aber so richtig Zukunft scheint mir das nicht zu haben, dieses Ruby-Motion jetzt, oder?
Ja, mal gucken. Also ich denke auch, dass die meisten Entwickler eher dann nativ aufs Coco gehen. Also solange nicht Apple sagt, hey Ruby, First Class Citizen, und das wird halt nicht passieren, nehme ich mal an, wird das wahrscheinlich keine allzu große Zubehörung.
Das haben sie schon mal mit Java gemacht. Und ich glaube, das kaufen sie sich nicht noch mal ein.
Sie haben echt die Meinung gehabt, dass sie Xcode nicht in Java umgeschrieben haben, oder?
Ja, aber dafür ist das immer noch garbage collected. Mal sehen. Aber keine Ahnung, ich glaube nicht, dass sie das machen. Die basteln eher am Objective-C selber rum.
Genau, das scheint ja wesentlich einfacher zu werden. Da sind es ja richtig, richtig dran. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch der richtige Weg, dass das einfacher wird. Aber es ist ja mit ARK unglaublich viel passiert. Und jetzt mit diesen bisschen besseren Literals und dass du dann die Variable nicht mehr synthesisieren musst, das wird ja schon alles einfacher. Wird bestimmt nicht so einfach werden wie Ruby, aber...
Vielleicht gibt es irgendwann auch noch mal ein garbage collector. Ich gebe die Hoffnung nicht auf.
Ich glaube, das machen die weiter mit ARK.
Was gibt es, Tim?
Was gibt es?
Ich frage mich, ob wir das Thema jetzt ausreichend eingetütet haben. Ich denke schon, oder?
Was hast du denn noch für ein Thema hier?
Ich wollte noch auf was hinweisen. Und zwar hatten ja verschiedene Leute unter anderem auch mit Nobamax, aber auch mit anderen Podcasts. Der Metaebene in letzter Zeit dann immer den Bugreport geliefert. Na ja, wenn ich das im Browser abspiele mit dem Player, der da ist, dann spielt das alles nur halb so schnell.
Das musst du jetzt sehr, sehr langsam sagen für diese Leute.
Nicht sehr, sehr schnell.
Viel, viel schneller musst du das sagen.
Okay, die Antwort ist einfach. Das Problem tritt nur mit Chrome auf. Es gibt da einen Bug. Der kann halt HE, AAC-Dateien irgendwie nicht richtig abspielen. Generell oder unter bestimmten Bedingungen. Das weiß ich nicht so genau. Auf jeden Fall tritt das unter anderem bei den von uns angebotenen MP4-Dateien auf. Das wurde dann auch, also da gab es schon längere Zeiten ein Bug-Report auf Chromium-Org. Da hab ich dann immer alle hingeschickt und sehe da, seit kürzester Zeit, es gibt ja da diesen Chrome Dev Channel, wo immer so zu quasi die Nightly-Bild-Abteilung von Chrome.
Der Dev Channel oder eher, die haben ja hunderte Stufen davon. Am Chrome Canary und Dev Channel und Beta.
Auf jeden Fall, wenn du irgendwie hier Chrome Dev Channel eingibst, dann kommst du irgendwie auf eine Seite, die heißt Chromium Org Getting Involved Dev Channel. Und das sind halt hier irgendwie Release Channels. Und da gibt es halt irgendwie für den Mac, gibt es irgendwie hier Stable, Beta, Dev und Canary Build. Und wenn du halt die Dev Channel Version für den Mac nimmst, also auf jeden Fall geht es mit der. Die anderen habe ich jetzt nicht durchgetestet, dann ist dieser Bug gone. Mit einer Worten, das ist davon auszugehen, dass irgendwie dieser Bugfix-Upstream da unterwegs ist zu dem richtigen Release. Und das Problem demnächst mit einem sich doch relativ fix aktualisierenden Chrome auch verflüchtigt. Das beruhigt mich auch sehr.
Also, bei Chrome gibt es übrigens ein sehr cooles Feature für die Herren Web-Developer. Und zwar kennt man das ja als erfahrener Web-Developer, dass man natürlich seine JavaScripts und CSS-Files alles in einen File und alle Widespaces raus und variablen, dann noch mal alles so schön compressed, um Transfer, Bandbreite usw. zu sparen. Und es ist natürlich blöd zu debuggen, wenn dann nämlich mal ein Error ist im Production-System, der nicht im Testsystem oder sonst wo da lokal auftritt und man muss dann irgendwie durch dieses compressed JavaScript durch. Gibt es bei Chrome ein Feature, im Web-Inspector kann man dann sich dieses ganze compressed JavaScript wieder ausfalten lassen und er versucht, das so möglichst schön wieder auseinanderzuklappen.
Aber wird das nicht sowieso wegkomprimiert? Wenn man das drin lassen würde, würde das nicht sowieso wegkomprimiert werden?
Wird man einfach eine G-SIP compression?
Du machst das ja auch, mehrere JavaScripts in einem Files zusammen und so, das ist halt, das ist schon so ein alles in eine Zeile, keine Newlines und so, das ist schon, ist schon nicht schön zu debuggen. So und mit Chrome geht das aber mit Safari. Selbst in dem aktuellen Beta-Browser gibt es dieses Feature leider noch nicht. Überhaupt finde ich den neuen Webkit, also den neuen Safari-Webinspektor, der ist irgendwie ganz unübersichtlich geworden, leider. Naja, die haben irgendwie, haben so ein bisschen, also der ist irgendwie nicht übersichtlich mehr. Leider.
Bin jetzt in der 5.2-Beta. Die ist aber noch sehr, sehr buggy. Ich hab ja...
Es gibt Updates. Du hast das Update Beta 3 auch schon?
Das hatte ich und das war trotzdem, also die Extension API war sehr anders als die Forma 5.1 und das hat alles keinen Spaß gemacht. Damit hab ich so ein bisschen gebastelt und das war nicht gut.
Aber, ja, ich benutze den, ja. Also bei mir, bei mir, boah.
Ich würd gern noch mal ein bisschen andere Hersteller hauen.
Immer auf die Schwachen.
Immer auf die Schwachen, genau. Habt ihr diese Wake-up-Kampagne mitbekommen, diesen Aufstand da rum?
Von diesem Randgruppen Telefonhersteller?
Es war ja am Anfang das Gerücht, dass das Samsung dahinter stecken würde, die waren es ja dann im Endeffekt nicht. Die haben schwarze Busse, so komplett schwarze Busse mit nur weißer Schrift Wake Up haben die vor Apple Stores fahren lassen, haben da Leute mit schwarzen T-Shirts und Wake Up Schildern aufstellen lassen und dann war angeblich rein zufällig ein Blogger vor Ort, der das Ganze gefilmt hat, was mal eine geile Werbekampagne ist, eine Werbekampagne, in der du ausschließlich die Produkte der Konkurrenz siehst, wie sie im Shop ausgestellt werden. Und jetzt hat sich vor ein paar Tagen geklärt, wer dahinter steckt, nämlich Rim mit Blackberry. Das ist eine interessante Frage. Weil es gibt so eine Seite, die ist so... At the end of the day, the question is, are you in business or are you not in business? Und ich glaube, damit wollen sie ihre Kundschaft ansprechen. Also wir wollen Profis, aber ich glaube, man könnte das durchaus als Kampagne für die Rim-Führung verstehen. So Wake up, at the end of the day, the only thing that counts is, are you in business or not? Im Augenblick sieht es doch eher für Rims so aus, als ob die nicht mehr länger in business wären, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab dieses Rim noch nie so richtig ernst genommen. Aber das ist vollkommen klar.
Aber dass sie in dieser Phase immer noch in dem Zustand sind, dass sie offensichtlich ihre Kundschaft für zu blöd halten, weil sie Apple-Produkte kaufen, das ist ja die eine offensichtliche Botschaft.
Ich verstehe überhaupt dieses Wake-Up. Wer soll denn da überhaupt wovon aufwachen?
Also was meinen sie denn?
Sie meinen, das war wohl in Australien, oder? Dass es so eine Testkampagne war, deswegen da irgendwo im tiefsten Busch, wo es höchst wahrscheinlich keinen Schwein mitkriegt, außer dass es jetzt durch diesen Gerichtsgeschichte... Das kam ja wohl raus, weil in diesem Samsung-Apple-Streit vor Gericht hat Apple wohl Samsung beschuldigt, dass die das gewesen wären und Samsung hat gesagt, ne, wir waren das gar nicht und dann hat drin gesagt, ey, ja, die waren es wirklich nicht, weil wir waren es. Irgendwie sowas habe ich gelesen.
Die haben eine Website dafür geschaltet, die haben da irgendwelche viralen Videos... Ich meine, sollen sie nochmal mit... Also, willkommen im Internet.
Ja, aber was soll denn das? Ich meine, wovon reden die denn?
Du sollst Blackberry-Telefone kaufen, gefällig.
Ja, aber was soll das heißen?
Du bist einfach nur zu doof zu erkennen, dass die hier bessere Telefone bauen. Wake doch endlich mal ab hier.
Ist vorbei, Piek Apple.
Sei nicht ein Mitfloater, sei ein Maker. Und ein Opportunity for Breakfast-Luncher-Esser. Das ist tatsächlich in deren Kampagne drinne.
Was? Opportunity for Breakfast-Luncher-Esser?
Are you eating Opportunity for Breakfast or are you floating with the Mars? Also ich lese kruxweise, aber das ist wirklich...
Jeder Stand an bei denen.
Ja, das ist hier auf der Seite. Ich meine, ich hab hier... Wie war das? Wake Up Be Bold. Das ist die Seite dazu und die kann man sich auch ohne Ton hier mal einfach so mitlaufen lassen. Da so ein Text drin steht, das ist die gesamte Kampagne. Also das ist wirklich so...
Welchen von diesen 1000 Links muss man jetzt hier anklicken gerade?
Na das sind wahrscheinlich diese Videos, die sie meinen. Aber hier, Wake Up Be Bold, das ist so das Ende.
Was ist das denn? Der Chat redet wieder in der Sendung vorbei. Ja, ach ich weiß nicht, ich find das total uninteressant. Lass uns mal über Apple reden. Wir haben einen Hardware-Release von Apple noch nicht besprochen, fällt mir gerade ein.
Ah, das neue iPad 2?
Das neue iPad 2. Was ich ja wirklich mal echt interessant finde.
Du meinst, das muss man jetzt kaufen?
Na ja, in gewisser Hinsicht scheint ja wohl das iPad mit der längsten Akkudauer zu sein. Nur kannst du es halt so explizit nicht bestellen.
Also für Leute, die sowieso nichts sehen, ist das genau das Richtige.
Also für Leute, die überhaupt noch noch gar nicht mitbekommen haben, was Sache ist, wir reden davon, dass ja neben dem neuen iPad auch noch das iPad 2 verkauft wird und wie herausgekommen ist, dass Teile dieser iPad 2, die verkauft werden, tatsächlich ein neues Design haben. Das sogenannte iPad 2,4. Richtig. Also es hat einen kleineren. Der Prozessor ist derselbe. Genau, aber sie haben ihn in einem neuen Prozess gemacht. 32 Nanometer sind das, ne? Oder? Jetzt komm ich was durcheinander. 32. Kilometer glaub ich. Das heißt, sie sind sozusagen dabei zu verkleinern. Sie haben ja was Ähnliches schon gemacht mit dem Prozessor im Apple TV. Da ist es ja auch so ein 32 Nanometer A5, aber halt nur Single Core, wobei manche davon ausgehen, dass das eigentlich auch Dual-Core Prozessoren sind, aber halt quasi so die Ausschussware, wo ein Core nicht funktioniert. Und dann haben sie den da irgendwie einfach als Single Core gemacht.
Die Apple, die müssen halt sparen, wo geht.
Ja, nicht nur sparen, sondern halt auch austesten. Man muss davon ausgehen, dass der A5X, der jetzt in dem iPad 3 ist, auch den Weg ins iPhone, was auch immer wie es heißen wird, das New iPhone finden wird und dann vermutlich auch auf 32 Nanometer geht. Und das Interessante war bei diesem anderen Tech-Artikel, die das mit dem iPad 2.4 entdeckt haben, dass die Stromersparnis wohl enorm sei. Und das Ding irgendwie mal locker 10 bis 15 Prozent länger hält.
Jetzt hält es so lange wie versprochen. Jetzt hält es länger so lange wie versprochen.
Es hält schon immer so lange wie versprochen, soweit ich bisher, ich habe es selber nie getestet, aber ich habe auch noch nie einen Test gesehen, der meint, dass es weniger als die 10 Stunden sind, sondern dass das iPad sehr häufig über die 10 Stunden hinauskommt.
Das Apple immer sehr konservativ ist mit den Batterieangaben im Gegensatz zu anderen Herstellern, also dass wenn Apple 10 Stunden sagt, dass es auch einigermaßen hinhaut, wobei wenn andere 10 Stunden sagen, du dann wirklich irgendwie neben der Antenne liegen musst und alles ist aus und nichts läuft und dunkelste Helligkeit und all sowas.
Und nicht benutzen. Genau. Und es ist ja interessant, ich meine das iPad 3 verbraucht mal locker doppelt so viel Strom bei allem, aber lebt halt deshalb nur genauso lange, weil sie es geschafft haben, die Akku-Menge zu verdoppeln. Wenn sie es also jetzt schaffen mit diesem neuen Prozess, dem iPad 3.
Und weil sie auch schon diesen neuen Chip haben, ne? Der hat den ja auch oder nicht? Also in der 32 Nanometer.
Ich glaube, die haben zuerst den iPad 3. Nein, nein, das ist noch 45 Nanometer.
Die haben zuerst die simpleren Prozessoren geschrumpft.
Das ist ja die Strategie. Den Prozess ändern sie mit einer Technologie, an der sich eigentlich nichts geändert hat. Das heißt, sie nehmen das, von dem sie jetzt schon wissen, dass es funktioniert, und machen es kleiner. Und die Innovationen...
Die Intel-TikTok-Change. Erst irgendwie die Struktur ändern und dann wieder mehr Features rein und dann wieder die Struktur ändern und dann wieder mehr Features rein.
Genau, und es ist natürlich jetzt auch super klug, wie die das mit dem iPad machen. Nach außen hin ist es immer dasselbe Gerät. Du kriegst auf einmal eins, das ist neu, ohne dass dir groß gesagt wird. Und es ist wohl nur ein sehr überschaubarer Anteil der verkauften Geräte. Aber sie können den natürlich jetzt jederzeit größer machen, wenn es funktioniert. Beziehungsweise sie können halt genau auch im direkten Vergleich sehen, hier das hat die und die Ausfallzahlen, hier haben wir die Ausfallzahlen. Und eben sind sozusagen dabei, diesen neuen Prozess schon einzuführen, während sie eben ihr normales Development weiterführen.
Aber im iPad 3 würde es wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr so viel bringen wie bei dem 2er, mit dem 10-15% weil beim iPad 3er es meist eben für das Display drauf geht und nicht für die CDU.
Für die Beleuchtung.
Warte mal, ich muss mal diesen Bericht rausholen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich auch für die Grafik relativ viel.
Es ist wohl wirklich sehr stark, dass die einfach viel, viel heller leuchten, damit das gleiche Licht vorne rauskommt. Und das kostet extrem viel Strom. Dann scheint dieses LTR noch ganz schön teuer zu sein, aber davon haben wir hier eh nichts. weiß keine, ob das der Prozessor so stark ist.
Also es ist halt nur ein Teil. Und der ist beim iPad 3 auf jeden Fall geringer. Egal wie man das dreht.
Also... Na klar, das ist natürlich hier, es kommt jetzt auch ein Chat auf, das ist für Apple dann, der hält nicht nur länger der Akku, sondern was für die natürlich oder wahrscheinlich wesentlich wichtiger ist, die Dinger lassen sich da nicht leichter produzieren, weil du kriegst mehr Chips pro Fläche.
Na leichter produzieren nicht, sehr schwerer produzieren, aber mehr Chips pro Fläche.
Genau, also wenn du es dann einmal drauf hast, dann wird es etwas billiger, den Chip zu produzieren.
Genau, mehr Yield pro Wafer oder wie du das da drin...
Langfristig könntest du sogar einen kleineren Akku einbauen.
Ja klar, wenn der Strom verbraucht, dann wär es leichter, ich glaube, das kommt bei Apple nicht.
Gut. Also das ist jetzt bei Leib nicht so nur der Bildschirm bei dem iPad 3. Also wir haben ja bei anderen Tech eine Liste von verschiedenen Benchmarks und was das iPad 3 da so frisst und das im Vergleich zum iPad 2 und dem iPad 2,4. Und das ist enorm. Also hier gibt es irgendwie so GL Benchmarks, wo das iPad 3 irgendwie 10 Watt frisst und das iPad 2,4,8 und diese überarbeitete Version 4,1 Watt.
Einfach doppelt so viel.
Ja, also das ist fast durchgehend doppelt so viel. Genau, das kann man, glaube ich, so festhalten. Und da ist einfach eine Menge Hub noch für Apple drin, das zu verbessern.
Ja, aber auch auf dem Homescreen braucht das unglaublich viel mehr und das ist halt vermutlich dann wirklich Display. Und du merkst auch, wenn du die Displayhelligkeit aufdrehst, dann wird das Dick warm. Also es ist nicht unangenehm oder sowas, aber das iPad 2 ist eigentlich nie wirklich warm geworden, das iPad 3, was ich eigentlich nie mache, aber wenn man das mal voll auftret, das wird warm.
Hast du eins eigentlich? Du hast das Neue, ne?
Ich hab das, ja. Und wie ist so jetzt? Angeblich ist gerade 10.07.4 gekommen.
Wir müssen mal kurz alle update.
Und, haben sie den Bug drin schon? Welchen Bug?
Na, haben wir vorhin drüber geredet.
In den Release Notes steht es wohl nicht drin.
In den Security Notes steht es ja wahrscheinlich.
Das kann doch sein.
Übrigens, ich habe auch noch ein kleines Update hier für zwischendurch. Denn ich musste letztens meinen Online-Backup-Service mal testen.
Du hast aber das Daten verloren.
Ja, und zwar auf schöne Art und Weise. Also, das Problem war meine Lüfterrattertin vom Diablo 3 Beta zocken. Und dann hat mir der freundliche Admin von meinem Arbeitgeber halt angeboten, gleich das Gerät zu tauschen und mein altes einzuschicken. Haben wir gemacht, habe ich Festplatte umgeschraubt, ging. Das hatte leider ein Glossy-Screen, habe ich ein bisschen genergelt, weil Glossy-Screen geht mal gar nicht. Hat er mir noch ein anderes Austauschgerät gegeben mit Non-Glossy-Screen. Habe ich noch mal Platte umgeschraubt. Also Platte zum dritten Mal getauscht, dann die Kiste hochgefahren, war halt ewig nicht geupdatet, kam erst mal mit 10, 7, irgendwas update und mit Firmware-Update, okay, mach mal. Firmware-Update läuft durch, braucht ein bisschen lange, booted, kommt in meinen File Vault 2 Unlock Passphrase-Screen, so am Anfang, ne? Tipp, aber da sind schon die Dialoge irgendwie, fehlt da so der Bezel am Eingabe-Fall, das sah ein bisschen komisch aus, drück so Enter, kommt noch mal ganz kurz dieser Firmware-Update-Balken und dann Gerät aus. Das war schon mal nicht so muntern, dann habe ich in die Rescue-Partition gebootet, Disk utility aufgemacht, Disk utility gecheckt, Your ist broken, klick mal auf Repair, klick ich auf Repair, sagt da, kann ich nicht Repairen. Weil ich Krypto gehe weg. Also diese Passphrase-Eingabe und so weiter, das hat noch funktioniert und er hat auch das Volumen gemountet, aber er konnte es nicht reparieren.
Das war eine SSD. Also der ist in der SSD gestorben.
Nee, nee, nee, warte mal. Also irgendwie war halt der Effekt, immer nach einem Passwort eingeben, kam noch kurz dieser Firmware-Update-Balken dann aus. Das heißt irgendwie dieses Firmware-Update ist halt mittendrin irgendwie stecken geblieben. Na ja gut, also ich konnte die Platte dann noch auf einem anderen Rechner, ja, konnte ich noch Read-Only mounten, wohlgemerkt, das Krypto, konnte meinen Scheiß auch so rüber kopieren und dachte mir, alles klar, ich hab ja zuhause Backup und ich hab ja online Backup und ich kopiere jetzt mal den Scheiß, den ich wirklich nur brauche und den ich nicht im Backup hab, wie zum Beispiel die ganze Musik. Und bin mal ganz bold und installiere Clean sozusagen, von der Rescue Partition und mach dann ein Update von, hol mein Scheiß wieder aus dem online Backup, gesagt, getan. Aus der Rescue Partition installieren ging auch angenehm schnell natürlich, weil von SSD. So und dann hochgefahren und dann der Lackmus-Test, wie man so schön sagt, für das online Backup Tool und es war eigentlich echt entspannt, muss man sagen, weil ich dachte erst, oh Gott, jetzt brauche ich meine Credentials und meine Passphrase und was nicht alles. Aber das A kommt dann hoch und sagt so, ja Moment, du musst dich hier erstmal identifizieren, klick mal hier auf den Button, kommst du auf deine Amazon S3 Seite mit dem Api-Key und so weiter. Also ist alles gleich so im Workflow integriert, musst du gar nicht groß nachdenken, oh Gott, wie komme ich jetzt an meinen S3-Account und so weiter, macht er alles schon für einen. Ok, angeklickt, dann holt er sich die Liste von deinen Backups, die du da abgelegt hast, habe ich ausgewählt und dann kannst du auch sagen, entweder gib mir den ganzen Scheiß oder gib mir nur einzelne Folder. Zum Beispiel bei Foldern, die schon jetzt existieren, zum Beispiel in der Library gibt es so ein paar Folder, die traut er sich nicht jetzt sofort selber zu überschreiben, mit dem Restorten oder den Kram da wieder reinzulegen. Was er dann tut, ist zum Beispiel zu sagen, bei Keychains legt er dann Keychains Restored from Arc-Folder daneben und dann kann man das manuell noch rüber schubsen. Das Einzige, was ein bisschen nervig ist, dass es trotzdem aus Irland kommt vom Amazon S3 Data Center, war es halt vergleichsweise lahm, sage ich mal. Also manchmal gab es halt so 6 Megabyte die Sekunde, manchmal gab es aber auch nur 600 Kilobyte die Sekunde. Das fluktuierte sehr stark, sagen wir mal. Also es war jetzt nicht so dieses so, ey, ich sitze an der 100 MBit-Leitung und wupp, hier, bitteschön, ist dein Online-Backup. Aber es war noch schnell genug, sage ich mal. Also für, ich habe ja so meine Library komplett im Backup und meine Documents und meine Projekte und so. Das sind so, glaube ich, insgesamt 20 GB oder so. Meine letzte Rechnung war, glaube ich, drei Euro und noch irgendwas pro Monat. Also du zahlst ja nur S3 Storage. Du zahlst einmal dieses Programm für 30 Dollar und dann zahlst du nur noch dein S3 Storage. Und dann kannst du eben noch sagen, ob du den normalen willst, der ja auch redundant ist.
Also über 20 Gigabyte zahlst du drei Euro im Monat.
Ich glaube, so was in dem Dreh war das, ja. Also es war unter fünf, definitiv, wenn ich mich rechne. Und du kannst halt immer noch sagen, du willst die no redundant Storage auf S3. Wenn du eh nochmal andere Backups hast und dir das egal ist, ob es jetzt bei Amazon nochmal intern repliziert ist, dein Bucket, dann zahlst du, glaube ich, sogar noch ein paar Cent weniger. Also es ist pro... Ja, wird auch immer genau. So, aber ich hab gesagt, hier, mach Maridana. Du kannst halt in dem Arc ja auch sagen, pass auf, ich will nur 15 Dollar im Monat maximal ausgeben. Und der speichert ja auch Historie von deinen Backups, also wie bei Time Machine. Und der räumt dann halt auch einmal die Woche oder so auf und guckt so, ok, dein Budget ist das, wie viel hast du gerade in deinem Bucket liegen, muss ich aufräumen, ja oder nein? Und dann, je nachdem, schmeißt er halt auch alten Kram weg.
Ja, verstehe, deswegen sind in den Arc-Updates dann immer so Preisanpassungen mit drin und so.
Also, war erstmal gut.
Also alles wieder angekommen. Hat funktioniert, das ist ja eigentlich das Wichtigste.
Andererseits, muss man auch noch anmerken, hatte der Arc-Typie letztens einen Buck drin.
Ja, das hab ich gelesen, zwei Versionen über...
Deswegen, wenn man dann nach dem dritten Update von Arc einmal nochmal komplett alles hochschieben musste. Na gut, war es auch nicht so dramatisch. Und ach, dieser Blogpost von dem Typen, der ist aber eigentlich voll gut. Nämlich, er hat so einen Blogpost auch geschrieben, die sieben des Back-Ups, also so irgendwie Guidelines oder was auch immer.
Mantras.
Mantras. Und das war echt eigentlich eine ganz gute Lese-Empfehlung für jeden, der mal sich wirklich über Back-Ups Gedanken macht, weil Leute denken ja, ok, ich hab eine externe Platte zuhause mit Time Machine und denken, das ist ein Back-Up. Ist kein Back-Up, Jungs. Müssen wir nochmal drüber nachdenken.
Sondern?
Naja, also du musst mindestens natürlich zwei Locations haben und eine davon sollte natürlich ein Offside-Back-Up sein, weil wenn alle deine Rechner und Platten an der gleichen Stelle stehen und der Blitz einschlägt und das Haus abbrennt, dann...
Das ist auf jeden Fall...
Oder das BKA vor der Tür steht.
Oder das BKA vor der Tür steht oder was auch immer. Da, Sieben Facets of a Good Back-Up Strategy, den kannst du ja mal in die Show-Notes packen.
Apropos, wenn das BKA vor der Tür steht, ja ich hab letztens...
Gibt es eine App für?
Ich hab letztens zwei Festplatten gefunden, die ich vor sechs Jahren mal versteckt habe.
Und jetzt so, jetzt kommt gleich in die Straße schon die Polizei eigentlich.
Nobody expects the Spanish Inquisition.
Ja, ne, die sind schon in der Tonne jetzt.
Das muss ja sehr lange her gewesen sein.
Da hätten die ja nicht mal mehr was mit anfangen können.
Die konnten auch sowieso mit nichts anfangen.
Wie dem auch sei.
Dank Fallwold.
ARK hat auf jeden Fall funktioniert erstmal für mich.
Super, das ist doch......jut.
Ich will jetzt wieder...
Ich will jetzt wieder, aber ich weiß noch nicht was.
Ich wollte noch ganz kurz was einnehmen. Ich glaube, ich hätte das schon in der letzten oder sogar schon in der vorletzten Sendung machen müssen. Und da haben sich ein paar Leute gewundert. Die twitterten mich dann an, was bei mir mal heißt, irgendwie aktuelle Feuchtigkeit 74 Prozent. Nein, das ist natürlich nicht meine Feuchtigkeit. Da habe ich mal so ein Botanifon, die backt. Und das ist so ein kleines Platinchen mit zwei Kupferstäben, die in die Blumenerde reinkommen von einer Pflanze. Kommt die ist da nicht mit dran und stromt. Und dann twittert die Pflanze, wenn sie durstig ist. Könnt ihr mal irgendwie googeln, das heißt Botanifon. Und ansonsten die Blume, die ich da debackt habe, die nennt sich bei Twitter Blumenantenne. Und steht gerade in Berliner Club und hat vorhin auch wieder gesagt, dass es schon lange nicht mehr geregnet hat. Aber spinnt gerade halt immer noch so ein ganz bisschen. Aber wer auch irgendwie sowas haben will, heißt...
Geschmeid sich auch, dass er zu viel Wasser bekommen hat und so.
Ja, die zickt gerade rum. Ist eine kleine Zicke irgendwie. Ganz komisch. Also das ist voll trockene Pflanze und sie heult nicht rum und dann gießt sie. Und dann ist sie aber auch wieder gleich zu viel. Also irgendwie erinnert mich das immer so ein bisschen an an den kleinen Prinzen da drauf. Eine zickige Pflanze irgendwie als Freundin, oder? Ja, die war auch so zickig und am Ende war es ja seine Lieblingspflanze, weil alle anderen waren ja irgendwie gleich und langweilig. Und er wollte halt die eine Zicke haben und so ist die ja auch. Die ist nerds und botanik. Ja, die zickt auch ein bisschen rum. Und Botanifon heißt das, gibt es auch bei den ganzen Atmel oder Arduino-Geschichten. Ist so ein Arduino mit Arduino-Software auch. Und ja, das Ursprungsprojekt davon heißt Botanical, der hat wohl die Blume in SMS gesendet oder so. Inzwischen machen wir Twitter. Ist ein bisschen teuer, aber ist eigentlich ganz spaßig.
Ich hab noch eine Mac-App, die vielleicht ganz gut ist. So ein kleines Tool. Und zwar heißt das Function Flip. Darüber haben wir neulich mal geredet, über dieses Thema, dass man nämlich diese F-Keys da oben, dass die ja teilweise haben die diese Funktionen, die im Teller, dunkler, lauter, leiser.
Wo ich so gereinzt hab und total daneben lag.
Genau.
Wieso lagst du daneben?
Weil ich zu dem Zeitpunkt geklaut habe, dass man das alles nicht... Also meine Probleme entstanden im Wesentlichen dadurch, dass irgendwie alles durch 1000 Updates überlagert war, man das aber auch alles cleanen kann. Function Flip finde ich hier nicht im Mac App Store.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht Mac App Store. Das ist zum Runterladen, kostet nichts. Das gibt es nicht im Store. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das ins Store reinkommen würde, weil es ist ein Preference Pane und so. Also das ist hier für die Systemeinstellung. Und damit kann man nämlich pro Taste separat einstellen, möchte ich gerne die als F-Taste benutzen oder möchte ich die gerne als die Funktion, die draufgemalt ist, nutzen.
Das ist doch was für mich.
Also dann kann man sagen, mute möchte ich gerne, dass da F10 kommt, aber laut, das soll trotzdem funktionieren oder sowas.
Ach herrlich.
Kann man auch, wenn man eine externe Tastatur hat oder so, kann man das für jede Tastatur separat einstellen.
Das ist cool, weil es gibt so ein paar, die benutze ich nie, und es gibt ein paar, da bin ich echt froh, dass ich eben nicht Funktion drücken muss. Coole Maat, geiler Tipp. Das hier Profi-Podcast. Hammerz.
Ich verstehe immer diese Apple Knowledge Base Security-Posts nicht.
Der ist noch nicht da, der kommt noch. Das machen die jedes Mal, die Scheißer.
Erstmal alle installieren und danach erzählen wir euch, welche Bugs wir gefixt haben.
Genau, sonst könnte man ja jetzt schon gucken.
Ach, das ist der Grund. Ich dachte, das wäre einfach, ich hätte alles verpeilt.
Also, das haben sie alles gefixt. Ja, bin ich in der Liste. Also, ja, genau. Na gut, jetzt könnt ihr auch selber klicken, wahrscheinlich, weil ihr es ja da. Aber jetzt peichle ich es hier rein. Da, zack. Wie man es noch nicht hat, da kann man klicken.
Meiner lebt noch.
Echt?
Lebt, lebt, lebt.
Hast du das bei der Leitung platt gemacht? Hast du das bei der Leitung platt gemacht?
Ach, du lebst das nicht, nee?
Nee, ich hab's schon.
Achso, du hattest es schon vorher geladen.
Aber ich kann euch sagen, dieses VDSL ist ganz schön fies, weil exakt als ich 512 Megabyte hatte, ist es irgendwie von 3 ms so plopp auf 10k runtergedroppt. Also wenn das nicht Shaping ist, die verarschen dich, Timme.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden mit meinem VDSL2. Vor allem, ich hatte neulich so einen Erweckungsmoment. Ich benutze ja jetzt auch immer Awfonic hier, um die Sendungen zu mastern. Und anfangs hielt ich das für eine ganz großartige Idee, immer meinen scheißen Dropbox zu werfen, zu warten, bis es hochgeladen ist, und dann über den Umweg das zu machen.
Das machst du jetzt nicht mehr?
Naja, es ist in gewisser Hinsicht schon mal an sich ein Zeitverlust, weil ich erst mal den Upload abwarten muss. Und es gibt ja auch den direkten Upload über die Webseite. Nun ist ja so Upload in Webseiten von großen Dateien etwas, wo man sich erst dran gewöhnen muss, dass es mittlerweile funktioniert. Und nun steht ja der Auphonic-Server in so einem Uni-Komplex Graz. Also die sind da irgendwie akademisches Netzwerk, dicke Glasfasern, keine Ahnung, ich kenne da keine Spezifiker. Nur habe ich irgendwie dann den Unterschied mitbekommen. So Telekom, Querverbindungen, akademische Netzwerke, die auch bis Österreich reichen, da war wohl echt Hub drin. So und ich habe einfach so eine gewisse gefühlte Geschwindigkeit so im Kopf, wenn ich so etwas in Dropbox reinwerfe. Und ich hatte dann halt nicht nachgedacht und habe dann irgendwie eine 750 Megabyte Datei aus dem Podcast gemacht. Ich glaube, das war sogar jetzt eine Mobamex-Sendung, die so unheimlich lang war und dann halt rausrendern und dann kannst du halt noch... Ich weiß nicht, das war glaube ich sogar schon... Ich mach das immer mit Flak noch kleiner und so. Ich könnte auch eine MP4 mit großem Enkoding und so weiter machen, aber ich mach mir dann immer so den Spaß, das einfach mal ankompressen zu machen. Und dann habe ich einfach diesen File-Upload gemacht und ich bin verrückt geworden, als auf einmal dieser Balken einfach mit sichtbarer Geschwindigkeit auf die 100% zuschoss. Also das war für mich wirklich ein Bandwidth-Schock. Das war einfach, ich weiß nicht, ich habe das nie so richtig gemessen, wie viel Prozent ich meiner Leitung hier wirklich nutze, weil das war einfach so dermaßen viel schneller alles, seitdem ich 10 Megabit Upstream habe. Aber übern Teich ist halt dann doch schon noch mal ein bisschen was anderes, als hier nur in die...
Ja, zu Dropbox.
Wobei man angeschlossenen Gebiete in Österreich.
Bei Dropbox habe ich neulich von Mr. Toto den großartigen Hinweis bekommen, dass man bei Dropbox, die haben nach jedem Update, was die einem unterjubeln, machen die ein Reset, also du kannst in den Einstellungen sagen, wie hoch die Bandwidth ist, die Maximale, und die setzen das immer wieder zurück auf, mach das mal automatisch, mach da mal nicht volle Bandbreite. Das ist natürlich so auf der einen Seite vielleicht für die User ein bisschen...
Die hält auch nicht, deswegen setzen sie immer wieder zurück.
Genau, deswegen setzen sie es zurück. Aber es gibt die Einstellungen, und die soll man unbedingt zurücksetzen. Das andere war, was ich bei Network, und da guckst du bei Bandwidth, und da ist beides auf Don't Limit. Bei mir war da hier schön Automatic Limit eingestellt. Was ich aber sehr lustig fand, auf der Republika bin ich ja mit einem schweren, da fühlt man sich auch mal so richtig schön wie 2008, wenn man mit so einem 15 Zoll MacBook Pro über die Republika rennt. Alle um dich rum haben bestenfalls iPads dabei, die die ganz schwer schleppen wollen, ein 13 Zoll MacBook Air. Mit so einem 15 Zoll MacBook ist man da wirklich einsam. Das merkt man auch so richtig im Rucksack, weil ich musste ja die Aufnahme machen, dafür brauchte ich Firewire, 15 Zoll MacBook Air. Da hatte ich diese Aufnahme gemacht und wollte jetzt gerne hochspielen. Und da ist auf Phonik natürlich mal ganz großartig, hier bei den Zipgate Leuten, da habe ich mich bei denen an den Stand geschleimt, dass ich deren WLAN mitnutzen durfte, habe da das MacBook hingestellt, habe das hochladen lassen. Hab dann mit dem iPad nachgeguckt, gelegentlich mal, ob der Upload jetzt fertig war. Und dann irgendwann, hat ziemlich lange gedauert, so schnell war das selbst auf den Messeständen das Republikanetz nicht, aber immerhin hatten sie welches. Und dann war der Upload irgendwann fertig, habe ich auf Phonik angeschmissen, direkt vom iPad aus rüberkopieren lassen und konnte dann den kompletten Podcast ab da offline, also vom iPad aus publizieren und so. Das ist auch wirklich geil, dass man so nach diesem ganzen ah, jetzt hat er es gerechnet, jetzt muss man es nicht mehr irgendwie noch hochladen, sondern es ist automatisch da oben.
Freien, ne?
Kann ich immer ein bisschen Strom von dir haben?
Erst schleimst du dich bei Zipgate ins WLAN, jetzt schleimst du dich bei Tim an die Stromader.
Genau.
Das ist ja nicht zu fassen.
Ja, so sieht es aus. Ich hab's gelernt, wie man sich so durchschnort. Wer hat noch so einen WLAN-Schnorrer? Nein.
Was machen wir da?
Du hast das andere Netzteil. Und Dennis hat wahrscheinlich das Netzteil.
Willst du meinen Strom haben?
Das ist ganz schön teuer hier. Mobile Mix. Muss hier für jeden der Herren, muss man hier noch ein eigenes Netzteil vorhalten.
Ich hab meins dabei.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist auch gut so weit. Aber im Rucksack.
Ich hab meins auch dabei.
Auch im Rucksack.
Er holst bloß nie raus.
Aber das gehört hier alles zum Service.
Das gewinnt man sich mit einem MacBook eher ab, ein Netzteil mitzunehmen. Also für so dieses alltägliche...
Und jetzt siehst du, was du davon hast.
Also ich will das einfach von Tim nehmen, wenn er es nicht braucht.
Es ist halt eins vor Ort da und so Sendung reicht das über. Und so dieses übliche im Café rumsitzen. Du bist auch immer am Oberholz? Nee, nicht immer, aber...
Da kamer wir jetzt nicht sofort in einen Line.
Ich bin manchmal mit im Oberholz.
So, wollen wir jetzt eigentlich aufhören oder wollen wir noch über Nokia ziehen?
Ein Kumpel von mir meinte letztens, er erholt sich demnächst neue Reifen von Nokian. Doch, also Nokia verkauft immer noch Autoreifen unter dem Namen Nokian.
Nokian.
Mit ein hinten dran.
Und demnächst dann Microsoft Nokia Reifen XP.
Kann sein. Express.
Im Eckig, falls man es will.
Was ich ja sehr lustig fand, da hab ich einen Tweet aufgeschnappt und siehe da. Also sofern das sich hier, sofern es nicht hineingeschummelt wurde, aber ich glaube jetzt einfach mal, was das Wiktionary mir sagt. Ihr wisst schon, Wiktionary ist so das Wörterbuch von Wikipedia. Und da gibt es im Spanischen einen Eintrag für das Wort Lumia. Das war doch der Name, oder?
Das hatten wir schon in der Sendung.
Hatten wir schon?
Ja sag mal, was ist denn?
Und?
Prostituiert oder irgendwie sowas?
Ja, das hatten wir noch nicht.
Doch.
Das haben wir ja erwähnt.
Irgendwelche Spanier im Chat hier?
Als ich nicht da war? Das ist eine gute Ausrede. Es gab mal eine Sendung, wo ich nicht dabei war. Ah, das habt ihr bestimmt in dieser Sendung gesagt.
Das Lumia gibt's doch schon seit wann? Seit einem Jahr? Seit einem Dreivierteljahr oder was? Wer hat das ganz, ganz am Anfang?
Noch bevor die Spanier das wussten.
Die Spanier?
Na, das ist auch Spanisch Nutter heißt.
Das ist Notenfohlen. Ich mein, das passt natürlich irgendwie echt gut, ne?
Ja, aber die scheinen auch...
Was willst du da mal sagen?
Naja, dass sie sich doch hier an Microsoft vernutzt haben.
Wenn du nicht so recht hättest.
Ich find das ja lustig, dass Nokia jetzt ungefähr 500.000 exklusive Apps angekündigt hat, die es nur für die Lumia-Telefone geben wird und nicht für andere Windows 7-Telefone.
Wer soll die schreiben?
Das ist geil.
Na, die schreiben sie selber.
Ich verstehe es. Viele?
Viele, viele, viele.
Das gibt wirklich Vertrauen in die Plattform, oder?
Also erstens, die gehören so halb zu Microsoft. Wieso wären die nicht einfach an alle? Und dann ist es ja nicht so, dass irgendjemand sagt, so unglaublich viele Windows 7-Phones zwischen denen ich mich entscheide, da nehme ich doch das für, dass es mehr Apps gibt. Also baut noch irgendjemand außer Nokia gerade Windows-Telefone? Ernsthaft? Ich glaube HTC noch dreieinhalb. HTC vielleicht, keine Ahnung.
Also wirklich. Meine Herren, ich darf euch ja bitten.
Ist das das Zeichen, dass die Sendung zu Ende geht?
Dass sie gerade erst anfängt.
Ich muss hier noch 10.7.4 installieren.
Solange geht dieser Podcast noch.
Der Balken ist erst zu einem Drittel durch.
Sechs Geräte, die man hier eben mal einen Gigabyte aus dem Netz schlabbern muss.
Die Objekte sind noch nicht am Zielort.
Nicht?
Nein. Ich warte erst mal ab.
Ich warte auch ab.
Ich nicht.
Das kann doch besser werden. Kann man sich auch nur so einen kleinen General vorstellen.
Aber was sagen sie denn, was jetzt überhaupt neu sei?
Wie bei Nokia?
Nein, bei 10.7.4.
Alles besser, alles toll. Immer Bugs, von denen noch niemand gehört hat, oder?
Schön finde ich den einen Security-Bug-Impact, when File Vault is used, the disk may contain unencrypted user data.
Ach, und vorhin haben wir uns noch gefragt, wann ja gefixt wird der Bug.
Was hab ich euch gesagt? Ich hab gesagt, wir werden dann nichts machen, sondern erst ein Update.
Nein, nein, nein.
Wie war's? Zwei Stunden später.
Das ist nicht der Bug, über den wir vorher geredet haben. Sondern es handelt sich wohl um dieses File Vault II Zeug. An issue in the kernel's handling of the sleep image is used for hibernation, left some data unencrypted on disk, even when File Vault was enabled. Also das muss ein File Vault II Bug sein.
Huckel, die haben da einen Bug gefixt.
Aber war nicht die VM-Files schon immer verschlüsselt? Oder auch ohne? Ich weiß nicht.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht verschlüsseln sie die VM-Files nicht mehr, seit sie ja sowieso den ganzen Disk verschlüsseln. Ich weiß es nicht.
Wird ja auch.
Und vielleicht gab es da einen Fall, wo halt dann irgendwie die Full-Disk-Enscription nicht an war und sie das unverschlüsselte VM-File dann drauf geballert haben. Das wär dann auch eine super Art, irgendwie Passwörter auf eine Platte zu lassen.
Was ich immer noch immer wieder als Problem habe, hatte ich gestern erst gehabt. Mein Rechner ist an einem Cinema-Display dran, an so einem älteren, aber noch kein Thunderbolt und so. Und wenn ich normal den Deckel zuklappe, geht's schlafen. Wenn ich aber ins Menü gehe und sage Sleep, dann geht er auch schlafen, aber er wacht nie wieder auf. Da kommt dann hoch und dann kommt das Spinning-Pizza-of-Dash und ich kann mich nicht einloggen und muss dann hardcore-mäßig ausdrücken. Anders kriege ich mich wieder aufgeweckt.
Hast du mal deine Platte gecheckt? Irgendwann mal so? Wenn?
Schon eine Weile, ja. Aber hatte ich davor das Problem und danach auch?
Mach mal Verify.
Okay, Huckel sagt Verify.
Wenn du so ein paar Mal hart ausschaltest, dann...
Also deswegen meinst du das nicht, dass ich Probleme löse, aber dass ich nicht noch eins kriege. Und ich hab das echt öfter, dass ich das irgendwie so hab, weil...
Huckel wird hier noch so ein Hardware-Doktor.
Ja, ich sag dir, das geht bergab.
Immer Sport treiben und...
Und immer mal wieder clean installen zwischendurch. Und was nicht alles, echt, ey, dieses Apple... Tim Cook musselt mir noch beweisen. Muss mir nur überzeugen. Ja, irgendwie, die haben auch alle keine Angst mehr vor dem Chefwitz. Hattest du die Theorie hier schon erwähnt? Die Angsttheorie?
Dass die Angst nicht mehr regiert, oder was?
Ne, echt, also vorher hat sich halt irgendwie so ein Team dreimal überlegt, ob sie zu Steve gehen und ihm eine Demo zeigen. Und haben sich echt erstmal ins Zeug gelegt und dreimal überlegt, ob es gut genug ist.
Du meinst, der Koch scheißt ihn nicht mehr zusammen?
Und jetzt ist halt so ein Chiller da, ja. So ein Softie. Der auch. Ist ja auch ein Softie. Aber jetzt haben sie keine Angst mehr, glaube ich.
Ja, da habe ich aber andere Storys gehört.
Der muss mich noch überzeugen.
Nicht über den Koch, aber schon über Chiller irgendwie. Also ich glaube, so freundlich ist es nicht hier.
Der Chiller ist kein Chiller.
Wie heißt nochmal dieser creepy iOS-Guy?
Scott.
Scott Forster.
Dem wird ja so eine gewisse jobsche Affinität zum Verhalten nachgesagt.
Aber das Ding ist halt, es ist glaube ich auch schwer, nicht nur diesen jobschen Perfektionismus an den Start zu legen, sondern eben auch das so in Bahnen zu lenken, dass es produktiv ist. Es gibt ja auch die Leute, die es dann übertreiben und dann irgendwie... So wie eine Feuerwerksrakete, die dem Plätzchen zu sich liegt.
Mach das Geräusch nochmal bitte.
Diesen Jobschen Ding kann sowieso keiner nachmachen. Ich meine so ein Frutarier auf LSD. Mit Technologiewision irgendwie, also das...
Da legt sich die Lampe hin.
Und zerstört das iMac.
Das hat sich ja schon lange abgezeichnet hier.
Haben wir runtergelacht.
Wir haben es ja eigentlich schon geahnt vorhin, ne? So ist es.
So geht es zu in der Mitte.
Achtung, Moment, Trommelwürfel nochmal.
Der Hucke hatte recht, durch das Resetten gestern, weil die Kiste halt nicht mehr hochkam, war tatsächlich mein Filesystem, meinte hier Discuted, ich voll im Arsch. Reparieren kann er ja nicht, wenn man davon gebootet hat. Also hat er gesagt, ich soll Command-R drücken.
Ich muss erstmal anlocken. In deinem Volume, damit er das klickt.
Wieso? Ich will doch erstmal die ganze Platte her. Geht schon, passt. Lass sie erst mal machen. Jedenfalls muss ich jetzt mal mit Command-R in meine HD-Rescue-Image booten, und da kann ich jetzt mal hier meinen...
Hier musst du erstmal deinen Krypto anlocken, damit er da richtig loslegen kann.
Ja, dieses kranke... Ich hab heute auch nochmal bei Cevo geklickt, ob sich da eigentlich irgendwas getan hat.
Irgendwann kann man ein Update, aber...
Die Silver Edition, die Goldene gibt es noch nicht. Da steht immer noch Spring 2012.
Doch, die kleinste ist doch Silver. Die mittlere ist Gold, die große ist Platinum.
Also es gibt nach wie vor nur das, was...
Das kleinste, ja. Wundert mich auch ein bisschen, warum die sich so lange Zeit lassen. Eigentlich muss man auf der Welle reiten und das ausnutzen, weil da war ja schon so ein bisschen Newscoverage, aber irgendwie lässt er sich da voll Zeit. Aber ja.
Ich hoffe, dass er sich nur Zeit lässt.
Wie?
Naja, das nicht bedeutet, dass er irgendwelche Probleme hat.
Nee, nee, Updates kamen in der Zwischenzeit. Also 2x. Also 101 wurde ja ausgeliefert und danach kam 102 und so 2, 3 Wochen danach schon 103. Hat dann mal irgendwelche Reboot... Nee, irgendwelche Reset-Bugs, tra-la-la gefixt. Ich hatte nie welche, aber... Ich hatte bisher noch nie Ärger.
Mountain-Line und Fallsysteme, irgendwas?
Ich muss zugeben, ich hab das mit den Betas und Mountain-Line auch nicht mehr so richtig weiterverfolgt. Irgendwie. Deswegen kann ich nicht sagen, was da passiert ist.
Dann kommt es auch irgendwie zu früh.
Wann soll denn das rauskommen?
Das kommt doch jetzt.
Im Juni, angeblich.
Nächsten Monat?
Ja, zur WWDC wahrscheinlich.
Fucking hell, wir sitzen hier, in einem Monat kommt ein neues Betriebssystem raus und uns interessiert es nicht.
Weißt du, was es bringt?
Ja, aber sonst waren wir total excited und konnten es nicht erwarten. Und mussten uns jede Beta reinholen.
Was ist denn los?
Neulich habe ich meine erste Runde gedreht auf Inline Skates in diesem Jahr. Das spielt keine große Rolle. Und dann holt ich irgendwie so... Dann holt ich mein ganzes Equipment raus. Das habe ich jetzt echt schon lange nicht mehr benutzt, weil ich irgendwie durch zahlreiche Umstände irgendwie nicht so richtig zum Sport gekommen bin. Unter anderem ein Helm. Und dann stell dich fest, oh Mann, auf dem Helm habe ich ein Apple-Logo kleben.
Den noch mit in bunt?
Ne weiß. Schwarzer Helm, weißes Apple-Logo. Und ich weiß noch, als ich das Teil da drauf gekriegt habe, dachte ich mir so, cool. Und in dem Moment hab ich mich so ein bisschen geschämt.
Kniwi, Kniwi, Kniwi, Kniwi, Kniwi.
Aber ehrlich, war es damals nicht komisch, oder?
Also wenn der Apple bunt wäre, dann würde ich sagen, das ist schon cool.
Ja, so einen bunten Apple hätte ich mir dann gleich gewünscht. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich fühle mich irgendwie anders. Du hast das ja, glaube ich, neulich mal aufgebracht, oder? Oder warst du das?
Dass man sich nicht mehr traut, sein iPhone noch rauszuholen, weil irgendwie alle eins haben?
Na ja, mit dem iPhone habe ich nicht so das Problem, weil das war mal scheiß praktisch, aber so dieses... Dieser Apfel-Aufkleber war ja eigentlich immer legendär. Du hast irgendwie ein Produkt gekauft und kriegst genau einen Aufkleber dazu.
Und alle waren noch heiß drauf.
Na zwei, es waren immer zwei.
Bei den großen zwei, bei den kleinen eins.
Und der prangte dann so...
Huckel hat recht.
Ja, und alle vier Wochen hast du mal ein Auto in Berlin entdeckt, wo irgendwie dieser Aufkleber drauf war. Das war immer so, ah ja.
Zwischendurch ist Auto so, wo keiner drauf ist.
Verschwörung und so weiter. So ein bisschen wie dieser komische Christenfisch und so weiter.
Ja, das ist im Untergrund.
Ja, so ganz abwegig ist es nicht. Und ja, irgendwie...
Das ist gar nicht der Fisch von Anglern?
Na ja, gut, aber ehrlich gesagt, da ist noch so eine Sache, da kann ich verschmerzen. Wenn jetzt ein Mountain-Line rauskommt...
Was mache ich jetzt auf meinem Helm?
Du musst mit der Zeit skaten.
Aber so, was mache ich jetzt mit meinem Helm? Ist auch so ein bisschen so wie, warum liegt hier Stroh?
Was mache ich jetzt auf meinem Helm?
Ich meine, echt so...
Warum hast du eine Maske auf?
Mich betrifft echt viel mehr das Mountain-Line mit dem Bloat Bear, der schon ja mal an zur Sprache kam, dass der jetzt los liegt und uns das überhaupt nicht interessiert. Keine Features drin sind, die uns kicken, keine Pro-Features, das ist sowieso, das rückt ja immer weiter weg. Je mehr wir es uns wünschen, desto weiter entfernt es sich von uns. Fallsystemen haben wir auch nichts gehört. Ich hab jetzt hier während der Sendung immer so partiell Mac-Stories und Apple Insider, alle 250 Storys so im Takt durchgekriegt, um wenigstens eine coole News, irgendeinen coolen Hardware-Rumor, irgendwas zum MacBook Pros, irgendwas, nichts. Und ich hab diesen RSS-Reader bestimmt zwei Monate nicht aufgemacht. So sieht es einfach mal aus. Es ist alles...
Es geht den Bach runter.
Es ist einfach...
We are non-excited.
Underexcited.
Keine Erregung. Kommt auf das Xcode 4.4 mit diesen ganzen neuen LLVM-Funktionen.
Im Juni!
Wahrscheinlich zur WWDC.
Bisschen vorher wär er schon schick.
Was für neue Funktionen.
Synthesize muss man nicht mehr reinschreiben.
Synthesize muss man nicht mehr reinschreiben. Kannst halt Arrays und Dictionaries, kannst jetzt so ein bisschen... Literals definieren und so. Das erinnert sich schon ein bisschen.
Das ist voll fies, wenn man die ganze Zeit codet und da noch Synthesize hinschreiben muss, wenn man weiß, demnächst kommt, und dann kann man das alles wieder wegmachen. Was macht dieses Synthesize? Wenn man halt ein Property im header-File willst, im clued-File, dann musst du halt trotzdem im method-File noch Synthesize...
Du musst ein Stück früher anfangen. Also, damals, irgendwann kam man ja mal drauf, dass es schön ist, Klassen zu haben und in den Klassen hat man schöne Member-Variablen und irgendjemand ist auf die Idee gekommen, zu jeder Member-Variable einen Getter und einen Zetter zu machen. Und irgendwann kam bei Apple...
Was heißt zum Machen?
An die Klasse ran zu hängen. An die Klasse ran zu hängen.
An die Sprache, das nicht mit sich bringt.
Die Sprache bringt es nicht mit sich.
Du musstest für alles einen Getter und einen Zetter schreiben.
Genau, jetzt hat Apple irgendwann dieses Key-Value-Coding und dieses Zeug eingeführt und Key-Value-Observation und so weiter. Sprich, wenn du den Getter und den Zetter hast, dann kannst du über bestimmte Funktionen besondere Dinge tun. Und irgendwann sind sie dann draufgekommen und haben dem Compiler beigebracht, dieses sogenannte Property-Makro. Nennt man das Makro? Keine Ahnung. Ja, es ist Teil der Sprache. Es ist so ein Aufruf Add Property. Und dann konnte man festsetzen, was soll denn der Getter und der Zetter können. Wie sollen die ungefähr aussehen?
Zum Beispiel Comic oder Read-Only.
Also du konntest bestimmte, welche Eigenschaft die Viable hat.
Und dieses, wenn du Property hingeschrieben hast, das hast du meistens im Haar-File gemacht und hast du den deklariert und definiert. Ich komme immer durcheinander. Und Synthesize hast du dann hingeschrieben am Endfile, um das zu implementieren. Also du musstest extra immer hinschreiben, bitte implementier mir die auch. Mach mir Code dafür. Und das war dieses Synthesize-Makro. Und das kann man jetzt weglassen. Das heißt, du schreibst nur Property und musst dann aber nicht im anderen File nochmal Synthesize hinschreiben.
Das ist eigentlich das Coole gerade, weil Apple fängt an auch, wie sie es ja eigentlich überall immer eine ganze Menge machen, alten Scheiß rauszuschmeißen und irgendwie aufzureimen. Und sie räumen gerade Objective-C auf, oder?
Ja, die monetisieren die Sprache ganz gewaltig.
Ist das so variabel, dass sie jetzt in das Implementation rübergerutscht sind, wenn man die Private haben will, über so ein Trick zwar so ein bisschen, in dem sie halt eine leere Category irgendwie oben ransetzen?
Ist das so neu? Ich dachte, das hab ich quasi... Ich bin ja erst so kurz dabei, dass sie das quasi immer machen.
Die leere Category ist relativ neu.
Und vorher waren halt Instanzvariate immer im Hedder-File und die waren immer mehr oder weniger Public. Und jetzt kannst du sie einfach rüberschieben und damit sind sie out of sight und nicht mehr sichtbar. Also kodmäßig schon, aber sind keine echten Private, aber du kriegst sie nicht mehr.
Hier nochmal die Literals, die schon angesprochen wurden, wo du halt Container relativ einfach befüllen kannst mit Objekten, indem du das alles so direkt hinschreibst.
Also Add1 ist ja zum Beispiel ein Objekt mit LSNummer mit dem Wert von 1.
Mit Here meine ich, ich hab den Link in den Chat gepostet.
Da freut sich der Podcast-Juror.
Gibt's hinterher in den Show-Nodes.
Und darum meinte ich vorhin, es gibt keinen besseren Zeitpunkt, als mit Objective-C anzufangen, als jetzt, weil die sich gerade echt Mühe geben, um den ganzen Scheiß einfacher zu machen. Und gerade für die ganzen Ruby und JavaScript und weiss der Teufel, was Leute da draußen nehmen, das wirklich ein bisschen erträglicher oder besser zu machen. Und mit ARK ist, glaube ich, so viel besser geworden. Auf jeden Fall. Und wir haben komplett umgestellt. Also bei uns gibt es jetzt kein Projekt mehr, was nicht mehr ARK ist. Außer vielleicht irgendeinen alten Schlafschnitzel, den man mir angefasst hat.
Wir haben noch ein Projekt, was halt Garbage Collection benutzt. Von Garbage Collection auf ARK umzustellen, das wird echt interessant.
Schwerer als von dem Retain and Release vorher auf ARK umzustellen, oder?
Das kann ich mir gut erinnern.
Garbage Collection fand ich immer blöd irgendwie. Hab ich gleich weggelassen.
Also das Einzige, was bei ARK relativ schwierig ist, ist, wenn du Core Foundation Objekte hast. Und die entsprechend zu bridgeen, das war, fand ich nicht so intuitiv.
Ja, aber gibt's auch Doku für steht alles da, was man machen muss.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall...
Und auch da räumen sie die API auf, indem sie halt Function Calls auch wirklich umbenennen, weil sie jetzt ja irgendwie, wenn ein...
Heute sind wir übrigens von euren...
Make-up vorkommt....
von euren TLA-Geschmeiße überfordert.
TLA-Geschmeiße?
Das haben wir hier aber schon alles ausführlich erklärt. Da sollen die Leute mal besser zuhören.
Nein, nein, nein.
Erstens haben wir immer wieder neue Leute und zweitens ist es eine Kunst, jedes Mal verstanden werden zu können.
Automatic Reference Counting ist der Weg, den Apple gewählt hat, um keine Garbage Collection auf dem iPhone zu brauchen. Und das ist quasi der Compiler für einen. Irgendjemand muss den Müll wegräumen. Entweder man macht selber den Speichermüll, das ist der klassische Weg, oder man lässt es zur Laufzeit die Garbage Collection machen. Das kostet es sehr bequem, kostet aber Zeit und macht das Telefon zum Beispiel spürobar langsamer, was man auf einem Android-Telefon so ein bisschen sieht. Das Gurgeln kommt unter anderem durch die Garbage Collection.
Das Zeitkosten wäre gar nicht so schlimm, aber es kostet eventuell dann Zeit, wenn man gerade keine hatte. Also es könnte in ungünstigen Momenten zuschlagen.
Und es schlägt halt automatisch zu und man hat es so relativ schlecht in der Kontrolle. Und jetzt hat Apple den, wie sie meinen, goldenen Wickelweg, Mittelweg gefunden, in dem sie einem das abnehmen, dieses Müll wegräumen, dieses Memory freiräumen, aber das halt zur Compile-Zeit machen. Also der Compiler baut die entsprechenden Befehle in den Code für einen ein, sodass das Telefon weiterhin schnell läuft, man schnell entwickelt und hoffentlich nicht so viele Probleme hat. War das okay erklärt? Der Goldene Wickelweg, wär auch ein schöner...
So viele Titel, so wenig Podcasts. So, wer so sagt, hat noch lange nicht fertig, aber ich glaube, wir sind trotzdem doch jetzt schon weit vorangeschritten, oder? Bevor wir jetzt hier neue Rekorde aufstellen. Oder wie sieht's bei euch aus, Jungs?
Wie neue Rekorde? Wir sind doch höchstens auch vier Stunden denn überhaupt. Nicht mal dreieinhalb, oder?
Was sagt denn der um?
Wo sind wir jetzt gerade?
Ist doch egal. Lass mich doch mal meine Brücken bauen.
Timme kann nicht mehr.
Ihr habt doch keine Themen mehr. Ihr redet doch nur noch Wörter.
Wir hatten von Anfang an keine Themen.
Also wird das jemals irgendwo von abgehalten.
Ich hatte Themen.
Ach, ich mach immer nur 8.
Als ob wir das nicht schon vorher gehabt hätten.
Ich hab mich da für euch geopfert.
Ja, wir sind dir unglaublich dankbar.
Aber die Pizzaschnittchen, die waren gut.
Also das nächste Mal wollen wir Microsoft-Pizzaschnittchen-XP-Service Pack 3 haben.
Also 8 Pizzaschnittchen-Preview will ich nicht.
Ausaufgabe Apple, zum nächsten Mal. Siegmeck-fickante Hardware-Rumors. Also jetzt ist MacBook Pro-Time, würde ich mal sagen. Und zwar MacBook Pro Air, was auch immer, neue MacBook Pros, I want to see it.
Mac Pros auch neu?
Mac Pros auch. Als ich hier meine Festplatte umgeschraubt hab, hab ich gesehen...
Mac Pro Mini. Ich will endlich einen Mac Pro Mini haben. Oder Mac Mini Pro meinetwegen auch.
Apple 15 Zoll MacBook Air. Das wünsch ich mir von dir. Mit 8 GB RAM Minimum eher 16.
Ich hätt gern MacBook Air 11 Zoll mit mindestens 3G, meinetwegen auch 4 oder 5G, was auch immer sie gerade noch im Regal haben. Hauptsache überhaupt irgendein G. Das wär angemessen.
Ja, und auf dem 11 Zoll ist ja vielleicht dritt in der Display auch eine greifbare Reichweite.
Und auf dem iPhone...
iOS 6?...
wär ich schon irgendwie glücklich, wenn sie das mal mit dem Podcast hinkriegen würden und wenn man mal das mit der Helligkeit ordentlich hinkriegt. Das wär auch mal geil, weil ich irgendwie jeden Tag morgens die Helligkeit raufdrehe und abends runterdrehe. Das kann aber nicht sein.
Stimmt, das geht mir auch so. Und was mich total nervt, also auf dem iPad hat man ja irgendwie, wenn man da diesen Doppelklick auf dem Home-Button macht, dann kriegt man die Leiste. Dann swipe man einmal nach links und dann hat man eine Lautspreche, einen Lautstärkeregler und einen Helligkeitsregler. Und das will ich fürs iPhone auch haben.
Du hast es aber nur für die Lautstärke.
Ja, aber nicht für die Helligkeit.
Aber Jungs, es redet von signifikanten Dingen.
Nein, besseres Sharing. Also bessere Dateiverwaltung zwischen Apps und dass man die Services besser nutzen kann und dass das alles mal vernünftig gelöst wird.
Multi-User. Das war ein Rumor, den ich gelesen habe. Den fand ich auch ganz interessant.
Hast du da von Marco Amendt die entsprechende Antwort gelesen, was der geschrieben hat? Leute, das ist eine Standard-Apple-Mail, wenn wir irgendwie einen Duplicate-Bug haben. Jemand anders hat das auch schon gesagt. Dann sagen wir immer, ja, unsere Entwickler sind gerade dran und kümmern sich um dieses Problem. Das ist einfach ein Bug, der ist offen, der wird niemals geschlossen.
Das ist mir auch egal.
Ich finde das Feature trotzdem cool. Du brauchst es trotzdem. Ich verstehe gar nicht, wie die Leute das machen. Wie soll ich denn so ein Kind so ein iPad überlassen, wenn dir dann als nächstes irgendwie in Mail reingeht und dann deine Mails beantwortet? Ja, zehn Jahre Mail-Folder löscht. Naja, ich meine, was ist das?
Das ist ein echtes Problem.
Ich weiß, was die Antwort von Apple auf diese Frage wäre. Die gleiche Antwort, die Dennis dir gibt.
Ja, und was machst du da mit Mail?
Das Kind hat sein eigenes Mail, da hast du dein iPad mit dem Mail und das Kind hat seine eigenen Mails. Wenn das Kind seine eigenen zehn Jahre Mail-Folder löscht, dann hat es kein Problem.
Aber ich will so ein Wohnzimmer-iPad haben, wo du das in so einen Spiel-Modus bringen kannst, und dann hier Kind Spiel und dann... Aber dann nicht für jeden. Dann hast du da einfach nur Hardware rumliegen, die nie benutzt wird.
Parental Controls oder so, wo man eben mal den Riegel vorschieben kann oder so was.
Ja, aber dann muss ich ja jedes Mal, wenn ich das Gerät weitergebe, immer wieder alle Settings ändern.
Das ist doch totaler Quatsch. Ich fände es auch geil mit Multi-User-iPad, weil man hat einfach in einem Haushalt mit einem iPad, mit mehreren Personen, immer unterschiedliche...
Das ist auch nicht so, dass dieses OS das nicht könnte. Das Gute ist, es ist jetzt nicht exposed, aber wie wir alle wissen, nicht das Problem.
Ja, aber ich meine, das nachträglich reinbauen ist nicht so schwierig, also Copy & Paste haben sie auch hingekriegt und da war ja auch vorher so. Ist ja nicht so, dass das OS das nicht könnte. Sie machen es ja genauso wie unter normalem Coco mit dem Pasteboard.
Sag mal, Jungs, Timme, welchem Irg-Channel oder Irg-Server benutzt du da?
Das ist ein Netz-Split.
Nee, meine Sachen kommen da schon, aber irgendwie drei Minuten später.
Geh mal raus und wieder rein.
Irg-Free-Note? Wieso ich denn? Aber ich bin auch mal Irg-Free-Note net.
Ja, du bist ja da auf DNS-Round-Drop-Inn, auf unterschiedlichste Server geleitet.
Na toll, ich muss jetzt wieder raus und rein gehen.
Also ich war grad auch irgendwie disconnected, komplett von der einen Hälfte des Chats und...
Nee, aber mein Zeug ist ja gekommen, nur halt verzögert.
Ich hab aber Free-Note gespendet, ja. Ich hab hier im Irg, hab ich glaub ich auch immer noch in der User-Liste mein Who-Is auf PDCP-Supporter oder so gestellt bekommen. Ja, vom Free-Note-Netzwerk. Sehr schön. Was? Wenn du jetzt über meinen Nick scrollst, dann steht halt nicht... Doch, steht meine IP. Nee, haben sie wieder ausgebaut. Die Schweine. Irgendwann hast du, wenn du gespendet hast, hast du so ein Special-Hostname und Dingsport-Who-Is gekriegt. Also wenn ihr euch über Free-Note beschwert, geht einfach mal spenden.
Du bist dabei über IPv6 drin.
Wir schreiben einfach, Irkserver und Erlang.
Geil, das ist wirklich das, das muss man auf jeden Fall direkt mal in jeder neuen Sprache nochmal durchexerziert sind, Irkserver zu schreiben.
Klar man, die können das ja anscheinend alle nicht.
Irkprotokoll, na gut, vielleicht.
Ich bin irgendwie, ich bin nicht so ein Mensch, der so an diese Theorie glaubt. Es ist schon dreißigmal probiert worden und hat nicht so hundertprozentig geklappt. Bestimmt wird es beim 31. Mai jetzt auf Anhieb perfekt sein.
Also vor allen Dingen hab ich nicht so die Motivation, große Teile meiner Lebenszeit auf das Problem Irkserver zu schmeißen.
Also ein paar Nachrichten hin und her rufen. Weißt du, wer so den Track angefangen hat? Ich kam an und meinte so, sag mal, dieses Tracker ist doch, eigentlich ist das doch nur HDTV, oder? Dann hab ich Ja gesagt und ein paar Tage später war er fertig.
Aber bei BitTorrent ist das Informations-Set, was da ausgedacht wurde, ist wirklich sehr minimal. Das muss man schon sagen. Aber bei Irk, ich bin mir sicher, da gibt es so einen ganzen Herrscher von irgendwelchen nicht dokumentierten Erweitern.
Genau und den ganzen Scheiß, den lässt man erstmal weg, damit man erstmal eine saubere Neuimplementation hat.
Vor allen Dingen, wie viele Leute hier hinten dran immer inkompatible Kodierung dranhängen haben.
UTF-8 im Irk, don't get me started.
Wie, das ist nur UTF-8?
Ich wurde aus Channels rausgeschmissen, weil ich UTF-8 benutzt habe.
Wieso das denn?
Ja, weil du halt unter Linux kannst du das halt irgendwie, weiß ich auch nicht, hat sich das noch nicht so richtig rumgesprochen.
Also wir vergehen uns jetzt zum unqualifizierten Rand. Liebe Zuhörer, wenn ihr abschalten wollt, es kommen glaube ich auch nichts interessantes mehr.
Ich dachte, der fängt nach dem Jingle an.
Wir warten jetzt nur noch bis alle Line-Updates durch sind.
Wenn ihr jetzt noch zuhört, dann seid ihr, wenn du jetzt noch zuhörst, dann bist du ein hoffnungsloser Fan.
Du meinst der hier da?
500 Knapp hören wir noch zu.
Du würdest doch auch noch zuhören, wenn wir über Ponys reden.
Nicht mehr lange. Also mein Line-Update ist durch.
Ich war ja der erste, glaube ich. So, RCA UTF8-Updates.
Ja, es gibt es, es gab. Mittlerweile ist das bestimmt auch schon zwei Jahre her, aber ich bin in Irk-Channels rein und hab dann einfach so SZ und Ö und Ü und so einfach in UTF8-Mese geschrieben und dann sind die ja total ausgerastet. Das geht ja irgendwie gar nicht und wie könnte ich nur? Dann hab ich mich gleich erstmal auf die Irk-Channel FAQ im Web verwiesen, wo dann erstmal die Regeln drinstehen, dass man da bitteschön auch keinen UTF8 benutzen soll. Wer hat das Ascii benutzt?
Isolatin irgendwas?
Was weiß ich, was die da erzählt haben. Und dann hab ich bestimmt eine Stunde oder so mich mit den so ein bisschen mit zweimal Kicken angelegt und denen mal erklärt, dass UTF8 ja wohl eine total sinnvolle Idee wäre. Jetzt wird es vielleicht richtig peinlich, wenn ich erzähle, dass der CCC-Channel war.
Aber aus dem bin ich auch schon mal rausgeflogen, weil ich nicht Hallo gesagt habe.
Hier siehst du UTF8-Kekse ohne Vorwarnung nebenan in bsdforum.de. Die Deutschen haben es bestimmt. Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, oder?
Ich meine, wir klicken jetzt mal da drauf.
Ich glaube, bei ccc.de haben sie es mittlerweile akzeptiert, dass es besser ist, vielleicht doch mal UTF8 zu benutzen. Aber ich habe diese Diskussion im Irk schon zwei oder dreimal, also nicht nur in ccc.de geführt.
Ach, gerade die Fraktionen, die den anderen immer mangelnde Modernität vorwerfen, an sowas scheitern wie moderne Zeitungen.
Vor allen Dingen hast du eine Sprache wie Deutsch mit Umlauten und SZ, und du könntest es, es gibt keinen technischen Grund, warum nicht einfach alle ihren Scheißkleint auf UTF8 stellen.
Doch, weil wir das schon seit 30 Jahren so und so gemacht haben.
Weil die das nicht können, Mann.
Man hätte das 8te Bit nie ins Beid nehmen können.
Ein lustiges Animates Gift, wo so zwei Typen im Büro sitzen und der eine sagt 100 110 110 und dann sagt der andere 1100 110 und dann krachen sie sich total weg. Das ist so ein Gift, das ist auch, das war genau sowas hier gerade. Wahrscheinlich die Hälfte der Hörer.
Ja, dieses 8te Bit, das war aber. Seitdem ging es bergab, das stimmt.
Wer hat sich das nur ausgedacht?
Habt ihr eigentlich gewusst, dass man sein iPhone blinken lassen kann, wenn man eine SMS bekommt oder eine iMessage?
Ja, das nervt total.
Kannst du auch wieder ausschalten?
Das lässt du bald wieder sein. Ja, wenn du dann noch weißt, wo du das Setting einstellst.
Das ist ganz fies, das ist nicht bei Messages versteckt, sondern bei Accessibility. Ich find's cool, mein iPhone kann sozusagen auf dem Display liegen und dann seh ich halt, wenn's blinkt, dass da was kam.
Schöner Chatbeitrag zum Thema UTF-8. Für die Hörer, die das jetzt leider...
Jetzt liest mal vor, jetzt liest mal vor.
Für die Hörer, die Sendungen als Aufzeichnung hören. Das ist jetzt wieder so eine Stelle, wo es sich doch wieder lohnt, die Live-Sendung zu hören, damit man live im Chat auch die ganzen lustigen Beiträge mithören kann.
Da hat er ja mal so ein T-Shirt, wo drauf stand, scheiß Encoding.
Jaja, Encoding. Echt, das könnte alles so schön sein. Ich mein, sogar MySQL kriegt das mittlerweile hin.
Stimmt, und die hatten lange, hatten hier schwedisches Encoding.
Die fangen jetzt an, diesen komischen BSD vor, an die e-Chat zu trollen.
Hinein ins Vergnügen, auf sie mitgebrüllt. Wie wär's denn mit so einem Härtchen oder dem Schneemann oder so? Irgendwie sucht euch mal ein paar wilde Charaktere aus und macht sie mal richtig fertig jetzt hier.
Lachen zwar mit BSD-Forum, oder?
bsdforum.de, ich poste mal den Snowman.
bsdforum.de Bin ich erinnernlicher.
Ist dir die Partie?
Jetzt mal die ganzen Emojis reinkicken. Jetzt schickt auch mal ein paar bunte Characters. Öffnet den Character-Viewer und geht mal richtig ab hier.
Live-Kommentar, wir sind gerade alle in der BSD-Forren und alle posten nur halt Zeug mit Umlaufen. Der Autobot sagt die ganze Zeit, es ist kaputt.
Ich hab noch was Schönes. Das hat mir ein Kollege neu gezeigt, der Japanisch lernt und wenn man hier auf die japanische Tastatur umschaltet, die sich eingestellt hat auf dem iPhone, dann hat man hier eine eigene Taste mit nur ausschließlich Seitenweisen, wirklich Seitenweisen verschiedenen Emojis zum schnell auswählen. Das ist echt irre. Das könnte man jetzt auch zum Beispiel in den Chatband werfen.
Man kann diese Emoji-Tastatur anschalten.
Nein, nicht die Emoji-Tastatur.
Geil finde ich halt diesen Account, der sich da beschwert.
Andersfalls wären wir unmöglich. Analtux.
Was wolltest du uns denn damit sagen? Du willst es gar nicht wissen. Oh Gott, die Bilder!
Hier Tim, klick mal auf.
Was ist denn ISO 88 59 15?
ISO 88 59 15 ist eine Variante von ISO 88 59 1, das ist nämlich Latent 1.
Aber?
Plus Eurozeichen.
Und warum nimmt man den und nicht UTF-8?
Weil man den halt in 8-Bit darstellen kann. Und UTF-8 ist halt Variable Length. Deswegen passt das halt nicht in Cinq Coda.
Ich verstehe, die ganzen BSD-Typis haben natürlich irgendwie noch den Uzi oder irgendein komisches Ding am Start und er kann das nicht, oder wie?
Tim, klick mal kurz hier auf dieses Bild, was ich gerade in den falschen Chat gepackt hast.
Eher nicht egal, aber das ist Analtox, ne?
Erzähl doch mal, was das mit diesem Snowman auf sich hat, weil der auch so gerade mal durchging. Bei Rails gibt es da auch diesen Snowman, der sich über euren Flügel fliegt.
Das ist aber niemand in diesem Chat, der sich ärgert, außer Analtox.
Ja, kannst du mal sehen, die sind nämlich alle schon tot. Also eigentlich bin ich ja BSD-Fan, aber die müssen auch mal ein bisschen moderner werden.
Wahrscheinlich gehört es uns gerade selbst hier.
Aber wir haben viel Spaß dabei.
So was wir jetzt machen, ist das, ich hab das glaube ich mal gepostet, das ist so ein kurzes Bild über so ein Chat-Log, wo einer sagt irgendwie Ficken und dann wird er von dem Chatbot rausgeschmissen. Danach ändert der Typ seinen Namen in Ficken um, postet wieder was und dann sagt der Chatbot wieder, spricht ihm unter seinem Namen Ficken an, merkt dann, dass er selber Ficken gesagt hat und kickt sich selber raus. Das könnte man mit dem Analtox jetzt auch machen. Du musst ja eigentlich nur einen Usernamen geben, mit einem Umlaut drin.
Ja, probier das mal.
Jetzt hier, nächster Level.
Ja, aber der kickt dir nicht, der nervt dir nur rum.
Ja, aber dann spricht er mit sich selbst und dann luptert er.
Kann man sich einen Usernamen mit Umlaut geben?
Keine Ahnung.
Probier es doch mal aus.
Also hier, so ein DIA-C-Noop, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie ich das mache.
Ich bin mir sicher, am Ende. Flash Nick, Fraktur Freak, muss es wissen, dass es nicht geht. Der hat auch einen Blog, wo er die ganze Zeit ein merkwürdiges App stattfindet. Achso, ja, so ein irgendwie anderes S, was irgendwie merkwürdig ist.
Dein Charset ist kaputt, sag ich nur.
Aber auch ungemütlich, noch schön mit Ue.
Und das in deinem BSD-Forum. Vor allen Dingen ist kaputt.
So dieses, es gibt nichts anderes, außer dem. Wer Chinesisch schreibt, ist noch...
Ist dein Chefkleid abgestürzt?
Genug Spaß.
Also wir sind immer noch bei stolzen 420 hier. Die Leute wollen mehr.
Wir haben nicht mehr.
Ach, jetzt kramen wir.
Was machen wir eigentlich zu unserer 100. Sendung?
Vielleicht machen wir die doch mal live oder sowas.
Gerade 87 machen wir ja gerade.
Wie wärs denn noch mit einer Live-Sendung? Dann zur 100.
Wir machen doch gerade eine Live-Sendung.
Nicht nicht so kleindenken. Wann wärs denn?
Das BCC ist frei dann. Bis dahin könnte der Apple Store öffnet sein.
Oder wir machen es auf dem Berliner Flughafen.
Apple Store geht nicht voran in Berlin.
Nichts geht voran in Berlin.
Ja ich weiß nicht ganz genau. Ich meine, jetzt haben wir...
20.12.
Wenn wir so zwei Sendungen hinkriegen.
Zwei Sendungen?
Ja, ich versuche gerade mal so ein bisschen auszurechnen, wann das so wäre. 90 ist für Ende Juni und dann hätten wir noch 10. Das sind immerhin noch fünf Monate. Also Juli, August. Ja, so im November.
Live-Sendungen in Saal 1 im BCC.
Oder wir sind nackt einfach.
Wie immer, oder?
Noch nackt?
Genau.
Ach, wir waren ja eigentlich neulich mit Kamerateam und so. Da war ich ja nicht da.
Und Spectacool, würde ich mal sagen. Dann halt da mit ihrer Kamera.
Das ist das mit dem Channel-Bot, der da den User kicken will und dann selber fliegt.
Ach, das ist doch ein...
Ist da eine urbanen Legende genauso, mit dem Droptable-Kennzeichen und so.
So, es franzt aus. Wenn wir jetzt kein überzeugendes Argument mehr haben, weiter zu senden, würde ich sagen...
Die Uhr läuft.
Geben wir dem Ganzen jetzt hier mal den Stiefel.
Aufwachen.
Na dann, würde ich sagen, hören wir uns in zwei Wochen wieder.
Auf eurer Apple-Uhr.
That's what we have for you today. Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.
So, und jetzt...
Das heißt ja nicht umsonst... Bum, zack, return.